WE OBVIOUSLY --
IF -- IF
YOU'RE COUNTING LIKE ME --
YOU KNOW THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET --
SO WE WILL --
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST
PRESENTATION FROM A WE HA THAT'S
A HOLD OPEN ITEM --
WILL HOLD THE THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR UNTIL WE DO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
AND I JUST WANT --
TO ANNOUNCED NOW AND ALL MAKE
THE ANNOUNCEMENT AGAIN THAT --
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION ISSUES
TWO THREE AND FOUR ARE GOING TO
BE MOVED TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR. TWO THREE TWO THREE
AND FOUR UNDER DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION AS OUR FOLKS FROM
WHAT WE HIGH HERE.
GOOD MORNING CAN REFERENCE.
GOOD MORNING HOW ARE YOU.
GOOD MORNING WE'RE DOING FINE.
GO RIGHT AHEAD.
OKAY WELL GOOD MORNING --
MY NAME IS ALAN HER SHINE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE OFFICE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT.
AND WITH ME HERE IS MIKE
JURICKSON OUR ADMIN CHIEF AND
SAM DEL SEND OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR EXTERNAL AFFAIRS --
IT IS HE WANTED JUST A QUICK
OVERVIEW OF OUR ITEMS YES LOOK
AT SO -- AB
SIX SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS ENACTED
IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REQUIRES THE
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD IN CONSULTATION WITH.
THE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH HAZARD AS SUFFICE.
IT ENTITIES. TO DEPLOY A
COMMUNITY AIR MONITORING SYSTEMS
AND DEVELOP EMISSION REDUCTION
PLANS.
IN IN MOSTLY LOW INCOME CUT
MUNITY SPATTER IMPACTED BY --
AIR POLLUTION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
YEAH AND AS THE BILL'S
IMPLEMENTATION HAS PROGRESSED.
CARP HAS --
RECOGNIZE THAT THE CONCERNS OF
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE EMPHASIZED
THE IMPORTANCE OF CONSIDERING
HEALTH IMPACTS IN THE BILL'S
ACTIVITIES.
M. THAT FORMS THE BASIS FOR A
WEEK BECAUSE ROLE IN A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN ACTIVITIES GET GIVEN
THAT OUR CORE EXPERTISE.
IS IN THE EVALUATION OF THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
POLLUTANTS --
SO -- WE HA.
IS REQUESTING FOR PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IN
ANNUAL CONTRACTS --
FOR A TOTAL OF NINE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND --
TO SUPPORT CARP LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS AND IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN I WANT TO NOTE
THAT OUR DIRECTOR DR LAWRENCE
ISIS JUST SHOWED UP.
BOB SELF GOOD MORNING I CAN
FINISH THE INTRODUCTION I GUESS
OKAY.
SO THEM THE REQUESTED --
WE HOUSE STAFF AND CONTRACT
FUNDS WILL PROVIDE BASICALLY
THREE THINGS ONE IS EXPERTISE IN
THE INTERPRETATION OF POTENTIAL
HEALTH EFFECTS.
THAT MAY RESULT FROM EXPOSURES
TO AIR --
TOXICS OBSERVED THROUGH THE AIR
QUALITY MONITORING DATA AND THE
EVALUATION OF POTENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS FROM REDUCING THOSE HE
MISSIONS.
IN OTHER WORDS PEOPLE WHEN THEY
GET INFORMATION ON WHAT'S IN THE
AIR THAT THEY'RE BREATHING
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO KNOW
WHAT ARE THE HEALTH OF FACTS.
AND AS THOSE LEVELS ARE REDUCED
WATER THE HEALTH --
WHAT ARE THE HEALTH BENEFITS AND
WE WILL?
WE WILL PLAY A BIG ROLE IN
DETERMINING THAT.
SECOND OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HEALTH GUIDANCE VALUES THAT ARE
NEEDED TO FULLY ANALYZE.
THE BE --
HEALTH EFFECTS AND BENEFITS OF
REDUCE.
OF THOSE POLLED LIEUTENANTS --
AND BY HEALTH GUIDES VALUES WE
ME NUMBERS THAT WE DEVELOP
THROUGH WE'VE THIRD THIRD RUI
VALUATIONS.
THAT TYPICALLY IDENTIFIED LEVELS
OF LEVELS OF AIR POLLUTANTS THAT
DO NOT POSE HEALTH RISKS AND SO
IF THE IF THE LEVELS ARE ABOVE
THAT -- IT
GENERALLY.
RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
THOSE HEALTH RISKS ARE.
SO -- THERE
IS -- WE
WILL BE TO DEVELOPING HEALTH
GUIDANCE VALUES WHERE WE NEED TO
AND THIRD.
THE I'M DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF TARGETED BY A
MONITORING STUDIES --
TO TRACK EXPOSURES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
AND BIO MONITORING PROVIDES
INFORMATION ON THE LEVELS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL CHEMICALS IN
PEOPLE.
AND IT'S A DIRECT MEASUREMENT OF
YOU -- TO TO
ENVIRONMENTAL CHEMICALS.
ADDED ANSWERS SORT OF THE
OBVIOUS QUESTION IF I KNOW
WHAT'S IN THE AIR WHAT'S GETTING
INSIDE ME.
AND THESE STUDIES SO THEN WILL
HELP COMPLEMENT INVALIDATE THE
AIR MONITORING.
IN N V. SELECTED CUB UNITIES AN
INCREASE THE UNDERSTANDING OF
EXPOSURES OF POTENTIAL HEALTH
RISKS THAT THE RESIDENTS MAY
FACE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM --
SEEING NONE THE WE HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION FROM STAFF TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPENED --
AT AT AND AND WE WILL WHAT STOP
DOESN'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
CONCERNS.
IT'S THE EXPENDITURE OF G. G. R.
F. FUNDS AND ARE NOT KNOWING.
HOW MUCH IS GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE ON HOW THAT POT IS ALL
GONNA GET DIVVIED UP THAT --
A RESULTS IN THE HOLD OPEN --
A RECOMMENDATION MS GARCIA DID
YOU HAVE A QUESTION --
CRY DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION
ACTUALLY SO I APPRECIATE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE HEALTH
IMPACTS AND WITH WITHIN THE
SPREAD OF OF AB AND IN THE MIGHT
NOT BE TNC MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
ANSWER IT ABOUT.
WHERE ARE WE AT WITH ACTUALLY
MONITORING THESE --
TOXICS YOU KNOW AND SO ARE WE
GETTING AHEAD OF OURSELVES A
LITTLE BIT OUT THERE AND AND I
KNOW THAT THAT'S THE AIR B. AND
THERE DISTRICTS OUT THERE BUT
I'M NOT I FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
WE HAVEN'T STARTED MONITORING.
YET.
THAT THAT THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING YES THAT'S REALLY
CARBS AREA I KNOW THEY'VE
SELECTED THE TEN COMMUNITIES
HAVE THEY'RE PUTTING TOGETHER
MONITORING PLANS IS IT JULY I
THINK IS THE TENTATIVE.
START DATE I DON'T KNOW THAT
TENTATIVE START DATE BUT I KNOW
THAT THEY'RE ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH THE DISTRICTS TO PUT
TOGETHER MONACAN HEADLAND SO I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING AND THAT YOU'RE GETTING
READY I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE GETTING READY AND
OTHER GROUPS ARE FALLING.
BEHIND IN YOU'RE ABLE TO DO YOUR
WORK ON TIME.
WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH KERR
BAND THE AIR DISTRICTS YES.
EXCELLENT IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING THAT --
I'M SORRY MS RANTS.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION I KNOW THE
TO BE SELECTING MORE OR MORE
SPEAK TO ME SHE'S WILL BE
SELECTED IN.
THE COMING YEARS.
SHOULD WE BE EXPECTING A BE A
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST EVERY
TIME NEW COMMUNITIES ARE
SELECTED --
WELL AGAIN CARP IS THE LEAD
AGENCY OF MASS AYE I THINK WE
FEEL THAT --
THAT ARCHED THAT VIçT WELL
THAT THESE ARE THE RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED.
TO PROVIDE THE NEEDED CAUGHT
CONSULTATION FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
YES THEY SEE THIS IS ONGOING --
AND THAT --
SHOULD WE BE.
BUYING THAT WE NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT WE WOULD APPROACH
IT BUT RIGHT NOW THIS.
SEEMS LIKE THE RIGHT AMOUNT. FOR
IT BUT ONGOING YEARLY --
WITH INCREASING COMMUNITIES
COMING INTO THE SYSTEM SO
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
WHY DON'T WE --
ESTABLISH QUORUM AND THEN WILL.
DEAR PRISON PRESENTATION WILL
FALL WITHIN THE OFFICIAL PART OF
OUR MEETING OF BLOOM.
HERE FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON RADIUS.
REVERSE.
HER RIGHT THANK YOU AND NOW WILL
OFFICIALLY HOLD THAT OVER THE
NEXT -- A
TIME WE DRESS YOUR DEPARTMENT
AND LET'S GO BACK TO THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR NOW I MADE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT EARLIER AND I
SHOULD WELCOME EVERYBODY HAD AND
SAY.
HELLO AND GOOD MORNING TO TO ALL
OF YOU AND WELCOME. TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE.
ITEMS SAID TWO THREE AND FOUR
UNDER DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
ARE BEING MOVED INTO THE VOTE
ONLY -- A
CALENDAR WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
SEPARATE VOTE ON ISSUE ONE SO --
LET'S DO THAT FIRST [inaudible]
MISSION [inaudible]
GOING YES.
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES IN THIS ARTICLE ARE FOR THE
MOTION IS TO IT'S DIFFERENT FROM
A FROM USUAL IT'S TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE
THERE ARE SOME SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS --
THAT YOU'LL FIND IN YOUR AGENDA.
HELLO.
HI FONG GARCIA HI MULLIN
PATTERSON RAY YES.
REVERSE.
AND THEN THE I'D ENTERTAIN A
MOTION --
FOR ISSUES TWO THROUGH SEVEN
THAT ARE ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR AND ISSUES --
TWO THREE AND FOUR THAT WERE
UNDER ITEMS TO BE HEARD IN THAT
HAVE BEEN MOVED TO VOTE ONLY.
BLOOM HI FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON REYES SIDE
REVERSE.
THANK YOU THAT MOVES US ON TO
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION.
AND IF I COULD ASK YOU --
TO BRIEFLY PRESENT --
TO YOUR TO I I I DO ONCE HAD OR
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
BCP'S BUT I AM CONCERNED TED
THAT THERE APPEARS TO BE A
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE WITHIN THE
PESTICIDE REGULATION FUND AND IT
APPEARS THAT EXPENDITURES ARE
GREATER THAN REVENUES.
AND HAVE BEEN FOR SOME TIME NOW --
ABSENT ANY ACTION --
FURTHER ACTION OF THE BUDGET
APPEARS THAT THE FUND IS GOING
TO BE IN THE RED SO IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS WHETHER --
THERE'S A PLAN TO CORRECT THIS --
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
YES SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US HERE TODAY MY NAME IS THERESA
MARKS ON THE ACTING DIRECTOR AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION AND I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY JESSE QUITE THIS HE WAS
ONE OF OUR SYSTEM DIRECTORS --
AT AT LIKE TO START WITH JUST A
BRIEF OVER VIEW IF I CAN'T ABOUT
THE DEPARTMENT SURE --
OUR MISSION IS TO PROTECT HUMAN
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT BY
REGULATING PESTICIDES SALES AND
USE ABOUT FOSTERING REDUCE RISK
PEST MANAGEMENT.
WE ALSO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT FOR
LOCAL PESTICIDE ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS IN ALL OF ALL FIFTY
FIVE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND THEIR COMPOUND
STAFF OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY BIOLOGIST.
OUR PROPOSED TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET IS A HUNDRED TEN
MILLION AND THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT POSITIONS WHICH
INCLUDE TO BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS REQUESTING FOR
POSITIONS.
KNOCK OVER THOSE VERY BRIEFLY
NOW OUR FIRST B. C. P. IS --
A IS UP FOR A POSITION OR
INFORMATION SECURITY TEAM IT'S A
REQUEST FOR FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
TWENTY AND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX THOUSAND FOR ON GOING COST
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FROM DPR.
FUND TO COMPLY WITH STATE
REQUIRE SEVENTY SECURITY
ASSESSMENT REMEDIATION AND CLOUD
MIGRATION SECURITY HARDWARE
SOFTWARE AND SERVICES.
WITH THE ADDITION OF THREE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SPECIALIST TO FUNCTION AS ITS
INFORMATION SECURITY TEAM DPR
WILL BE BETTER SITUATED TO MEET
THESE NEW SECURITY REQUIREMENTS.
THE SECOND B. C. P. RESULTS FROM
A BILL THAT WILL --
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT ST
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN AND THAT
WAS PASSED LAST YEAR REQUEST A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE DPR FUND
ANNUALLY. FOR TWO YEARS TO
IMPLEMENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN REQUIRES DPR TO SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE BY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO EVALUATE THE IMPLEMENTATION
AFFECT.
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND EFFICACY OF
THE HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT.
AND I KNOW --
CHAIRMAN BLAMED YOU WOULD LIKE
TO LOOK AT THE ADDRESSING THE
DEFICIT --
OR WHAT LOOKS LIKE --
A DECLINING INCOME IN OUR BUDGET
FIND AND WE'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT
OR TAKE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THE VERY SPECIFICALLY IF WE KNOW
THAT THE THE RESERVE.
WENT FROM FOURTEEN MILLION.
TO SEVEN TWO THREE FROM.
SEVENTEEN TO NINETEEN IS THERE
SOMETHING PLANNED IT. TO TO TAKE
CARE THAT STRUCTURAL PROBLEM
[inaudible]
DO YOU.
GOOD MORNING THE JULIANNA MOORE
IS A ME WITH FINANCE SO AT THE
TIME OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE
HAD SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS THAT
WERE USING THE FUND AS WELL AS
DPR.
DEBT HADN'T CLOSE THEIR BOOKS
YET.
SO WHAT YOU SEE WHAT YOU SAW ON
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR BASED
ON ESTIMATES.
AND IT DID NOT INCLUDE ANY OF
THE ADJUSTMENTS FOR TWENTY
SIXTEEN SINCE THEN WE'VE UPDATED
THE THE FUND CONDITION AND FOR
MORE THAN HAPPY TO SHARE THAT WE
SHARE THAT WITH THE CONSULTANTS.
EARLIER IT WAS JUST YESTERDAY
BECAUSE WE JUST GOT THE
INFORMATION PUT THROUGH SO WE
HAVE SO THERE WAS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A COP OKAY I
CAN.
YES SO ARE YOU CAN YOU GIVE US
THE NUMBERS IN IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WE HAVE A PRIOR YEAR
ADJUSTMENT OF EIGHT POINT NINE
MILLION.
AND SO THEN THE FUND AT THE END
OF NINETEEN TWENTY THE BALANCE
IS ACTUALLY TEN PUT LITTLE OVER
IT'S ALMOST TEN POINT SIX
MILLION.
SO WHETHER STILL IS A STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE WITH THE EXPENDITURES
EXCEEDING THE REVENUES.
WE HAVE SOME TIME TO SEE HOW THE
MAIL MIL TAX AND EVERYTHING
WORKS OUT IT'S WITHIN A 5% --
TOLERANCE LEVEL [inaudible]
AND JUST. TO GIVE YOU SOME SOME
CONTEXT ON THAT LARGE IT SEEMS
LIKE A LARGE --
PRIOR YEAR ADJUSTMENT THAT'S
BASED ON TWO YEARS.
AND BECAUSE OF THE TIMING OF
OKAY CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
BECAUSE IT IT STARTED BOGGLING
MY MIND.
THE WAIT THE THE MILL TAX WHERE
MIL FEE IS CALCULATED.
IS NOT BASED ON A CALENDAR A
YEAR SO IT'S IT HAS A MARCH CUT
OFF DATE.
SO TRYING.
TO COORDINATE THAT AND ROLL OVER
INTO THE NEW FISCAL SYSTEM IT
WAS A TIMING ISSUE.
CAN YOU GIVE ME THE UPDATED
NUMBERS THEN YOU SAY FLOW.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THERE'S AN
ADJUSTMENT OF EIGHT POINT NINE
SO RIGHT SORT OF THE NEW NUMBER
SO THAT GIVES --
A RESERVE OF TWENTY POINT SEVEN
MILLION. TWENTY TWENTY POINT.
SEVEN AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LOOKS LIKE IT
WOULD BE A THIRTEEN POINT
ROUGHLY THIRTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION.
AND THEN NINETEEN TWENTY IS TEN
POINT SIX CORRECT.
SO WE LOST ABOUT TEN MILLION IN
THE TWO YEAR PERIOD AND PART OF
THIS TOO IS DANIEL SEE THIS IN
OTHER BUDGETS AS WELL WHEN WE
HAVE THE THE PENSION PREPAYMENT.
THIS IS THIS IS PAYING BACK THAT.
SO IT'S HITTING ALL OF THE
SPECIAL FUNDS --
OFF ALL FUNDS ALL THE WAY AROUND
ACTUALLY HOW OFTEN DOES THE
DEPARTMENT FORECAST FUTURE
REVENUES AND HOW MANY YEARS
AHEAD.
DOESN'T DEPARTMENTS PROJECT.
WE HAD --
LESLIE YOU MAY WANT TO COMMIT TO
THAT ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT.
I THINK WE PROJECT AT LEAST TWO
YEARS OUT AND MAYBE --
THREE WESLEY CAN ADDRESS THAT
FOR SURE.
HI LESLIE FORD --
I'M THE FISCAL OFFICER AT THE
DEPARTMENT --
GENERALLY REYES WE FORECAST A
FIVE YEAR FUND CONDITION.
SEE FORECAST FIVE YEARS OUT.
AND WHEN YOU FORECAST TO FIVE
YEARS OUT DID YOU HAVE AN IDEA
THAT YOU WERE TWO YEARS BEHIND
ON THIS ALL MALE OR THE MILL TAX.
CALCULATION IT'S IT'S HARD TO
UNDERSTAND.
AND ALMOST NINE MILLION
ADJUSTMENT.
THERE WOULD BE FROM TWO YEARS
PRIOR.
SO HELP ME TO UNDERSTAND THAT --
WAS WHAT OCCURRED WAS WHAT --
JULIE ON I HAD SPOKEN TO IS THAT
WHEN WE TRANSFERRED OVER FROM --
THAT CAL STAR SYSTEM THE
ACCOUNTING SO.
THAT'S WHERE IT APPEARED IN THE
TRANSITION SO THE WAY WE
REVENUES WERE RECORDED IN ONE
SYSTEM WAS DIFFERENT AND IN THE
FISCAL SYSTEMS.
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE EIGHT POINT
NINE MILLION BACK TO THE PATENT.
THAT'S A LARGE ADJUSTMENT.
BUT THEN FROM THERE.
THERE WAS A SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT THE FOLLOWING YEAR AND
IT CONTINUES.
SO THERE'S CLEARLY A STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE IN THE DEPARTMENT.
HOW IS HOW ARE YOU PLANNING FOR
THE FUTURE SO THAT YOU DON'T END
UP IN THE RENT?
SO WE HAVE BEEN MONITORING THE
FUND OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
AND WE HAVE BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION TO THAT STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE AND MAKING SURE THAT --
WE ARE --
MONITORING THE MAIL.
I'M SORRY FOR INTERRUPTING
BESIDES MONITORING WHAT IS BEING
DONE SPECIFICALLY.
BECAUSE MONITORING.
STILL GIVES US FROM TWENTY DOWN
TO THIRTEEN DOWN TO TEN AND
WE'RE GOING IN A DOWNWARD SPIRAL.
AND IN JUST A FEW YEARS I
THOUGHT IS GOING TO BE IN ONE
YEAR BUT NOW WITH TEN POINT SIX
IT'LL TAKE A LITTLE LONGER.
BUT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE HEADING TO
THE RED.
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO PLAN TO
NOT JUST MONITOR BUT TO PLAN TO
MAKE SURE YOU DON'T END UP IN
THE REST?
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IT IS CONCERNING WHEN YOU
LOOK WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT BUT I
THINK THE MYUNDERSTANDING IS
BEEN NOT BEEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT NOW FOR THREE ALMOST
THREE YEARS.
MY UNDERSTANDING HAS BEEN THAT
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL FOR US TO RUN
AT THIS TYPE OF STRUCTURAL --
DEFICIENCY IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
UNUSUAL TO HAVE THE BALANCE
GOING DOWN --
WE HAVE WE THINGS THAT WE DO IN
OUR OFFICE IS PLAN YEARS AHEAD
STRATEGICALLY.
AND WE LOOK AT WHAT TYPE OF
PROGRAMS WE CAN OFFER AND WHAT
TYPE OF THAT MONEY WE MAY HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS IN THE OFFICE --
WE WILL BE MONITORING THAT VERY
CLOSELY THE SPENDING OF THOSE
TYPES OF ODD --
MATTERS THAT BASICALLY WE LIKE
TO HAVE THAT ARE NOT NECESSARY
TO THE CORE OPERATIONS OF THE
PROGRAM SO THAT WILL WORK WILL
BE HAVE TO WILL HAVE TO LOOK AT
THAT VERY CLOSELY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
RUN INTO PROBLEMS.
WHO IS IT IN THE DEPARTMENT THAT
WOULD BE LOOKING AT THIS?
AND WOOD SOUNDS OF THE ALARM
SAYING THIS DOES NOT LOOK GOOD
WHETHER WE LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
BEFORE GOING FROM.
FOURTEEN TO SEVEN TO THREE TO
FOUR AND NOW IT'S TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN TO SIX THERE IS A THAT
THE IT'S AND WE'RE NOT HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THE NUMBERS THAT YOU SAW BEFORE
WAS ACTUALLY NOT OUR DPR FUND
THOSE NUMBERS WERE OUR OUR
REGULAR RAZOR.
WHEN I WAS AROUND REGISTRATION
FIND AND SO IT DIDN'T COVER ALL
OF OUR FUNDS ACTUALLY SO THERE
WERE SOME ISSUES THERE --
BUT WE HAVE OF COURSE WE HAVE
OUR PHYSICAL CHIEF WHO'S HERE WE
HAVE AT THE DIRECTOR WHENEVER
THE NEW DIRECTORS NINE WILL
CERTAINLY BE LOOKING AT THE FIND
I LOOK AT THE FINE I'M THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR NORMALLY AND I
LOOK AT THE FUND --
WE HAVE WE WATCH THE BUDGET FUND
CLOSELY --
WE HAVE REGULAR MEETINGS ON THE
SPENDING THE AND I PERHAPS I'M
ASKING THE RIGHT WRONG QUESTION.
BESIDES MONITORING WHAT IS BEING
DONE TO PLAN.
BECAUSE WE'RE HEADED IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION.
THAT IS MY QUESTION NOT JUST THE
MONITORING BECAUSE I'M SURE YOU
SAW THE NUMBERS AND YOU CAN
MONITOR AND SEE THAT IT'S GOING
DOWN.
WHAT SPECIFICALLY IS BEING DONE
TO PLAN SO THAT THE NUMBERS
DON'T GO DOWN BUT RATHER GO UP
OR REMAIN STABLE SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE?
SUCH A STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE.
WE WE REVIEW OUR FEES --
ON A REGULAR BASIS --
AT THIS POINT WE DO NOT INTEND
TO INCREASE THE FEES BUT THAT'S
AN OPTION SHOULD WE NEED TO DO
THAT WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
TO BE ABLE TO CURB THE SPENDING
IN THE DEPARTMENT --
AND NOT HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
ADJUSTMENT OF THOSE FEES BUT
CERTAINLY THAT IS ALWAYS A
POSSIBILITY OUR REGISTRATION
FEES -- ARE
ADJUSTED TO SUPPORT OUR
REGISTRATION PROGRAM SO EVEN
THOUGH IT ALL GOES IN OUR DEEP
YOUR FUN WE REALLY LOOK AT WHAT
THE COST TO THE REGISTRATION
PROGRAM IS.
AND WHAT WE HAVE MANY WHAT THE
FEE AMOUNT IS WE'RE GETTING IN
ON THAT PROGRAM --
OUR MILL ASSESSMENT --
HAS HAS BEEN --
THAT'S FORCE 80% OF OUR BUDGET --
WE ARE NOW AT THE MAX ON THE
MILLS HAS SPENT TWO POINT ONE
SANTA -- A
ON EVERY DOLLAR SOLD BUT THAT
DOES NOT NECESSARILY MEAN WE
COULDN'T COME BACK TO TRY TO
RISE THAT SHOULD BECOME
NECESSARY ONE OF THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE OF COURSE IS MOVING FORWARD
WITH PROGRAMS TO INSTITUTE SAFER
ALTERNATIVES AND INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT MEASURES.
SO AT SOME POINT IT MIGHT BECOME
NECESSARY FOR US TO COME BACK
AND LOOK AT THE MILL ASSESSMENT.
VERY GOOD IF I MAY I WOULD LIKE
YOU SAY THAT IT IS NOT UNUSUAL
TO HAVE THE NUMBERS GO DOWN.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
ME.
MAYBE GOING BACK TEN YEARS IT'S
SO WE CAN LOOK AT IT AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT IT WILL BE.
CALCULATED DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE
OF THE ADJUSTMENT OF THE THE OF
THE PERIOD --
THAT YOU IT'S NOW BEEN CHANGED --
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT IF
I MAY CERTAINLY TO GET A BETTER
IDEA OF THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
ALARMING TO ME.
I UNDERSTAND WE WILL CERTAINLY
PROVIDE YOU WITH THAT.
THANK YOU WELL IT'S A LIME
ALARMING TO THE CHAIRS WELL
THAT'S WHY I BROUGHT THE ISSUE
UP IN THE FIRST PLACE AND ASK
YOU TO ADDRESS THAT AND WHILE
THE SITUATION MIGHT BE NOT BE
DIRE IN THE IMMEDIATE NEAR TERM --
THE AT THE ACCOUNT APPEARS TO GO
READ -- IN A
RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
I THINK IT'S TWENTY TWENTY OR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE SO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS PROBABLY
RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER.
IN TERMS OF A PLANNING HORIZON
AND THE QUESTION --
THAT'S BEING POSED IS WHAT'S THE
PLAN TO ADDRESS THAT THEIR
FRANKLY APPEARS TO BE NO PLAN
RIGHT NOW OTHER THAN TO WATCH IT --
WHEN ASKED --
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT THE PLAN IS
THE RESPONSE WAS WELL WE COULD --
REYES FEES OR WE COULD CUT COSTS
THE FACT YOU KNOW TO SORT OF
GETTING TO THE HEART OF WHAT YOU
SAID BUT THAT'S THAT'S NOT A
PLAN.
THE THOSE ARE THE TWO OPTIONS
THAT THAT --
THAT YOU HAVE A AND THAT ANY
DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE BEEN --
A IN ANY GIVEN SITUATION WHEN
THERE'S GOING TO BE A A
SHORTFALL SO --
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
AND REQUEST THAT YOU COME BACK
WITH THE PLAN AHEAD OF OUR NEXT
HEARING SO THAT THERE'S AMPLE
TIME TO REVIEW IT I'M --
A LITTLE BIT FRUSTRATED THAT
THIS YESTERDAY AFTER HAVING
INQUIRED ABOUT THAT ABOUT IT --
SO.
YOU KNOW WE APPRECIATE A LITTLE
BIT MORE LEAD TIME IN ORDER TO
EVALUATE THESE THINGS AND AND TO
I WOULD LIKE THE LA --
TO HAVE THAT INFORMATION TO SO
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE US WITH
THEIR BEST ADVICE ON ISSUES LIKE
THIS.
THIS IS THE UP BY THE WAY THIS
IS -- I
THINK IT TO BECOME A RECURRENT
THEME --
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE ACCOUNTS
THAT APPEAR TO BE GOING INTO THE
RED AWARE THERE'S BEEN BORROWING
AND MOVING MONEY AROUND.
AND IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
GONNA TRY TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF AND PROVIDE SOME --
HOPEFULLY SOME OVERSIGHT AND AND
SEE SOME SOLUTIONS ON OUT DID
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS YES SUMMER
WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE FIRST OF ALL.
WE WERE RAISING ANY ISSUES WITH
IT THE TWO PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU
HOWEVER WITH REGARDS TO THAT
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION FINE THIS WAS ON A
LIST OF FUNDS THAT WE WERE
LOOKING AT BECAUSE WE'VE NOTED
THAT THE TRAJECTORY.
OF THE RESERVISTS GOING DOWNWARD
WE WERE VERY CONCERNED THAT WE
WERE GOING TO RUN INTO ANY
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE VERY SOON
HOWEVER YESTERDAY WE RECEIVED
UPDATED FUND CONDITION
STATEMENTS.
WE'VE ALREADY GONE OVER THE
NUMBERS --
THAT'S FINDING A SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM NONE THE LESS THE
PROBLEM STILL EXCESS AND BECAUSE
WE ONLY RECEIVED AS UPDATED FUND
CONDITION STATEMENTS YESTERDAY
WE HAVEN'T REALLY HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY DIVE INTO THEM YET.
AND SEE IF WE CAN IDENTIFY SOME
OF THE ROOT CAUSES SOME
POTENTIAL OPTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF TO
IDENTIFY THOSE OPTIONS.
THANK YOU YES TO TO ONE ANOTHER
COMMUNIST CHAIRMAN.
I APOLOGIZE I WANTED TO CORRECT
MY MY EARLIER STATEMENT.
ACCORDING --
ASSUMING THAT THE REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES ARE FLAT IN THE OUT
YEARS.
THE FUND GOES IN THE RED IN.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE OKAY
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
CORRECTION.
ALL RIGHT --
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM IF THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING MR KERRY MEMBERS
JENNIFER APPEARING HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK IN THE CALIFORNIANS
PURPOSES I WOULD MORE THAN.
I UNDERSTAND THAT TODAY'S ITEMS
ARE LIMITED TO A COUPLE OF
ISSUES BUT COULDN'T MISS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE A PRESSING
URGENT.
POLICY CONCERN THAT WE HOPE WILL
OFTEN BE ADDRESSED BY YOUR
COMMITTEE AND THE BUDGET PROCESS
CONTINUES EXCUSE ME MISS FEARING
IS THAT THIS THE MICROPHONE ON
OKAY [inaudible]
THANKS -- I
AM SO I START OVER.
I HEARD YOU ANYBODY HAVE A
PROBLEM HEARING.
OKAY NOT CONTINUE FROM WHERE YOU
WORK OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN I WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE DID NOT
MISS AN OPPORTUNITY ON FOREIGN
THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHERS OF
THAT ONGOING AND PRESSING
CONCERNS.
THAT WE HAVE ABOUT THE EXPOSURE
TO CALIFORNIANS WORKERS THOSE
WITH FOOD AND AND SCHOOL
CHILDREN THE ONGOING RISKS --
THAT THERE'S A MOUNTAINS OF
SCIENCE TO DEFEND --
PROTECTING US FROM CORPORATE
BOSS AND I JUST WANTED TO FLAG
THAT JUST OUT TODAY A NEW REPORT
BY UCLA RESEARCHERS ARE FINDING
A COMPLETE.
FAILURE BY THE STATE'S
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS TO
CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE SAFER
ALTERNATIVES TO CHLORPYRIFOS
THIS IS GOING TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE.
AND THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION IN
BOTH POLICY AND BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS AND WE REALLY WANT
TO SEE THIS ADMINISTRATION WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS ADEQUATELY FROM
THIS HAZARDOUS PESTICIDES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THE BOTH OF THESE
ITEMS OPEN.
AND THE BRING THEM BACK AT A
FUTURE HEARING --
SO WILL THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND DGSE DEPARTMENT TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL WHO HAVE ONE
ISSUE -- IN
FRONT OF US TODAY --
THAT IS ISSUE SEVEN AND THE
PLEASE GARCIA I KNOW --
YOU HAVE SOME --
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE --
I DOUBT THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
A RESOLUTION ON ALL OF THEM
TODAY SO --
A WE HAVE A A RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THERE'S SOME SOME QUESTIONS --
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR MORE
INFORMATION ON WILL --
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
BUT A PLACE WHEN THE TIME COMES
IS.
SO WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING
AND CHAIR PERSON BLOOM AND AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY
TO BE HERE --
TO DISCUSS WITH YOU EXCEL AND ON
THE EXCITED PROJECT --
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TO ACCELERATE MICROPHONE JUST A
LITTLE A LITTLE BIT BETTER WITH.
THANK YOU --
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TO ACCELERATE THE CLEANUP CLEAN
UP OF PROPERTIES INCLUDING
RESIDENCES SCHOOL SCHOOLS DAY
CARE CENTERS PARKS AND CHILD
CARE FACILITY SURROUNDED THE NOW
SHUTTERED EXIDE LEAD ACID
BATTERY RECYCLING PLANT.
INSTEAD OF CLEANING UP TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED PROPERTIES BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO CLEAN
THAT.
UP TO THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
PROPERTIES THIS BUILDS ON THE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS THE DTS ES
MADE OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS.
THE STATUS OF THE CLEAN UP IS
THAT WE HAVE TO CONTRACTORS ON
IN THE FIELD RIGHT NOW AND
CLEANING UP PRESIDENTIAL PARCELS.
AS OF MARCH FIFTEEN A TOTAL OF
SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
PARCELS HAVE BEEN CLEANED UP.
FOUR HUNDRED NINETEEN PARCELS
ARE IN THE CLEAN UP QUEUE WHICH
MEANS THEY'RE GOING TO THE PRE
CLEAN UP PROCESS IN PREPARATION
FOR THE CLEANUP.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWENTY FIVE
CREW CREWS IN THE FIELD. FOR THE
PARKWAY INVESTIGATION WITH THE
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION RECEIVED
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT THE TSC IS ENTERED INTO THE
CONTRACT. TO CONDUCT THE PARKWAY
INVESTIGATION WITH DTS SEE
OVERSIGHT WE EXPECT THE
CONTRACTOR TO SUBMIT A DRAFT
WORK PLAN IN EARLY APRIL.
ADDITIONALLY DTS SEE IS MET WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DISCUSS THE
PARKWAY SOIL SAMPLING STRATEGY
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND PEOPLE IN NEARBY COMMUNITIES
ASWE COMPONENT THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE TSC IS UNDERTAKEN SEVERAL
EFFORTS TO ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY TO MEMBERS OF
THE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
AND THESE INCLUDE ESTABLISHING
AN ADVISORY GROUP CONSISTING OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THESE MEETINGS
ARE HELD THREE TIMES PER YEAR.
IN ADDITION DTS SEE HOLD PUBLIC
MEETINGS FOUR TIMES PER YEAR
THESE MEETINGS PROVIDE INTEREST
INTERESTED PARTIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE CLEAN UP EFFORTS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN DTS HE
OPENED A FIELD OFFICE IN
COMMERCE TO HELP BUILD COMMUNITY
PRESENTS AN OFFER BETTER OUT
REACH.
THROUGH ITS OFFICE OF PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION DE TSC REGULARLY
CUT CAMPUSES NEIGHBORHOODS TO
SECURE ACCESS AGREEMENTS TO
OBTAIN SOIL SAMPLES AND CLEAN UP
PROPERTIES.
WHICH FURTHER ASSISTANCE WITH
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
WE ALSO USE OTHER MEANS FOR
COMMUNICATING COMMUNITIES WE
RELEASE A BI MONTHLY REPORT ON
CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES.
AND IN ADDITION WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A HOTLINE WHERE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS CAN CALL AND
INQUIRE ABOUT OUR CLEAN UP
ACTIVITIES.
FINALLY WE REGULARLY UPDATE OUR
WEBSITE AND DISTRIBUTE A
NEWSLETTER TO INTERESTED PARTIES
BOTH WHICH INCLUDE INFORMATION
ON A VARIETY OF TOPICS INCLUDING
DATA COLLECTED PROPERTIES
CLEANED AND SAMPLING STATUS.
OUR WEBSITE INCLUDES INTERACTIVE
MAPS THAT ARE SEARCHABLE BY
ACCESS OR PARCEL ADDRESS OR
PARCEL AND UPDATED MONTHLY TO
SHOW THE CLEANUP PROGRESS.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO COVER
INCREASED COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CLEAN UP OF THE FIRST TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED PARCELS PRIORITIZED
IN THE CLEANUP PLAN.
THIS IS A LOAN FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL ACCOUNT.
AND AUGMENTS THE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX POINT SIX MILLION
LOAN AUTHORIZED IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE INCREASE
COSTS COVERED BY THIS LOAN ARE
DUE TO UNKNOWN FACTORS ABOUT THE
SCOPE AND NATURE OF THE
CONTAMINATION.
IN THE COMMUNITY SURROUNDING
EXCITED AND THE ASSOCIATED COSTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE AMOUNT WILL
COVER COSTS THE ORIGINAL
ESTIMATE DID NOT INCLUDE SUCH AS
A QUALITY ASSURANCE OVERSIGHT
CONTRACTOR.
SAMPLE STORAGE COSTS A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT IN PERFORMANCE
AND PAYMENT BONDS.
THE GOVERNOR IS ALSO PROPOSING
AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION THAT
WILL ALLOW FOR THE CLEANUP OF UP
TO SEVEN HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
PARCELS.
THE DECISION OF FUNDS WHEN ABLE
DE TSC TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
CREDIT CLEAN UP CREWS FROM.
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY PER WEEK
ON AVERAGE.
THESE ESTIMATES ARE BASED ON
INFORMATION WE'VE GATHERED ABOUT
THE COST OF THE PROPERTIES CLEAN
TO DATE.
HOWEVER SHOULD THE ASSUMPTIONS
CHANGE THE NUMBER OF PROPERTIES
REMEDIATED WILL ALSO BE SUBJECT
TO CHANGE.
WE ESTIMATE WE CAN COMPLETE
THESE CLEANUPS BY DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ALL THE WEATHER
SCHEDULING WITH RESIDENTS
HOLIDAYS AND OTHER FACTORS CAN
AFFECT THE TIME LINES.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT DTS SEES
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT
OF LEAD CONTAMINATION IN THE
COMMUNITY SURROUNDING THE EXITE
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGY FACILITY.
AND TO MEET OUR COMMITMENT TO
CLEAN UP THE MOST CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES IN THESE COMMUNITIES
WE WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE.
THANK YOU QUESTION.
SIX GARCIA YES --
LET ME START OFF WITH THEM.
COMMENTS I APPRECIATE THE AT THE
FROM.
THE TSC --
THOUGH THE WORK ON ACT THAT
STARTED LONG BEFORE I GOT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WHEN WE GOT TO
THE LEXUS BUT SLATER.
ANALYST OKAY AND HAPPENED THERE
WAS THE STARK CONTRAST WITH HOW
WE WERE HANDLING THE SITUATIONS.
AND IT WAS IN A WITHIN A
COINCIDENCE OF WHO LIVES WHERE
AND HOW WE WERE HANDING THE
SITUATIONS.
AT THAT POINT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED ABOUT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TOYS ALL OF THE TNC
BUDGET THAT WOULD HAVE INCLUDED
ALL THE WORK IN A TO DO AN
EXCITED.
EVERYTHING ELSE AND I SAID THAT
IT WAS INSULTING BECAUSE IT WAS
THE SAME BROWN I WAS THROWING
PENNIES AT BROWN PEOPLE.
ON AND AFTER THAT.
ACTION CHANGING WE GOT A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX UNKNOWN WE WERE
TOLD THAT THAT WAS THE ONLY
MONEY THAT WAS GOING TO COME OUR
WAY.
BUT WE WERE TOLD EVERY TEN
THOUSAND HOMES THAT NEEDED TO BE
CLEANED UP AND THAT THAT COST
COULD BE CLOSE TO A BILLION
DOLLARS.
I COMMUNITY SAID THAT WE WERE
GOING TO FIND A WAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE LEAVE ANYONE.
SEWER TACIT FINDING.
CREATIVE WAY TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T LEAVE ANYONE BEHIND HIS AT
THAT POINT WE TOOK ON THE
CHALLENGE TO PASS THE FIRST TWO
THIRDS VOTE FEE IN A DECADE. TO
CREATE THE BATTERY FEE FUND.
AND THANKFULLY WITH THE HELP OF
STAFF HERE STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE CENTER COLLEAGUES WE
GOT THAT PASSED.
AND THEY GAVE US A LITTLE BIT OF
HOPE OR GOING ANY OTHER THOUGHT
THAT HOPEFULLY WERE CREATING A
MODEL. FOR ALL THE OTHER TOXIC
THAT WE HAVE IN THIS COMMUNITY
JUST LIKE LOTS OF OTHER
COMMUNITY THE COLORS THEY'RE
COSTLY BEING TO THE LIKELY SIGN
THIS IS ONE OF MANY THINGS.
AND THAT PROCESS IS ALSO
DISCOVERED THAT THERE WERE AT
LEAST FOURTEEN OTHER LEGACY
SITES IN THE SITE.
AND IN THE STATE THAT NEEDED TO
BE CLEANED UP --
TIED TO LEAD BATTERIES A LOT OF
THE NEAR THE THING COMMUNITY
THERE.
AND SO WE REALIZED THAT IT
pDOLLARS TO THE TEN THOUSAND
HOMES THAT WE NEEDED TO BE
WORKING ON BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE ALL THESE LEGACY SITES
WORKING THE ALONG THE WAY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BATTERY
FEED GAVE US THEY GAVE US HOPE
AND A WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T LEAVE ANYONE BEHIND NOW
THAT WE WERE IN OVER.
THE RIGHT PATH [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY [inaudible]
OUR COMMUNITY.
FEELS LIKE WE'RE BEING ASSAULTED
WE FEEL LIKE OUR WORK IS BEING
PROSTITUTED.
IN THOSE HARSH TERMS BECAUSE WE
HAVE TAKEN TO BORROW FROM THIS --
FEE FOR OTHER PROJECTS ARE TO
KEEP THE TSC UP THOUGH WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT HOW WE HAVE
DEPARTMENTS GOING INTO THE RED
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS THAT THE TSC.
AND WOMEN PLAYING GAMES WITH THE
BATTERY FEE FIND LAST YEAR AND
AGAIN THIS YEAR AND THERE'S A
SENSE THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
GIVING US.
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
LOANS OVER TWO YEARS WE REALLY
YOU'RE NOT WHEN YOU'RE TAKING
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR FROM A FUND IN CREATING A
HABIT THE MIXES WORRY THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO THEN CREATE A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT.
WITHIN THE HARD WORK OF OUR OUR
BATTERY FEET OUT THERE WE LOOKED
AT THIS EVEN CLOSER YESTERDAY'S
WERE TRANSFER OUT WHAT'S GOING
ON WAYS TO SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IS ANOTHER ONE TIME LOAN.
OR IS THAT CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION WE SAW THAT AT
SOME POINT.
BECAUSE OF THE BATTERY FEE FUN
WAS TOSCA ANOTHER FUN WE KNOW
THAT'S GONNA BE INSOLVENT IN
ANOTHER TEN YEARS.
SO HE SHOULDN'T SHIFTING MONEY
AROUND AND WHEN YOU DO THIS AND
I GO BACK HOME AND THE COMMUNITY
ACTIVIST RIGHTFULLY SO FILL THEY
CONTINUE TO TELL US THAT THESE
BROWN PEOPLE DON'T MATTER.
THAT WE'RE GONNA PRETEND WE'RE
HELPING YOU AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THESE VICTORY LAPS AND GET THESE
HEADLINES BUT YOU'RE REALLY
GOING TO LEAVE THIS BEHIND A
COUPLE OF YEARS.
THIS PROCESS HAS BEEN HARD IT
HAS IT IT'S BEEN HARD FOR THE
TNC WERE LEARNING ALONG THE WAY --
WE NEVER EXPECTED TO BE PERFECT
BUT WHEN WE SEE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE PAYING THESE GAMES H.
AS ADDS TO OUR DISTRUST.
IT CONTINUES TO MAKE US FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE THROWING PENNIES AT
BROWN PEOPLE YOU CHALLENGES TO
PASS A FEE A TWO THIRDS FEE THAT
HAD TO MEAN THAT IN THE DECADE.
PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE WERE CRAZY PARTICULAR
TASK ON WE DID AND THEY CONTINUE
TO PILLAGE OF FIND.
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO NOT
JUST KEEP THIS OPEN BUT WE NEED
TO FIND A WAY TO RESPECT WHAT
WE'VE TOLD THE WHAT WE TOLD MY
COLLEAGUES INCLUDING MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES THAT WAS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN THAT WE WERE
NOT GOING TO BE SINCE WHETHER
THINGS.
AND SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE
CONTINUE TO PLAY THESE GAMES AND
IS YOU COULD HELP ME UNDERSTAND
WHY WE'RE DOING THIS WHY WE'RE
PAYING BACK.
A GENERAL LOAN AND THEN YOU'RE
TELLING ME YOU'RE GIVING GIVING
ME ANOTHER FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
LOAN.
JUST ON THE MANY MORE LOANS USED
THE MONEY AND THE FEET AND THE
BATTERY FEE TO CLEAN UP EXCITE.
AND SO I JUST FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
SO YOU'RE FINALLY MONEY AROUND
YOUR LAUNDRY MONEY AROUND. TO
KEEP THE DEPARTMENT OF FLOW THAT
WE KNOW IS STRUCTURE IN A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN ITS REALLY
INSULTING TO MY COMMUNITY OUT
THERE.
AND SO I WOULD LIKE AN
EXPLANATION OF WHY THIS IS OKAY
WHY WE CONTINUE TO MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION I TOOK OF LAST YEAR IN
THE BUDGET THAT I'M NOT GONNA
TAKE AGAIN THIS YEAR.
AND SO PLEASE HELP ME UNDERSTAND
A LOT.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND.
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA I
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERNS WE HAD
PROPOSED THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT ANY OF THE THE LEAD ACID
BATTERY.
FUND CANNOT SUPPORT.
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT'S
NECESSARY AND WE WANTED TO
XCELERATED.
BECAUSE OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES AND THE RISKS.
THERE'S THE YOU ARE TAKING FORTY
OR FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM A
FINE YOU IN THE IN TWO YEARS. TO
DO WORK THAT COULD BE THERE IF
YEAH I CAN'T SUPPORT IT IF WE
COULD TAKE IN OUR MONEY FOR
SOMETHING ELSE.
AND AND WHY NOT GIVE US THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND USE
WITHIN ABOUT A REFUND CHECKS
ALREADY BEEN MORE IT'S NOT JUST
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED HOMES WE
HAVE TEN THOUSAND HOMES THAT
NEED TO BE CLEANED UP.
SO GIVE ME THAT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND ALSO USE THE
ADDITIONAL SEVENTEEN TO NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS PROJECTED ENOUGH
FUN. TO TO TO GIVE ME EXTRA
MONEY OR LET'S GO AHEAD AND
INCREASE THE FONT LIKE WE'RE
TRYING TO DO TO ONE OF OUR BILLS.
BUT INSTEAD WERE PLAIN MONIES
WERE WERE SHIFTING DOLLARS
AROUND TO HIDE UPON THAT WE HAVE
A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AT THE TSC.
IS THAT CORRECT.
THE UN STATEMENT SAID THAT MS
GARCIA JUST MADE IS THAT AN
ACCURATE REFLECTION OF WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH THAT ACCOUNT.
AS A PONG GAME.
NO I WOULDN'T I WOULDN'T KNOW IS
IT BEING IS IS THE MONEY IN THE
FUND BEING USED.
TO SHORE UP DTS SEES OVERALL
FUNDING.
A DEFICIT NOW [inaudible]
NO.
THE THE THE WIRE WHERE WE
BORROWING MONEY OUT OF THAT
ACCOUNT.
I'M NOT SURE WHERE THE BORROWING
IS THE THE LOAN.
OKAY SORRY.
THE LOAN FROM THE LEAD ACID
BATTERY IS SUPPORTING.
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO EXCITE.
WIRE WIRE WE NEEDING TO PAY THAT
LOAN BACK RIGHT NOW AND WHEN
YOU'RE THAN SAYING I'M GONNA
LONELY ANOTHER FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON TOP OF THAT YOU'RE
TAKING MONEY OUT OF A BATTERY
FEE.
AND THEN SAY NEIL ANY EXTRA
MONEY.
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
THERE'S NO NEED TO PAY THAT
MONEY NOW YOU COULD TAKE WITH IN
THEIR AND ACCELERATE THE CLEAN
UP EVEN MORE.
HAVE EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
CLEAN UP EVEN QUICKER START
WORKING ON THE OTHER LEGACY
SITES.
THERE'S NO NEED TO WAIT ROOM
COULD START DEVELOPING OF CLASS
AS WELL.
SO MY NAME IS SUPER TELLING THE
DETAILS SEE I'M A PROJECT
MANAGER FOR EXCITED AND WHAT I
CAN I CAN ACT TO THIS
CONVERSATION IS THAT THE FIFTY
MILLION THAT IS BEING PROPOSED A
TOP ABOUT.
IS GOING TO HELP US TAKE CHARGE
OF THE MOMENTUM THAT WE ARE
BUILDING TO CLEAN UP PROPERTY SO
WE ARE GOING TO INCREASE.
I HEAR YOU SAYING THAT GIVE THE
THEIR ADDITIONAL I CAN'T TALK
ABOUT LOVE RICK FUNDS --
WE HAVE BORROWED A FUNDS TO AS A
GUARANTEE FOR OF OF OF
ACTIVITIES WHERE WE ARE
OVERSEEING CLOSURE OF EXIDE THE
MONEY IS TO BE PAID BY EXCITE.
WE ARE USING THAT FUNDED TO
GUARANTEE THAT --
IT THAT'S THE ONLY.
A ITEM THAT I KNOW WHERE BE A
BARRING.
THAT AS A GUARANTEE FUND.
AND ON THE BRICK SITES ALTHOUGH
I DON'T WORK ON IT I KNOW THAT
WE ARE INVESTIGATING --
THERE IS ACTUALLY SAMPLING
HAPPENING IN A BURKE METALS
WHICH IS ON THE PERIPHERY OF THE
PROJECT --
AND THERE ARE TWO OTHER --
SITES THAT ARE ALSO BEING
INVESTIGATED SO THERE IS WORK
BEING DONE BUT I WILL TAKE THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY.
AND AND I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT WE ARE.
USING THE MONEY THAT WE HAVE
THAT YOU HAVE --
ENSURE THAT TO CLEAN UP AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CRUISE
THAT WE HAVE IN THE FIELD --
AND TO YOU KNOW TO WORK WITH THE
RESIDENTS TO GET THOSE CLEAN UP
SCHEDULED --
WE HAVE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
SPECIALISTS --
ASSIGNED TO DIFFERENT ZONES IN
THE PROJECT SO THAT WE CAN BE
DOING THAT OUT REACHING GETTING
THE ACCESS AGREEMENTS TO HAVE
THE THE RESIDENCES IN THE QUEUE
TO BE READY WHEN THE CONTRACTORS
ARE READY TO GO --
AND TRAINING UNDER THE WORKS
PROGRAM RIGHT TRAINING LOCAL --
YOUTH AND WE ARE EMPLOYING THEM --
THERE'S THIS THERE'S A FOURTH
COURT THAT IS GOING TO START FOR
THE TRAINING BECAUSE THE DEMAND
FOR THE LABOR IS THERE --
AND WITH THIS FUNDING WE CAN
MAXIMIZE ALL OF THAT.
YOU CAN MAXIMIZE THE AM I
CORRECT THE TO MAXIMIZE THAT
EVEN MORE AB HAVE TO FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS PLUS WITHIN THE
BATTERY FEE FUND.
ABSOLUTELY AND SO THERE'S NO
REASON. TO BE PAYING BACK A
GENERAL FUND ON RIGHT NOW ONE
TIME MONIES --
WHEN WE HAVE ALL THESE HOMES
THAT NEED TO BE CLEANED UP AT
LEAST TEN THOUSAND HOMES THAT
NEED TO BE CLEANED UP IN THIS
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
MS REST.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO HAVE
SOMEONE WHO HAS THE THEN THE
KNOWLEDGE.
ON A PARTICULAR ISSUE TO THE
EXTENT THAT SHE DOES TO HAVE THE
COMMUNITY HAVE A CHAMPION THE
WAY THAT SHE HAS BEEN.
ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S SO
EASY TO GO ALSO OVER ANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE PRESENTED TO US
BECAUSE THEY ARE.
PIECE MEAL.
SO I SINCERELY APPRECIATE I WANT
TO SAY THAT PUBLICLY BECAUSE IT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE ESPECIALLY
FOR THE COMMUNITY THAT IS MOST
AFFECTED BY THIS --
THERE ARE FEW THINGS IN THE THAT
IS THEIR QUESTIONS IF I MAY --
MISTER CHAIR THAT I WOULD LIKE
SPECIFIC ANSWERS ON WHEN DOES
THE TSC ANTICIPATED WILL
COMPLETE THE SAMPLING OF THE TEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE PARCELS WITHIN THE P. I. A
AND THE CLEAN UP OF PARCELS
CONTAMINATED BY LET.
SO THERE IS TEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
PARCELS --
IN THE P. I. A. AS YOU ARE SAID --
280-005-0020 TWO HAVE BEEN
SAMPLED AS OF MARCH FIFTEENTH.
THE REMAINS SIXTEEN HUNDRED ARE --
REMAIN OPEN --
THE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
SPECIALISTS THAT --
FOR JUST CONNECT WE WAS TALKING
ABOUT --
THESE.
ALL OF THESE TEN THOUSAND PLUS
PARCELS HAVE BEEN KNOCKED ON BY
OUR PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AT
LEAST SEVEN TIMES ON AN AVERAGE.
THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED ARE GOING TO
COME INTO THE FOLD.
ONLY IF --
THEIR NAME OWNERSHIP CHANGES
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
EITHER FLAT OUT TOLD US.
DON'T KNOCK DON'T COME HERE OR
ARE NOT INTERESTED IN ANY OF THE
OUTREACH WE ARE GEARING TOWARDS
THEM WE ARE SEEING SOME TRICKLES
WE ARE SEEING PEOPLE THAT WALK
BY SEE SOMEBODY IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD GETTING CLEANED UP
AND SAY.
ASK ABOUT IT AND ARE GETTING
SAMPLE BUT THE SAMPLING NUMBERS
ARE DWINDLING --
BUT WE DO HAVE A SAMPLING
CONTRACTOR HANG ON HAND AND IF
ANYBODY COMES TO US AS LONG AS
WE ARE WORKING IN THIS PROJECT
AREA WE WILL SAMPLE THEM.
SO RIGHT NOW WE ARE EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO OF OUR EXPERIENCE HAS
BEEN THAT THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED OR
SO PROPERTIES MAY OR MAY NOT.
COME INTO THE FOLD --
BUT AS LONG AS WE ARE IN THE
FIELD IN DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
WE WILL CONTINUE TO OFFER THOSE
SAMPLING.
SO THEY NEVER COME INTO THE FOLD
WHEN DO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT YOU
WILL COMPLETE THE SAMPLING.
SO IF THEY NEVER COME INTO THE
FOLD WE WILL WE WILL JUST --
LEAVE IT AT THAT NUMBER WHATEVER
THAT NUMBER IS WE ME MAY REACHED
EIGHTY SIX HUNDRED WE MAY REACH --
NINE THOUSAND BUT OUR EXPERIENCE
HAS SHOWN THAT THEY'RE ALWAYS
GOING TO BE FEW PEOPLE THAT DO
NOT WANT TO PARTAKE.
BUT THAT NUMBER CAN CHANGE AS
PROPERTY OWNERSHIP CHANGES AND
WE WILL CONTINUE OUR OUTREACH
REACH OUT TO THESE BEYOND WHAT
WE'VE DONE THUS FAR.
CAN I ADD ON THAT I MEAN I AND
IN ALL FAIRNESS I KNOW THE TSC
AND COMMUNITY GROUPS HAVE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO BRING EVERYONE
INTO THE FOLD --
AND CONTINUES TO WORK TO DO THAT
INTO THE FALL UNTIL I HAVE A LOT
OFDECISIONS I WANT TO BE FOR
AND THAT IS THE SPACE WHERE THE
TSC HAS BEEN WORKING
AGGRESSIVELY. TO TRY TO CONVINCE
EVERYONE AND ALL THE PROPERTY
OWNERS CONTINUOUSLY TO COME INTO
THE FOLD.
THE NEXT QUESTION IS HOW DOES
DTS YET.
HOW MUCH DOES THE TSC ESTIMATE
IT WILL COST TO COMPLETE THE
SAMPLING AND CLEAN UP OF ALL OF
THE PARCELS THE REQUIRED CLEAN
UP WITHIN THE PIAA?
AND SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE
EXPECT TO SEE IT TIME GENERAL
FUND LOANS IN FUTURE BUDGETS --
SO AS I MENTIONED EARLIER --
OR I'M I'M NOT SURE I DID I WAS
AT A COMMUNITY MEETING LAST
NIGHT SO I'M MIXING UP MESSAGES
PERHAPS BUT SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE PARCELS HAVE BEEN
CLEANED UP AS OF MARCH FIFTEENTH --
WE ARE WE ARE.
TARGETING A ANTICIPATING
CLEANING UP UP TO TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED PARCELS BY DECEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY AND THE CAP YACHTS
THAT --
CHIEF OF A **** HE SAID.
WHETHER AND PEOPLE PERMITTING --
IF NOTHING HAPPENS THAT THAT IS
THE GOAL THAT IS WHERE WE ARE
GOING.
THE CONSTRUCTION COSTS HAVE GONE
UP THE INFLATION THE COST OF
LABOR THE ORIGINAL ESTIMATES
THAT WE BASED THE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
LOAN ON WAS --
WAS BASED ON CONSTRUCTION COSTS
THAT WERE OF FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN LATE.
FOURTEEN ARE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND OUR THAT.
CLEAN UP WAS CONDUCTED BY EXCITE
CONTRACT --
CONTRACTING --
ORGANIZATION HAS DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTRACTING
THEN EXCITE DOES ARE CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS HAS ADDED SOME COST
WE HAVE BONDING REQUIREMENTS.
OF WE HAVE --
PREVAILING WAGES THAT WERE ALL
KNOCKED OUT IN THAT ORIGINAL
COST -- AND
SO THAT HAS ALL ADDED UP AT AS
OF TODAY.
WE BELIEVE THIS THAT THAT THE
AVERAGE PROPERTIES GOING TO COST
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS IS AN AVERAGE BASED ON WHAT
WE HAVE DONE SO FAR THESE
NUMBERS DO CHANGE BECAUSE THE
SIZE OF THE PROPERTY IS
DIFFERENT.
THE SOMETIMES THE CONFIGURATION
OF THE PROPERTY IS SUCH THAT IT
IS ON A HILLSIDE WHERE WE CANNOT
USE EQUIPMENT WE HAVE TO USE
MANUAL LABOR THE COST GOES UP.
SOMETIMES THERE IS THE LAY OUT
OF THE PROPERTIES SUCH THAT THE
EQUIPMENT CANNOT PASS BETWEEN
THE STRUCTURES AND WE HAVE TO
USE MANUAL LABOR AND THE COST
GOES UP.
SO THESE ARE THINGS THAT THAT
THAT.
AFFECT THE AVERAGE BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE BASING ON AND YES
THERE IS A THERE IS AS I SAID --
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED PLUS
PROPERTY SAMPLED WE HAVE A ABOUT
FORTY FOUR HUNDRED THAT'LL
REMAIN AND THERE WILL NOT GET
CLEANED UP EVEN AFTER THE
AUGMENTATION OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS --
THAT WE'LL NEED A FUNDING.
SO.
SO THAT I CAN WRITE IN MY NOTES.
WHAT IS THE ESTIMATE FOR DETAILS
SEE?
NOW TO COMPLETE THE SAMPLING AND
CLEAN UP.
SO THIS IS THIS IS.
MATH IS NOT MY FORTE BUT I WILL
TELL YOU IF YOU DO SIXTY TIMES
OF FORTY FOUR HUNDRED THAT IS
WHAT IS AS OF TODAY.
BUT BUT LIKE I SAID.
BUT WE'LL SAY MATH IS NOT MY
FORTE EITHER WE HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO WHO CAN DO THIS MATH I
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO PUT DOWN A
NUMBER.
AS TO WHAT THE ESTIMATE IS RIGHT
NOW -- TO
COMPLETE THE SAMPLING AND CLEAN
UP OF ALL THE PARCELS.
AS A MAY I ADD A A COMMON HERE
PLEASE YOU DON'T MIND --
THIS IS A QUESTION THAT'S
PRINTED IN THE AGENDA.
AND SO IT REALLY BEHOOVES --
EVERYONE WHO APPEARS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TO BE PREPARED TO
ANSWER WITH SOME LEVEL OF
SPECIFICITY THAT THE THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE POSED.
THAT'S WHY OUR STAFF BECAUSE TO
THE TROUBLE OF PUTTING THOSE
QUESTIONS IN THERE --
ALL ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES --
TO IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER
JUST SAY YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER AND YOU KNOW WE EXPECT.
THAT ANSWER TO BE PROVIDED --
NOT YOU KNOW AT THE TIME THE
NEXT HEARING BUT IT WELL IN
ADVANCE OF THE OF THE NEXT
HEARING WILL THAT.
YEAH HELP MISTRESS AND WE CAN
CERTAINLY --
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE DATA THAT
WE HAVE AS OF TODAY'S DATE I
THINK A THE CHALLENGE THAT SUITS
HAVING IS THAT --
WE ASSUME WE'RE GOING TO GET
MORE SAMPLING AGREEMENTS BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
OUT IN THE FIELD --
AND AND EVEN AS WERE CLEANING WE
EXPECT SOME --
PROPERTY OWNERS TO TO SIGN UP
FOR SAMPLING AS THE SEE THE
THEIR NEIGHBORS PROPERTIES BEING
REMEDIATED AND THEN WE WERE WERE
A LITTLE TENTATIVE ON THE PRICE
PER PROPERTY WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
CHANGED OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS BECAUSE OF INCREASED.
INFLATION WITH CONSTRUCTION
COSTS UNDER CROSS ALL
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY NOT JUST
PERTAINING TO THIS AND IN THE
OTHER AT ELEMENTS THAT NGUYEN IN
THE UNKNOWNS WHICH ARE THE
EXTENT OF CONTAMINATION.
AND THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PROPERTIES TESTAMENT AND AND WE
WOULD NEED TO QUALIFY IT WITH
THOSE FACTORS THAT WE'VE ALREADY
DISCUSSED THE AGENDA ASKED FOR
AND AN ESTIMATE --
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT I'M SORRY --
TO TO INTERJECT HERE BUT THIS IS
JUST A LITTLE BIT FRUSTRATING --
I'D.
HEY AND THE ALL WE NLY EXPECT
PROJECTION AND IF THERE'S A
TOLERANCE THAT'S PLUS OR MINUS
OF YOU KNOW CERTAIN PERCENTAGES
JUST TELL US --
BUT NOT COMING IN WITH ANY
INFORMATION AT ALL THIS --
OF FRANKLY A AN UNACCEPTABLE.
AND I THINK THAT IF IF YOU GIVE
ESTIMATES YOU CAN SAVE BASED
UPON THIS NUMBER.
AND THESE MANY PARCELS WITH THIS
MANY OF THEM HAVING BEEN --
SAMPLED IT AND THEN YOU CAN
QUALIFY IT BUT HONESTLY THIS IS
VERY FRUSTRATING. TO BE ABLE TO
TO TO TO FEEL THAT WE CAN VOTE
ON SOMETHING. FOR ME ANYWAY I'M
THE NEW KID ON THE BLOCK BUTTO
TO ASK ME TO VOTE ON SOMETHING
AND WHEN I HAVE MY COLLEAGUE WHO
KNOWS THIS INSIDE AND OUT HAVING
THIS LEVEL OF FRUSTRATION.
IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO
EVER VOTE. TO ON THIS KIND OF A
BUDGET ITEM WITH NO ESTIMATES
AND AS THE CHAIR HAS INDICATED
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS
LISTED.
ON READING THE QUESTION RIGHT
FROM WHAT WAS PROVIDED TO THE
DEPARTMENT I I AM.
SO AS OF TODAY WHAT IS THE
NUMBER.
IT'S WE WE ANTICIPATE THAT WE
HAVE WE WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL PROPERTIES.
THAT ARE --
HAVE BEEN SAMPLED BETTER BE TO
THE CLEANUP THRESHOLD OF EIGHTY
PARTS PER MILLION AND THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE PARTS
PER MILLION WHICH IS --
WHAT THE ADDITIONAL SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION WILL WELL I'LL ENABLE US
TO CLEAN TO AND WE'RE ESTIMATING
THAT THOSE FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
PROPERTIES WILL COST
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER PROPERTY TO CLEAN?
IF I MAY INTERJECT DISAPPEAR THE
SIMPLE MATH THAT'S TO OUR SIXTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FONG.
HANDY DANDY CALCULATORS.
HOW DO YOU DISAPPOINT ME I WAS
HOPING YOU WOULD THEN THAT --
CALCULATION HERE AT ALL RIGHT.
OF THE THE NAME IS RACE I THINK
THERE'S A TO OTHER QUESTIONS
HERE THAT WE WANT TO GET --
TO AND AND WE HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH
OF OTHER --
TO SIT TECHNICAL TERM CAN I MUCH
OF OTHER QUESTIONS YES --
I I'D APPRECIATE THAT LET'S TRY
TO GET ANSWERS TO THOSE OF THE
ANSWERS ARE HERE TODAY --
THE SAME DIRECTION --
PLEASE GET THAT INFORMATION TO
US PLEASE PROCEED ADDRESS.
WHEN DOES THE TSC ESTIMATE EXIDE
WILL BEGIN TO REPAY THE STATE
FOR THE CLEAN UP COSTS IS IT HAS
INCURRED AND HOW ARE THESE
PAYMENTS LIKELY TO BE SCHEDULED
OVER TIME?
SO DETAILS HE IS WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
NECESSARY STEPS ARE TAKEN --
TO HOLD EXCITE AND ANY OTHER
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ACCOUNTABLE
THIS PROCESS IS CONFIDENTIAL AND
PRIVILEGED --
AND THIS IS ALL I CAN TALK ABOUT
HERE.
BUT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND FINALLY WHAT A FORTY DOES
DTS SEE HAVE TO ENSURE EXCITED
WILL ULTIMATELY BEAR THE COSTS
OF THE PLANE --
SO THERE'S THERE'S A COUPLE OF
ITEMS I BUY A I WILL READ IT TO
YOU DDS HE HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
RECOVER ITS RESPONSE ACTIONS ARE
AT THE CORRECTIVE ACTION AN
OVERSIGHT COSTS.
FOREST'S FROM RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES UNDER SECTION NINE SIX
ZERO SEVEN OF THE CIRCLE A WHICH
IS THE COMPREHENSIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL RESPONSE AND
COMPENSATION AND LIABILITY ACT --
AND SECTION TWENTY FIVE THREE
SIXTY OF THE HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE
ACCOUNT ACT --
THIS IS HEALTH AND SAFETY COAL --
TWENTY FIVE THREE SIXTY IN
ADDITION DGSE HAS AUTHORITY OVER
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE SECTION --
TWO FIVE ONE EIGHT ZERO TO
ENFORCE EXCITES OBLIGATION
ACTIVE ACTIONS REQUIRED UNDER
THE TWO THOUSAND TWO CORRECTIVE
ACTION CONSENT ORDER AND THE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN STIPULATION AN
ORDER AND IT'S AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING AN ANSWER
FOR THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
WELCOME TO AND ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS LET ME JUST --
ASK COULD A A AND I'VE THE THE
WHOLE VIOLATED THIS RULE OUT OF
MYSELF IN THIS RECENT --
INTERCHANGE --
PLEASE ALL OF US HAS TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED AND TO YOU KNOW
RAISE YOUR HAND LET ME KNOW YOU
WANT TO BE HEARD IN THAT.
A LOT --
TECHNOLOGY YOU AND WE'LL HAVE A
LITTLE MORE ORDERLY PROCEEDING
AND WANT THINGS TO DEVOLVE OVER
THE COMING MEETINGS --
AND I'D LIKE TO JUST KEEP WITH
THE NORM OF OF THIS COMMITTEE --
MS GARCIA AND THEN LIST.
I APOLOGIZE IF I WAS ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE BREAKING THE RULES
TO AN ANAL BETTER I'M NOT AND
YOU BE HERE.
BUT ACTUALLY YOU KNOW WE WE DID
SOME MATH EARLIER ABOUT THE COST --
AND IF WE'RE LOOKING AT AN
AVERAGE OF BETWEEN 600-002-80000
PRESS HOUSEHOLD.
IF WE HAVE --
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED HAVE BEEN
SAMPLE ONLY NO NEED TO BE
CLEANED UP WE'RE LOOKING AT
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION TO SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CLEANUP OF X. HAD A LOAN ON
INCLUDING THE OTHER LEGACY SITES.
MATT THIS MY FORTE ACTUALLY IT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I LOVE --
AND I WANT TO SAY TWO THINGS IN
THE IN THAT VEIN --
WE HAVE TAKEN AN A TEN MILLION
WE HAVE TAKEN TEN MILLION FROM
THE BATTERY FUND TO REPAY.
A LOAN THAT WAS DONE ANOTHER
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS AND THEN
WE'RE PROPOSING ANOTHER SIXTEEN
MILLION ACTUALLY ALMOST
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS CLOSE.
TO FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THEN WE ARE SAYING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE EXCITED
ANOTHER FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
LOANS AND REALLY WHAT WE'RE NOT
WHEN THEY WE TAKE THE FORTY FOUR
YEAR TAKING IN THE FIFTY IT'S
ONLY.
SIX BILLION DOLLARS OF ANYONE'S
GOING TO TAKE A VICTORY LAP OR
SAY GOOD JOB OR GIVING NEXT DAY
WHERE MONEY IS BECAUSE BUT WE
ARE GIVING IT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS.
NOT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IF YOU FEEL THAT THE MONEY
COMING INTO THE BATTERY FEE FUND
IS NOT ENOUGH.
THERE'S A MUCH BETTER SOLUTION
THAN THIS THIS SHELL GAME THAT
WE'RE PLAYING LET'S INCREASE THE
BATTERY FEE FUND LET'S REMOVE
THE FENCE AT THAT WE PUT IN
THERE FOR SOME OF THOSE FEES --
THIS IS GONNA BE AN EXPENSIVE
PROCESS EXCITE IS ONE OF FIFTEEN
LEGACY SITES WE KNOW WE HAVE
MORE WE DON'T HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO DO.
GENERAL FUND LOANS WEEKLY THAT
MY THIS BATTERY FEE FUND IT'S A
FEW THAT WE PAY EVERY THREE TO
FIVE YEARS AS A FEW THAT I HAD
TO PAY LAST YEAR WAS EXCITING TO
SEE MY HE OUT THERE AS A
CONSUMER.
I'M WILLING TO PAY THAT THE TO
FIVE EVERY TWO TO FIVE YEARS
EVEN EVER LISTEN MY FAULT TO
MAKE SURE COMPLETED EASE THAT
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES.
AND HAVE BEEN TREATED LIKE
ALWAYS I'M FOR GENERATIONS HAVE
A BETTER FUTURE AND SO I WHICH
IS RECOMMEND THAT WE DO.
A DIFFERENT TYPE OF MATH.
AND WE THINK ABOUT THIS IN A
SMARTER WAY SO THAT WE DO HAVE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS OUT THERE
LEFT FOR ALL THE OTHER THINGS WE
HAVE TO DO.
AND WE CREATE A MODEL OF HOW TO
TAKE CARE OF THESE LEGACY THAT
MAN MADE DISASTERS.
OUT THERE AND SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
WE'RE NOT TAKING FALLS VICTORY
LAPS AND WE'RE NOT SATISFIED
WITH.
YOU KNOW A HEADLINE I WILL SAY
THAT THE IN THE DAY THE TSC IS
OUT THERE WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
THE CLEANUP IS PICKING UP THE
MORE MONEY WE PUT IN THERE AT
THE FASTER GETS UNDER THE FASTER
WE CAN DO THE CLEAN UP.
THE THE LEFT SICKNESS AND THE
HELP YOU'RE COMMUNITIES ARE
GONNA HAVE LONG TERM LET IS BAD
AT ALL LEVELS.
LET IS BAD FOR KIDS IT DOESN'T
LET THEM THINK IT DOESN'T LET
THEM GROW WE TALK ABOUT IT SHE
MAY GAS ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
OTHER COMMITTEES.
THIS IS PART OF THE PROBLEM IN
THIS IS ONE OF MANY PROBLEMS I
HAVE THIS IS THE REGENCY NOT
JUST BECAUSE I GO HOME I LIVE IN
THIS COMMUNITY AND I WONDER WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME AND MY NEIGHBORS.
BUT BECAUSE I KNOW I HAVE LOTS
OF OTHER LEGACY ISSUES THAT I
NEED TO FIGHT FOR AND I'D LIKE
TO HAVE THIS WILL BE A MODEL FOR
US MOVING FORWARD FOR ALL THE
OTHER THINGS HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
CHROMIUM SIX ARSENIC WAY MY
FRUSTRATION IS NOT JUST TO BEAT
YOU UP MY FRUSTRATION IS
ABSOLUTION IT'S LET'S IMPROVE ON
THAT BETTER IF YOU FIND INSTEAD
OF SAYING IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH
HE TOSSES WITH PASSING A FEE.
THAT THEY GET BETTER LET'S HONOR
THE PROMISES THAT WE MADE TO OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT WE WERE NOT
GOING TO BE READING THAT FUND
FOR OTHER THINGS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN I MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE --
THE THE AS THE NUMBER THAT WAS
PRESENTED EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
THAT HAVE BEEN SAMPLED NOT ALL
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED AND NEED TO
CLEAN UP --
BUT THERE'S THERE'S ABOUT
SEVENTY SEVEN HUNDRED THAT ARE
REQUIRED CLEAN UP --
AND A BUT THERE ARE SIXTEEN
HUNDRED THAT WE HAVEN'T SAMPLED
SO I I'M GOING WITH HER MATH BUT
I WANTED --
TO PUT IT OUT THERE THAT AS OF
TODAY WE HAVE SEVENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED PARCELS THAT DO REQUIRE
CLEAN UP --
WE WILL CLEAN UP UP TO THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED AND THERE IS FORTY
FOUR HUNDRED THAT REMAIN.
THANK YOU --
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A VERY
LARGE SCALE --
JOB IT'S COMPLICATED THE FUNDING
FOR IT IS AS AS COMPLICATED BUT
IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE THE FUNDING AND TO SEE TO IT
THAT DAY --
PROPER --
LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT IS APPLIED TO
WE CAN'T DO THAT IF WE YOU KNOW
HAVE A HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING
THE OF THE INFORMATION SO --
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WANT TO BE
HERE HEARD ON THIS ITEM --
WE DO HAVE A HOLD UP IN --
WHAT WE HAVE A --
APPROVED RECOMMENDATION BUT I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT WE HOLD THE
SITE NOW THE GOOD MORNING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS CHARLENE CONTRAST AND
I'M WITH A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF ANGELO
PALOMA OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
HEALTH PROTECTION.
WE WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR INCLUDING THE PROPOSED
BUDGET.
IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS
CLEANING UP RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES SURROUNDING THE
FORMER EXCITE FACILITY.
WE ARE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
ACCORDING TO MATH IN THE ROOM
THE ESTIMATED COST TO CLEAN UP
THIS CONTAMINATION IS OVER FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS PROPOSED IN
THE BUDGET IS ANOTHER KEY STEP
IN ASSURING A SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING STREAM.
IS AVAILABLE UNTIL CONTAMINATION
IN THE LAST HOME IS REMOVED.
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
NEW AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT
LEADERSHIP AND ARE ENCOURAGED
WITH THEIR DESIRE TO WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE COUNTY.
AND LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS IN
ADDRESSING THE LONGSTANDING
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH THE X.
I. CLEAN UP.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
COLLABORATION AND STAND READY TO
ASSIST THE AGENCY AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN ACHIEVING THIS
GOAL.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO THAT
CONCLUDES SAID --
THIS ITEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PRESENTATION AND FOR ANSWERING
PCA A LOT OF TOUGH QUESTIONS --
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO OF
RESOURCES RECYCLING IN RECOVERY
HOW CAL RECYCLE WE HAVE --
ISSUES EIGHT NINE AND TEN AND
WELCOME A MISTER SMITH KLINE --
WOULD WOULD YOU KNOW --
WE'VE --
WE'VE GOT A PACKED AGENDA --
TODAY AND AND WE'VE ALREADY
SPENT A GOOD DEAL OF TIME ON
SOME COMPLICATED ISSUES --
SO I'M A LITTLE BIT HESITANT --
TO STEP IN BACK INTO THE
QUAGMIRE OF THE BOTTLE BILL --
BUT IT IT DOES SEEM --
BASED ON EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN
REPORTED TO ME THAT --
RECYCLING SITUATION IS GONE FROM
BAD TO WORSE --
THE LAST TIME WE HEARD FROM --
FROM THE DEPARTMENT I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY
THAT IS HAPPENING BUT IN JANUARY
YOUR DEPARTMENT REPORTED THAT --
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
CYCLING CENTERS HAVE BEEN CLOSED --
OVER THE LAST YEAR WHICH BRINGS
THAT THE TOTAL OF CLOSE
RECYCLING CENTERS TO ABOUT A
THOUSAND AND THE RECYCLING RATE
IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SEEMS TO HAVE
DROPPED BELOW 75% WHICH IS THE
LOWEST LEVEL IN A DECADE AND I
YOU KNOW I'VE KIND OF REPEATED
AS MANTRA DILLON.
BLUE IN THE FACE --
THAT IF THE PUBLIC YOU KNOW
UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT RESTORED
RECYCLING IS THIS THING THAT IS
SORT OF EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS --
WITHIN A REALLY GOOD JOB IN
GETTING THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND
THAT RECYCLING IS AN IMPORTANT
THING -- I
AND THAT THAT WE CAN DO IT WE
PROVIDED THE FACILITY FOR THEM
TO TO DO IT --
AND YET OF THE ACTUAL RECYCLING
RATES -- HAS
DROPPED ABOUT TEN PERCENTAGE
POINTS OF BLOOD --
WHAT IT WAS IN --
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND THEN
ACCORDING TO YOUR MOST RECENT
REPORT THE LEGISLATURE THE
BEVERAGE RECYCLING FUND HAS A
SURPLUS OF THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS SO YOU
KNOW HOW CAN WE HAVE A SURPLUS --
LIKE THIS IN A FUN THAT I THINK
IS DUE TO GO UP.
A IF I'M READING THAT --
THE STAFF REPORT CORRECTLY --
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE IN A
AND THAT THAT FUND BALANCE IS
GOING TO GROW EVEN MORE WHY
AREN'T WE USING THAT MONEY. TO
IMPROVE RECYCLING RIGHTS I THINK
IS THE KIND OF FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU AND I GET OAK DON'T WANT TO
SURPRISE YOU WITH THAT QUESTION.
TRY NOT TO YOU KNOW DO --
YOU KNOW BEING A GOTCHA MODE
HERE I KNOW YOU'RE VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THIS ISSUE --
SO IF YOU COULD PROVIDE US SOME
FEEDBACK --
ON THAT ISSUE IN THE COURSE OF
YOUR COMMENTS I WOULD APPRECIATE
IT OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND WE CAN TAKE MORE
TIME BECAUSE WE'RE STILL EARLY
HERE -- LET
ME JUST SAY THAT ON ON YOUR
SPECIFIC ITEMS WE HAVE --
A RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE ALL
THREE OF THE SPECIFIC ITEMS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN ASKED TO ADDRESS
HERE TODAY OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS SCOTT SMITH ONE OF
THE DIRECTOR OF COVER CYCLING
JOINED TODAY BY OUR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CAN ROSA --
I GUESS I'LL START WHERE YOU
STARTED --
MISTER CHAIR THAT IT'S A LOT TO
UNPACK --
ARE THERE AND AND I'M HESITANT
TO TO LEAVE ANY MISUNDERSTANDING
SEVERAL TRYING JUST BRIEFLY RUN
THROUGH IT AND THEN TRY TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO YOUR YOUR ULTIMATE
QUESTION --
SO -- I
GUESS I CAN CONFIRM A LOT OF
WHAT YOU SAID HERE STATISTICALLY
WE WE CERTAINLY HAVE SEEN A DROP
IN THE RECYCLING RATE AND IS NOT
INSIGNIFICANT EVERY PERCENTAGE
MATTERS WERE BELOW THE STATUTORY
GOLD 80% FOR THIS PROGRAM AND
THAT CERTAINLY IMPORTANT TO US.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF REASONS
FOR THAT THAT I THINK MAY NOT BE
TOTALLY APPARENT --
YOU KNOW IN THOSE IN IN THOSE
ENSUING YEARS WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF NEW
FRAUD MEASURES THAT WE THINK
HAVE.
REDUCED ILLEGAL REDEMPTION THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN RECURRING WHICH IS
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE AND IRIS REFER TO SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY OVER THAT FUND.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT RATE
REPRESENTS A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN BEVERAGE SALES AND
REDEMPTION AND WE HAVE SEEN A
TAPE BRING IN SOME CASES OF THE
BEVERAGE SALES SO REDEMPTION IS
ACTUALLY BEEN.
RELATIVELY ARE WE START WITHIN
AN INCREASE IN BEVERAGE SALES
REDEMPTION HAS BEEN RELATIVELY
FLAT -- SO
WE'RE NOT WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHY WE'RE NOT GETTING MORE
REDEMPTION GIVEN THAT SALES ARE
GOING UP --
IT'S CERTAINLY.
THAT IS DUE TO THE THE CLOSURES
OF SOME THE SITE WE DON'T SEE A
SIGNIFICANT DROP OFF BECAUSE OF
THOSE BUT WE HAVE SEEN A DROP UP
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE CLOSURES --
WITH RESPECT TO THE THE THE
SURPLUS I JUST WANTED TO BE
REALLY CAREFUL ABOUT OUR TERMS
HERE --
THANK YOU BECAUSE I'M YEAH I'M
PRETTY SURE I YOU KNOW MISSTATED
YEAH WE DO WITHOUT FUND AND AND
I MAYBE I SHOULD JUST PREFACE
THIS BY SAYING.
BE VERY HAPPY TO COME IN A WALK
THROUGH THE QUARTERLY REPORT IN
IN INTO A DEEPER DIVE INTO THE
THE FUND CONDITION AND THE
CONDITION OF ALL THE SUB
ACCOUNTS AND THE RELEVANT
FACTORS THAT LIMIT OR RESTRICT
OUR ABILITY TO USE DIFFERENT SUB
ACCOUNTS AND WHY THAT MIGHT BE.
RELEVANT BUT THE THE REFLECTS
THAT THE FUNNY CONDITIONER --
FUND -- THE
FUND -- YEAH
FUND CONDITION OF TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS --
THE SIXTY FOUR MILLION.
THAT YOU REFERENCED WAS A
POTENTIAL PROJECTED SURPLUS BUT
THOSE AGAIN ALL THESE NUMBERS
ARE PROJECTIONS AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT --
BASED ON THE MOST RECENT DATA
THAT WE'RE SEEING SEEING WE
DON'T.
THINK THAT NECESSARILY BE COMING
TO FRUITION THINGS COULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT THAN
THAT SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THESE ARE ALL POINT
IN TIME ESTIMATES --
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT EVEN IF THAT FUND
CONDITION PROJECTED --
IS ON THE ORDER OF THREE AND A
MILLION DOLLARS AT ANY GIVEN
POINT TIME.
THE WAY THE PROGRAM WORKS WE
COULD HAVE A HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS NOT
AVAILABLE TO US BECAUSE WE MIGHT
BE PAYING OUT.
IN ADVANCE --
CRB BEFORE WE'RE GETTING IT BACK
FROM THE DISTRIBUTOR SO JUST
BECAUSE THE FUND BALANCES THERE
DOES MEAN THERE'S A CASH
AVAILABLE FOR US TO EXPAND AND
THEN FINALLY I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT --
THESE NUMBERS CAN CHANGE WILDLY --
OVER THE COURSE OF A YEAR TO
EVERY SINGLE PERCENT INCREASE OR
OR EVERY SINGLE PERCENT DECREASE
BEVERAGE SALES IT'S ABOUT
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
FUND EVERY --
PERCENT INCREASE REDEMPTION IS
ALSO ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND SO.
IF WE SEE JUST A COUPLE PERCENT
INCREASES ON THOSE SIX THREE
SIXTY TO EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
ALL SAID THAT IT'S NOT
MANIFESTING FOR SO THAT THERE
ARE WILD SWINGS IN THESE NUMBERS
A WHILE THEY LOOK LIKE VERY
LARGE FUND BALANCES WE DO HAVE.
TO TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT BUT TO
COME TO YOUR YOUR YOUR ULTIMATE
QUESTION --
I THINK WE WE ALL WOULD AGREE
THAT --
THERE'S A CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW
WITH THE REDEMPTION CENTERS THE
RECYCLING CENTERS MISSTATED
CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S A NUMBER
OF FACTORS THAT HAVE CAUSED THAT --
ONE OF THEM ABSOLUTELY IS THAT --
YOU KNOW THE PUT THE PROGRAM HAS
NOT BEEN ABLE TO ALWAYS PROVIDE
THAT THE A PAYMENT THAT REFLECTS
THE ACTUAL COST OF THOSE
RECYCLING CENTERS DUE TO THE
TIMING OF HOW WE HAVE TO DO OUR
CALCULATIONS PER STATUTE.
ANOTHER IS THAT ONE OF THE MAIN --
FACTORS THAT ALLOW THESE
RECYCLING CENTERS TO STAY A FLOW
IMPROBABLE HAS BEEN THE FACT
THAT ALUMINUM IS AT BEEN A VERY
VALUABLE COMMODITY FOR THESE
RECYCLING CENTERS --
AND AS WE SEE LESS QUICKLY
UNLESS ALUMINUM IN THE MARKET
PLACE COMPARED TO OTHER
PACKAGING TYPES --
THEIR PROFIT IS IT'S BEEN GOING
DOWN AND WE'VE ALSO SEEN A
RECENT VERY SIGNIFICANT DROP IN
THE PRICE OF ALUMINUM WHICH IS
PUTTING ADDITIONAL PRESSURE ALL
THESE RECYCLING CENTERS.
SO I THINK --
IT'S IT'S A FAIR QUESTION THE
TODAY SOMETHING THAT WOULD AGE
DâN SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE
COULD THE ONE WE WENT OVER THE
FINE CONDITION --
THANK YOU FOR THE RATHER
DETAILED.
RESPONSE AND FOR YOU KNOW
SETTING THE RECORD STRAIGHT ON
ALL AND THE LIMITATIONS ON THE
FUND AND AND THE CALLS ON THE
PHONE -- I
THINK THE UNDERLYING ISSUE HERE
AT THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS NOW.
IS HOW DO WE TURN THIS AROUND --
AND MAKE CALIFORNIA --
IN THE NATION OF AS AS IT SHOULD
BE WE'VE BEEN.
DOING THIS FOR A LONG TIME FOR
FOR MANY MANY DECADES NOW --
WERE WELL PRACTICED AT IT WE
SHOULD UNDERSTAND --
WHERE THE IMPROVEMENTS NEED TO
BE AND AND THE OF I LOOK FORWARD --
UNDER THE NEW ADMINISTRATION TO
TAKING A FRESH LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE AND FIXING IT --
WE WE NEED TO BE FLEET OF FOOT
WHEN -- WE
LIVE IN A IN A TIME WHEN THINGS
DO CHANGE.
OF VERY QUICKLY WE DIDN'T KNOW A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT CHINA WAS
GOING -- TO
YOU KNOW CHANGE --
ITS RULES ON WHAT IT WAS WILLING
TO ACCEPT A MINISTER MEDICALLY
CHANGE THE THE PLAYING FIELD
HERE IN OUR ABILITY --
TO ADAPT AND ADJUST AND A KEEPER
SYSTEM GOING SEEMS TO BE --
VERY CALCIFIED AND I THINK THERE
ARE SOME REASONS FOR THAT BUT
YOU KNOW I'M GONNA --
TRYING CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS A PRIORITY ISSUE
AND LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
COLLABORATIVELY --
TO BRING ABOUT A CHANGE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER --
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO MOVE INTO
THE THREE ITEMS YES PLEASE OKAY
YOU HAVE TO SO --
WITH RESPECT TO THIS DAY WHAT
WAYS CHARACTERIZATION STUDY
COVERS LIKE REQUESTS NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
FROM THE INTEGRATED WASTE
MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT FOR WASTE
CHARACTERIZATION STUDY --
THE STUDY DATA ALSO WHETHER THE
STATE NEEDS SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE TARGET.
OF A 505050% REDUCTION
INDISPOSED ORGANIC WASTE BY
TWENTY TWENTY THERE ARE TWO
PARTS. TO THIS STUDY ON THE
FIRST PART IS THE TRADITIONAL
WAYS CHARACTERIZATION STUDY
WHERE WE CHARACTERIZE WASTE
COMING FROM TRANSFER STATIONS
AND DISPOSAL FACILITIES.
THE SECOND PART IS SLIGHTLY MORE
SOPHISTICATED THIS WE WHERE WE
CHARACTERIZE WAYS FROM A
TARGETED --
SECTOR OF GENERATOR SO WASTE AT
THE POINT OF GENERATION BECAUSE
THE WASTE CAN CHANGE FROM THE
POINT OF GENERATION TO THE POINT
WHERE IT'S DISPOSE THE CHARACTER --
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE WASTE --
OVER THE YEARS WASTE
CHARACTERIZATION STUDIES HAVE
BEEN OF VERY SIGNIFICANT POLICY
MAKING TOOL FOR THE DATA
CALIFORNIA FRANKLY FOR OTHERS --
I THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT NOT ONLY DUE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE SORT OF TRIGGERED
ANALYSIS.
BUT ALSO DUE TO AS YOU MENTIONED
THE CHANGING THE INTERNATIONAL --
COMMODITIES --
SHE'S NOT WANTING TO IMPORT OUR
MATERIALS ANYMORE SO THAT'S CAN
HAVE AN IMPACT ON WHAT WORKS
BEST --
APOLOGIZE I TOOK HIM OUT OF
ORDER --
THAT'S OKAY OKAY I HARDLY
NOTICED.
IF YOU'D SAID NOTHING.
HE WOULD HAVE HE WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN AWAY WITH IT --
SOME MOVE --
TO AT LET ME JUST SAY A YEAH
FINANCE ARE AT LA --
HAVE ANY --
ON EACH OF THESE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS TO ADD JUST --
SPEAK UP JUST COMPUTERS BUT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS SPECIFIC PROPOSAL REGARDING
THE WEEDS CHARACTERIZATION STUDY
AND AS STAFF NOTES IN THE AGENDA
AND THIS IS A TWENTY TWENTY SORT
OF A MILESTONE YEAR AN IMPORTANT
POINT OF TRYING.
TO TRACK AND HOW THE STATE IS
DOING IT MEETING ITS EXISTING
GOALS AND SETTING BASS LINE FOR
NEW GOALS AND SO HAVING THE
STATE AND INFORMATION WILL BE
HELPFUL --
TO THIS COMMITTEE INTO THE
LEGISLATURE INTO THE DEPARTMENT
TO TO EVALUATE IMPROVEMENTS
GOING FORWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES WE WILL --
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT NOW.
IF THERE IS ANY.
WELCOME MR MURRAY.
MR MEMBERS MARK MURRAY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP BUT
CALIFORNIA'S AGAINST WASTE BIG
FAN OF THE WASTE
CHARACTERIZATION STUDY --
THE THERE IS A HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA DOING THESE IN THE
THE STORY THAT THOSE WAYS
CHARACTERIZATIONS --
TELL US ABOUT.
ABOUT THE STORY THAT THAT TELLS
US ABOUT NOT ONLY WHAT WE'RE
THROWING AWAY BUT WHAT WE'RE
CONSUMING IS REALLY VALUABLE IN
TERMS OF SHAPING OUR POLICY IN
TERMS OF ADVOCATING FOR SOURCE
REDUCTION.
ADDITIONAL RECYCLING SO.
VERY BIG FAN OF THAT SUPPORTING
THAT ALSO --
OTHER ITEM THERE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING IN TERMS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIRTEEN
THIRTY FIVE THIS IS THE
LEGISLATION WHERE.
WE GAVE CAL RECYCLE GREATER
AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY FOR RECYCLING OF
PARTICULAR PROBLEM PACKAGING
MATERIAL AND WE LIKE THE WAY
THAT THEY'RE EXERCISING THAT I
THINK THAT AS YOUR PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION AND BALK BILL WHEN.
IT WOULD BE GREAT IF THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD ASKFOR THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD APPROVE
GREATER FOR SIMILAR GREATER
FLEXIBILITY INPUT IMPLEMENTATION
THE BOTTLE BILL SO THAT WE CAN.
FOCUS SOME OF THAT SURPLUS FOR
SOME WHICH CONTINUE RECYCLING
PROGRAM.
IT'S BAD WHEN PROGRAMS DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO IMPLEMENT
THEIR MISSION BUT IT'S ALSO BAD
WHEN CONSUMER MONEY IS LEFT ON
THE SIDELINES WHEN MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS SITTING ON THE
SIDELINES.
AND WE'RE NOT USING THAT TO
INVEST RECYCLING WHEN WE HAVE
SUCH A OBVIOUS CRISIS THAT
EVERYONE AGREES.
APPRECIATE THANKS THANK YOU --
WELL I THINK WHAT WAS VOTER THEM
COLLECTIVELY AT THE END SO LET'S
PROCEED TO THE NEXT ITEM.
NO.
OKAY SO TAKE SEPARATE VOTES BUT
LET'S FINISH THE PRESENTATIONS
AND THEN TAKE ABOUT.
OKAY I THINK I'M ON ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT IF I'M BACK ON TRACK HERE.
CALPERS LIKE REQUEST ONE
PERMANENT FULL TIME SENIOR OF
OUR MIDDLE SCIENTIST AND HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND FROM THE
INTEGRATED WASTE MANAGEMENT FUND
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT.
SENATE BILL --
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE PROHIBITS.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE
PROHIBITS STATE FOOD SERVICE
FACILITIES FROM DISTRIBUTING
FOOD SERVICE WHERE THAT IS NOT
REASONABLE RECYCLABLE OR
COMPOSTABLE.
ADDRESS CAL RECYCLE TO
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS AND
ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR
DETERMINING WHETHER --
SERVICE PACKAGING IS REASONABLE
RECYCLER COMPOSTABLE IT ALSO
REQUIRES US TO CONDUCT ONGOING
EVALUATIONS OF OF THE FOOD
SERVICE PACKAGING.
A VERY IS AN ALICE'S MATERIALS
PRODUCT PERFORMANCE AND AND OF
LIFE ASSESSMENT OF RECYCLING AND
COMPOSTING INFRASTRUCTURE
MARKETS --
TECHNICAL STANDARDS INTESTINE
EXTENSIVE CONSULTATION WITH THE
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AGENCIES.
DEFINING THESE TERMS WILL ALLOW
CAL RECYCLE TO EVALUATE PRODUCTS
BASED ON CRITERIA UNIQUE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
QUESTION [inaudible]
SIX MR MILLER.
THIS IS SO.
I SEE SOME NOTES ABOUT A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT.
IN THE INTEGRATED WASTE
MANAGEMENT.
FIND.
DOES THE DEPARTMENT HAVE A GAME
PLAN ON ADDRESSING THE
STRUCTURAL.
DEFICIT.
SO AGAIN --
IF I IF YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
NUMERICAL QUESTIONS I'M ASKED --
JEEP DEPUTY TO HELP ME BUT THE
ANSWER IS YES --
THIS IS SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE
TRACK VERY CLOSELY --
WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN A NUMBER
OF POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVES
DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVE SOLUTIONS
TO ADDRESS THIS --
IN IN THE FUTURE AS AS WE SEE
THIS IS A ON COMING PROBLEM --
SOME OF THEM ARE RELATIVELY
SIMPLE --
AND SOME OF THEM ARE MORE
COMPLICATED AND MIGHT --
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS A
COUPLE ISSUES AT ONCE AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS IN A SIMPLE
APPROACH MIGHT JUST BE AN
INCREASE IN OUR TRADITIONAL FEE --
BUT WE'VE ALSO OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS TO ENGAGE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES --
TO FIND NOT ONLY THE DEPARTMENT
BUT ALSO --
REYES --
REVENUE TO COULD PROVIDE BACK TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO INVEST IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT BE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF
THESE NEW --
NEW STATUTES THAT WE'RE SEEING --
SO YES WE HAVE DONE A LOT OF
ANALYSIS ON THAT IN OUR ENGAGED
IN THAT PROCESS.
HI THERE APPEARS TO BE NO PUBLIC
COMMENT SO --
WENCH MOVE ON YOUR THIRD ITEM I
THINK THAT'S NINE RIGHT.
YES NUMBER --
NINE PHARMACEUTICAL SHARKS.
CAL CYCLE WRECK A REQUEST ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION AND
PHARMACEUTICAL AND SHARP
STEWARDSHIP FUND INTEND
POSITIONS AND ONE POINT TWO
MILLION ON GOING.
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
IMPLEMENT.
SB.
TWO TWELVE SENATE BILL.
TWO TWELVE DIRECTS
PHARMACEUTICAL AND SHARKS
MANUFACTURERS DISTRIBUTORS
LICENSE THAT'S WHOLESALERS RE
PACKAGERS LIENSEES OF TRADE
MARKS ARE BRANDON IMPORTERS TO
ESTABLISH A PHARMACEUTICAL AND
SHARP EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM.
THIS PRIVATE SECTOR DESIGNED
APPROACH WOULD ESTABLISH A
PHARMACEUTICAL INSURANCE PROGRAM
FOR PROPER END OF LIFE
MANAGEMENT OF COVERED DRUGS AND
HOME GENERATED SHARKS --
BY -- THIS
WOULD DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
UNWANTED DRUGS IN TRUCKS
MENTORING TRADITIONAL WASTE
STREAMS.
THE UNIVERSE OF POTENTIAL
PARTICIPANTS --
IS VERY EXPANSIVE IS
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
PHARMACIES AS WELL AS OTHER
PHARMACEUTICAL ENTITIES LICENSED
BY THE BOARD WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONALLY OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PHARMACEUTICAL INSERTS
MANUFACTURERS WILL FALL UNDER
CALPERS CYCLES PURVIEW AS A
RESULT -- AN
ACT OF ENACTMENT OF SENATE BILL.
TWO TWELVE THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS PUBLIC YES MISTER
MULLIN.
SO THERE ARE ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
THAT ARE BEING COLLECTED IS THAT
OUR IS THAT ALREADY HAPPENING.
NOT YET WHAT WHAT'S A TIME LINE
ON THE CAN TO WRESTLE WITH THE
CAL RECYCLE WAY.
FROM THE PROGRAM REALLY BEING UP
AND RUNNING SO THAT WE CAN BEGIN
TO COLLECT THOSE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES THAT WILL SUSTAIN THE
PROGRAM THE OPERATIONS IN THE
STAFFING ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SO
IN THE INTERIM.
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO BUILD THE
PROGRAM PROMULGATE THE
REGULATIONS BUILD DATABASES --
WE ARE BORROWING FROM THE E.
WASTE FUND I THINK --
ROUGHLY TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THEN THAT
RATCHETS UP TO THIRTY MILLION
AND THEN WILL YOU KNOW FIGURE
OUT A MECHANISM TO REPAY THE E.
WASTE ON BUT BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY OF THE PHARMACEUTICAL
ENTITIES REGISTERED WE DON'T
HAVE.
THE STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION
ONLINE IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH CARPET PAINT
MATTRESSES AND YOU KNOW THOSE
THE PR PROGRAMS THERE'S ALWAYS
AN ADVANCE LAY OUT.
AND THEN WE WE GET BACK TO THAT
ONCE THE REVENUE ACTUALLY COMES
AND AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE ON ON WHERE WE ARE IN
THAT PROCESS WE'VE HAD ALREADY
TOO INFORMAL WORKSHOPS --
REAL INTO INFORMAL RULEMAKING
WORKSHOPS ON SB TWO TWELVE AND
TWO MORE ARE PLANNED SO WE'RE
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUING THAT
THERE'S A FAIRLY AGGRESSIVE
REGULATORY DEADLINE FOR US TO
MEET AND THAT --
PROGRAM.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS IS THERE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THEN -- THAT
WILL --
COMPLETE OUR HEARING ON THESE
ITEMS --
WILL MOVE ON TO VOTE ON ISSUES
EIGHT NINE AND TEN WE'VE HAD A
REQUEST TO VOTE SEPARATELY ON
ISSUE EIGHT SO IS THERE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU BLOOM HI FONG.
YEAH.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON NO [inaudible]
RAY S..
IS THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE FOR
A ISSUES NINE AND TEN BLOOM HI
FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
RAY S. REVERSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT UP STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD WE HAVE ISSUES
ELEVEN THROUGH
.
SEVENTEEN WELCOME ONE WELCOME
YOU TO YOUR FIRST --
A BUDGET SUB THREE MEETING GONNA
CHAIR ESQUIVEL THANK YOU CHAIR
BLOOM TO HAVE YOU HERE THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE IT AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS WELL.
NAME IS WALKING AFTER ABOUT NEW
NEW CHAIR OF THE STATE BOARD --
I REALLY APPRECIATE AGAIN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JUST NOT COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
YOU KNOW I I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF I HAVE WITH ME HERE TODAY
I MEAN SO BACK --
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD DURING PULL HIM S. R.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND HEAD OF THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER --
HEIGHTS IT'S BEEN I THINK ABOUT
A MONTH NOW THAT I I'VE BECOME
CHAIR SO I'M STILL STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU'RE DOES AND
AND WHAT MY PRIORITIES ARE BUT --
I DO KNOW THAT ALTERNATELY
BERMAN SERVICES BETTER --
THE STATE BOARD WE OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF OUR PURVIEW ON WATER
RIGHTS --
WATER QUALITY AND AND DRINKING
WATER HAVE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITIES
TO A KIND OF FIGURE OUT.
HOW YOU BREAK DOWN SILOS BETWEEN
THOSE REGULATORY STRUCTURES THE
DIFFERENCE IN A DRINK WATER
BEING SO NEW?
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO JUST
FINDING WAYS TO BE INNOVATIVE
WITH MY AGENCY SO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE DIVE RIGHT IN YOUR ISSUES
YES ALL START WITH THE ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN I'M TERRIBLE HE
WAS DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER --
ISSUE NUMBER --
ELEVEN OUR LABORATORY --
WORKED AS PERFORMED FOR THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER
REMAINS AT THE GIVE ME THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH --
SO THIS STUFF FUNDING REQUEST IS
FOR EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
AND SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND ON GOING AFTER THAT. TO
DO SEVERAL THINGS FIRST --
WERE.
OF MOVING FORWARD WITH ASKING
THE LABORATORY TO BECOME TEEN I
COMPLIANT THAT'S A NATIONAL
STANDARD THAT WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS --
HAVING ALL THE LAUGHTER TORIES
IN CALIFORNIA THE BOARD WILL
CONSIDER REGULATIONS CONSIDERING
THAT SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE SO.
NOT DONE DEAL BUT IT'S A GOOD
MEASURE DOES HAVE OUR LAB OF
ENTER INTO THAT FRAME --
ALSO -- A
DRINK IN MODERATION LABORATORIES
ARE REFERENCE LABORATORY SO PART
OF OUR GREEN WITH YOU SEE PA IS
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO PERFORM --
ALL THE NOW SAYS AS WE NEED FOR
THE ENTIRE SUITE OF UP.
MATERIALS THAT HAVE TO BE TESTED
UNDER THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
ACT OF THROUGH OUR CONTINUED
KIND OF REFINING OF THAT WE
DETERMINE THAT THEY ARE NEEDED
SOME EGGS EXTRA RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO ADD THE METHODS
NECESSARY TO COMPLETE THAT
ENTIRE LISTA WERE --
ASKING FOR AN INCREASE IN
EQUIPMENT AND AND INCREASED
METHOD --
CAPABILITY ON THEIR PART FOR
THAT AS WELL AND THEN --
FINALLY A IS THE ADDITION OF OF
THEIR ABILITY TO PERFORM NEW
ANALYSIS IS FOR US AND DEVELOP
NEW METHODS THAT WORK WE SEEK
INCREASING IN THE FUTURE.
OF WITH THE THOUSAND OTHER
MATERIALS COMING ONLINE SO IT'S
A WILL BE FOR THAT ENTIRE THING.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS ON ON
ISSUE --
ELEVEN WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE CLOSE OF ISSUES ELEVEN
THROUGH SEVENTEEN WILL DO THAT
COLLECTIVELY CAN SPEAK ON ANY
ITEM YOU WANT IF YOU DESIRE TO
ADD PUBLIC COMMENT --
SO -- ISSUE.
TWELVE SO ISSUE NUMBER.
TWELVE IN THIS WERE ASKING FOR
IT -- AN
INCREASE OF SIX ADDITIONAL
PERMANENT STOP IN THE FUNDING
FOR THE STAFF OF A ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
OF FOR INCREASING OUR SENATORS
SURVEY WORK THIS IS OUR OUR MAIN
WORK DO WE DO APPROXIMATELY 60%
OF OUR STAFF TIME IN THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER SPENT
DOING SENATORSSURVEYS IT'S OUR
MAIN WAY OF MAKING SURE WATER
SYSTEMS ARE COMPLIANT AND IN.
ACCORDANCE WITH THE WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS REGULATIONS
WE'VE ADOPTED.
THIS IS THE SECOND STEP WEEK --
INCREASED ONCE BEFORE WITH A TEN
ADDITIONAL STOP TO INCREASE OUR
ABILITY TO ACHIEVE SENATORS
SURVEY -- WE
WERE ABLE TO REDUCE THE BACK
LOAD OF FROM THAT --
INCREASE IN THIS IS ABOUT THE
TIME THEY CAME OVER TO THE TO
THE WATER BOARD FROM ABOUT --
A BEAMING BEING ABLE TO COMPLETE
75% OF OUR SENATOR SURVEYS AND
UP TO ABOUT 88% NOW.
THIS ADDITIONAL RESOURCE WILL
ALLOW US TO EXTEND THAT INTO THE
9495% RANGE AND MAKE BETTER
PROGRESS ON THAT SO THAT WE MAKE
SURE WE GET ALL THIS DONE AS
BEST WE CAN.
THANK YOU --
QUESTIONS SEEING NONE ISSUE --
THIRTEEN ONE THAT'S OF GREAT
INTEREST TO ME AS A KERRY
LEGISLATION ON THIS --
GENERAL TOPIC AND TO SENATOR
PORTANTINO I THINK WHOSE --
WAS THE AUTHOR OF SB FORTY FOUR
YES I THINK A GRAPHIC AND
DEFINITELY A HOT SO THIS IS A A
AND ESTABLISHING A TESTING
METHOD FOR MICRO PLASTIC SO.
KIND OF THE FIRST STEP REQUIRED
OF ANYTHING THAT WE'RE PROPOSING
TO COULD CONTEMPLATE BOTH WHAT
IT'S HEALTH IMPACTS WILL BE ANY
FUTURE REGULATIONS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THAT.
IS NECESSARY ESTABLISHING A
UNIFORM OUT THAT THAT ANYBODY
CAN GO OUT AND PERFORM AND WE
GET A VALID ANSWER BACK FROM
WHOEVER IS PERFORMING ITSELF.
ALL RIGHT NOW IN MICHAEL
PLASTICS THERE ARE A LOT OF
RESEARCH GOING ON THERE'S A LOT
OF ACADEMIC METHODS THAT ARE OUT
THERE BUT THEY ALL PERFORM A
LITTLE DIFFERENT VALUE AND GIVE
YOU DIFFERENT RESULTS.
SO THIS IS A REQUEST HERE IS FOR
US TO BE ABLE --
TO BASICALLY DEVELOP A METHOD
UNIVERSALLY --
THAT WE CAN THEN DEPLOY AND AND
START DOWN THE PROGRESS OF
UNDERSTANDING MICHAEL PLASTICS
AND AS YOU CAN APPRECIATE THESE
ARE SUPER COMPLEX BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY THINGS WHEN YOU SAY
MICHAEL PLASTICS THAT CAN
INCLUDE.
PAINT CHIPS MICROFIBER FROM
CLOTHING --
DISSOLVE PLASTIC MATERIALS GOES
ON AND ON AND SO THIS IS GOING
TO BE A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE IT'S
A VERY BROAD THING TO SAY
MICHAEL PLASTIC IT SEEMS LIKE
ONE THING BUT I HAVE A FEELING
THAT IT'S MULTIPLE THINGS WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO CATALOG DOESN'T
WORK TOWARDS THEM.
IT IS VERY COMPLICATED AND IT'S
AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE CREATED FOR
UNWITTINGLY FOR OUR FOR
OURSELVES AND I THINK THE
SOLUTIONS ARE GOING TO BE --
A DIFFICULT WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
EXISTS YET EXACTLY DEFINITELY.
IF THERE'S NO --
QUESTIONS WILL MOVE ON A
FOURTEEN ISSUE NUMBER --
FOURTEEN IS TO ASK FOR
ASSISTANCE OF ABOUT NINE A
TWENTY FOUR FOR THE GENERAL FUND
AND FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR ON
GOING SUPPORT FOR TO PART OF THE
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO DO
AN EXPERT PANEL. FOR ON SITE
RECYCLING.
THIS IS BASICALLY RECYCLING WITH
IN BUILDINGS NOT GENERALLY
RECYCLING AS MUNICIPAL WASTE
WHICH WE'VE DONE A LOT OF IN
CALIFORNIA --
CONTINUE TO PROGRESS ON THAT
FRONT AS WELL BUT THERE IS AN
INCREASING TREND OF SMALL IN
BUILDING SYSTEMS SPECIALLY IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND LA IN URBAN
CENTERS WHERE.
A RECYCLING A WITHIN THE
BUILDING BEFORE THEY LET GO OF
IT MAKES SENSE --
BUT THERE'S A LACK OF REGULATION
THERE THEY'VE REQUESTED THAT WE
HELP HIM DEVELOP THAT REGULATION
THIS REGULATION WILL BE
BASICALLY A FRAMEWORK WHERE
LOCAL AGENCIES WILL COUNTIES AND
AND CITIES CAN THEN ADOPT.
THAT PROBE SPECIFICALLY THE
FRAMEWORK WHICH LOCALS CAN OPT
IN TO DO THAT AND WE'RE A HELP
HAPPY TO ASSIST IN THAT AREA.
THANK YOU ISSUE.
FIFTEEN GOOD MORNING CHAPLAIN MY
MYLEENE SUFFOCATE SECULAR
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE WATER
BOARD --
ISSUE FIFTEEN INVOLVES SEWER
SERVICE PROVISION FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THE THE STATE BOARD REQUEST
THREE INITIAL PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND 500-250-00100
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM.
OF WAYS DISTRICT PERMIT FUND
SPENDING.
FOR OF FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN THROUGH TWENTY AND THEN
SIX ADDITIONAL PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND ONE MILLION SO --
ABOUT -- SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE WASTE DISCHARGE PERMIT FUND --
ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
SB TWELVE FIFTEEN AUTHORIZED
REGIONAL --
WATER PORTS TO ORDER CITY COUNTY
OR SPECIAL DISTRICT WITH AN EX
EXISTING RECEIVING SYSTEM --
TO PROVIDE SEWER SERVICES TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITH
INADEQUATE SEPTIC TANKS SYSTEMS --
THIS IS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PREVENTION OF POTENTIAL IMPACTS
TO SOURCES OF OF DRINKING WATER
SO WE NEED TO LOOK BOTH THAT THE
DRINKING WATER END OF THINGS AND
THE PROVIDING ADEQUATE
SANITATION --
AND IN A DAZE.
I'M CURRENTLY THERE'S LITTLE
INCENTIVE FOR MOST PROPERTY ON
OWNERS TO MAKE A CHANGE FROM
SEPTIC TO SEWER --
SEPTIC TANKS OFTEN SERVE RURAL
SPARSELY POPULATED AREAS --
LEADING PROPERTY OWNERS WITH NO --
NO OBVIOUS REALISTIC ALTERNATIVE --
EVEN WHEN I'M PROPERTY OWNERS
ARE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
ESTABLISHED COMMUNITY
COMMUNITIES WITH SEWER SYSTEMS.
THE COST OF REMOVING THEIR
SEPTIC TANKS CAN RUN INTO TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
THE CHALLENGES ARE MAGNIFIED BY
THE FACT THAT FREQUENTLY --
ADJACENT --
WITH WATER TREATMENT EFFORT
WICKS EXISTING WASTE WATER
TREATMENT AGENCIES THAT ARE --
IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO THESE
AREAS -- ARE
UNWILLING TO TAKE ON AND EXTEND --
SERVICES.
TO COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SERVED
BY SEPTIC TANKS.
SO THESE RESOURCES WILL ALLOW
THE STATE AND THE REGIONAL
BOARDS TO IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SB --
TWELVE FIFTEEN AN ORDER OF
NECESSARY CONSOLIDATIONS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITH A
LOT OF PROCESS BEFORE THAT
HAPPENS.
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITY FOR VOLUNTARY
CONSOLIDATIONS --
MAKING SURE THAT THE THERE'S
ASSIST --
LETTING PEOPLE KNOW WHAT THE
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING SOURCES --
TO ASSIST IN THESE PROCESSES
WILL BE SO THE SO THIS --
SO THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S IT FOR
THIS PROPOSAL.
CHEN CHAIR IF I MAY UM IT WILL
BE SPEAKING WITH THE SECRETARY
ROSS HERE SOON ON CLEAN AND SAFE
BUT OFTENTIMES THE SANITATION
COMPONENT TO THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER IS OVERLOOKED.
AND IS QUICK KEY AND CRITICAL TO
ALSO ADDRESSING AS WE ALSO
LOOKED AT ADDRESS ACCESS TO
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
ISSUE -- TWO
SIXTEEN YES ISSUE --
SIXTEEN IN THE WE THE STATE
WATERBOARD IS REQUESTING TO
POINT MILLION TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FUNDED.
IN PART --
BY THE WATER RIGHTS FUND THAT
WOULD BE FOR ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL
FUND FOR THAT THE BALANCE FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS. FOR THE SUPPORT OF NINE
PERMANENT POSITIONS --
TO ESTABLISH AND ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS OFFICE.
AT WHICH WILL A BRIGHT PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING OFFICERS
AND SUPPORT STAFF TO CONDUCT
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS IN WATER
RIGHT ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS --
IN -- AND TO
PREPARE --
THERE'S ALSO REQUEST A FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS --
FOR CONTRACTING FOR FOR CERTAIN --
ECONOMIC TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
WHEN NEEDED.
SO THE STATE BOARD --
ANTICIPATES PROSECUTING MORE
WATER RIGHT AND FOR SPENT CASES
IN -- THE
THE NEXT --
pDUE TO RECENT WATER RIGHT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND NEW
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY.
AND WE ALSO EXPECT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM AND THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT WILL ALSO RESULT
IN MORE HEARING REQUEST TO OUR
STATE BOARD IN COMING YEARS --
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN A. B. --
THREE THREE THIRTEEN WAS VETOED
BY GOVERNOR BROWN HOWEVER IN HIS
VETO MESSAGE THE GOVERNOR
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
TO INCLUDE INCREASE BURNESS AND%
TRANSPARENCY --
WAS WAS LAUDABLE BUT CONCLUDED
THAT THE BILL WOULD NOT WORK AS
INTENDED --
THERE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE DIRECTED THE SECRETARY
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY. TO EVALUATE THE
POTENTIAL ROLE FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
PROVIDE A RECOMMENDATION FOR
IMPROVEMENT TO THE BOARDS
HEARING PROCESS.
AND THE SECRETARY'S
RECOMMENDATION WHICH WAS --
PREPARED AND SUBMITTED CALLS FOR
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING OFFICE AS
A SEPARATE AND INDEPENDENT
ORGANIZATIONAL UNIT WITHIN THE
STATE WATER BOARD. TO PROVIDE
QUALIFIED IMPARTIAL HEARING
MATTER MATTERS.
SO DO TO OF A VARIETY OF FACTORS
WITH KNOWLEDGE AND THAT INCLUDES
COMPETING RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
BOARD MEMBERS AND KEY STAFF
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG.
ON PROCESSING HEARING REQUEST ON
THERE CAN BE LONG DELAYS BETWEEN --
I REQUEST AND A HEARING AND EVEN
WHEN A HEARING IS HELD --
THERE CAN BE A SIGNIFICANT DELAY
BETWEEN COMPLETION OF THE
HEARING AND RELEASE OF THE
PROPOSED --
DECISION.
SO HAVING HEARINGS HELD BY
HEARING OFFICERS WHO CAN --
APPLY SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE AND
WHO ARE DEDICATED TO THESE
PURPOSES --
AND THEY CAN PREPARE THE CAN
HOLD HEARINGS --
PREPARE PROPOSED DECISIONS AS
AUTHORIZED BY SB SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN WE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THAT COULD SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE --
THE PROCESS IF IT SIGNIFICANTLY
FUNDED TO HANDLE THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
SO WHILE THE FORK FOCUSES ON
ENFORCEMENT THE OFFICE WILL ALSO
BE AVAILABLE TO HEAR AN EXPEDITE
OTHER WATER RIGHTS PROCEEDINGS.
AFTER FOR FILLING ITS
ENFORCEMENT HEARING OBLIGATIONS --
AND THAT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RELIEVE THE OF
THE BACKLOG THAT EXIST IN THOSE
CATEGORIES OF THE PORTS WORK --
AS I NOTED 25% OF THE REQUESTED
FUNDS ARE FROM THE GENERAL FUNDS
BECAUSE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME
HEARINGS WILL INVOLVE
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST PERSONS NOT
SUBJECT TO WATER RIGHT FEES
UNDER EXISTING LAWS.
BECAUSE THEY DIVERT.
UNDER A PARENT OR PRE NINETEEN
FOURTEEN APPROPRIATE RIGHT.
AND ARE NOT SET UP SUBJECT TO
EXISTING WATER RIGHT FEES THERE --
FOR GENERAL FUND RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED OUR CURRENT ESTIMATE AND
WE WILL YOU KNOW BE ABLETO
ADJUST THIS IN OUT YEARS BASED
ON THE ACTUAL LOAD AND WE'RE
CLOSE AT THE OFFICE IS.
IS A PROSELYTIZATION OF THE
HEARING OFFICE COSTS.
WILL INVOLVE THE VOTERS NOT
SUBJECT FEES.
THANK YOU ONE OF THE MORE --
BUT NOT NOT UNCOMMON ARCANE --
RESIDUALS OF CALIFORNIA LAW
AROUND WATER --
AB THERE'S NO QUESTIONS SO I'LL
ASK YOU TO JUST MOVE RIGHT ON TO
ISSUE.
SEVENTY SHALL BE TAKEN NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AGAIN.
SO THIS --
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN WE'RE
REQUESTING SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND AND ONGOING GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT FOR FOR PERMANENT
POSITIONS --
TO BASICALLY EXPAND THE
POTENTIAL NUMBER CONSOLIDATION
CASES THAT WERE ABLE TO DO THIS
IS IN LIGHT OF AB TWENTY FIVE A
ONE PASSING LAST YEAR --
AND MOVING FOR WITH THAT SO.
IN ESSENCE --
IT TO BOIL IT DOWN THIS WILL BE
A GOOD --
KIND OF SEGUE OR PER PER --
A PREVIEW FOR THE SAKE
AFFORDABLE UNDER SEVEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED WATER SYSTEMS IN
THEIR ENTIRETY --
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE
NUMBERS AND BOILING DOWN QUICKLY
YOU SEE QUICKLY THAT --
WE HAVE OVER THREE THOUSAND
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS AND
FIFTEEN HUNDRED OF THOSE OUR
WATER SYSTEMS --
WITH LESS THAN FIVE
INTERCONNECTIONS AND 90% OF OUR
VIOLATIONS OCCUR AT THE SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS THE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS ARE OFTEN.
IN NAY RIGHT NEXT TO EACH OTHER
A DONUT HOLES WITHIN LARGER
WATER SYSTEMS AND A LOT OF
FACTORS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO IMPLEMENTING
THE TORIES.
UNDER TWENTY FIVE A ONE WE HAVE --
THIS IS KIND OF EXPAND WHAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY DONE AND SENATE BILL
EIGHTY A PREVIOUSLY TO ALLOW US
TO CONTINUE TO DO CONSOLIDATIONS
AND A USE ADMINISTRATORS TO HELP
FACILITATE THAT AS WELL NOW.
SO THE STAFF WILL BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT FURTHER WHAT OUR STAFF
ALREADY DONE WE HAD TO STOP COME
ON BOARD AFTER SB EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH THE AUTHORITIES THEN.
AND WE INSTANTLY JUMPED FROM OF
FOR CONSOLIDATIONS YEAR TO
AVERAGING BETWEEN FORTY AND
FIFTY IN THE TWO YEARS AFTER
THAT SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
ABLE TO FURTHER.
IMPROVE THE UTILITY DELIVER
WATER YOU WATER SYSTEM UTILITY
DELIVER IN CALIFORNIA BY
UPBRINGING OF CONSOLIDATING
SYSTEMS TOGETHER THAT THE
DESERVE TO BE THERE AND AND
SERVING OF GOOD WATER TO THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THOSE PRESENTE
SHINS SERVICING THOUGH QUESTIONS
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUES ELEVEN THROUGH.
SEVENTEEN HI AND THEN YOU'RE
BLESSED HIDING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION --
REGARDING OF THE THE HOST OF
PROPOSALS WE APPRECIATE.
THE FACT THAT THERE WATER POURED
IS ASKING I'LL BUT IN --
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE FEE STRUCTURE
FOR WATER SYSTEMS WAS CHANGED
AND SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED FEES.
FOR A LOT OF OUR WATER SYSTEMS
WITHIN OUR MEMBERSHIP.
AND AS YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH
LOOKING AT THESE PROPOSALS WE
ASK THAT YOU LOOK AT THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF THESE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE --
LOOKING TO INCREASE CONTINUE TO
INCREASE FEES ON WATER SYSTEM SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS NIKITA
CRIED WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ON ISSUE SIXTEEN
WE SUPPORT THE BUDGET REQUEST TO
IMPLEMENT EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN AND ESTABLISH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS OFFICE --
WE THINK THESE RESOURCES ARE
CRITICAL FOR THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO BE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
ENFORCE WATER RIGHTS AND AS WE
KNOW THE EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT
OF WATER RATES IS CRITICAL TO
PROTECT FISH AND WILDLIFE --
WATER RIGHT HOLDERS AND THE
PUBLIC IN GENERAL SO WE SUPPORT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE THIS AS BUDGET THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND IN
MEMBERS UP ROBERT COR FROM THE
QUALCOMM GROUP ON BEHALF OF KERN
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY KINGS
RIVER CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
KINGS WITH RIVER WATER
ASSOCIATION MODESTO IRRIGATION
AND THE CITY OF FRESNO ON ITEM
SIXTEEN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS --
OFFICE OF AND WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE WATER BOARD FOR AN OPEN AND
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS THUS FAR.
THE COSTS. TO RATEPAYERS IS A
MINIMUM OF ONE POINT SO WE FEEL
WILL QUICKLY BECOME THE FULL TWO
POINT TWO MILLION.
IT WILL BURDEN RURAL EMPLOYERS
IN PERPETUITY --
THIS REPRESENTS A MINIMUM --
AN UNPRECEDENTED 15% WATER RIGHT
RATE INCREASE --
AND WE WERE JUST INFORMED THIS
ON MONDAY.
AND ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
OFFICE H. A. H. O. DONE RIGHT IS
WELCOME HIRING SENIOR LEGAL
COUNSEL --
IS JUSTIFIED WATER LAWYERS
AREN'T CHEAP.
HOWEVER WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE FOLLOWING POSITIONS BE
ELIMINATED AS I NECESSARY AT
THIS TIME.
THE SUPERVISING ENVIRONMENTAL
PROGRAM MANAGER STAFF SERVICE
ANALYST TWO SENIOR ENGINEERS AND
A NAY GPA THIS IS A SAVINGS OF
ABOUT HALF.
OF OF THE TOTAL BCP AND IT
REDUCES THE WATER RATE INCREASE
BY ABOUT 40%.
OF WATER RATE INCREASE NO
QUARTER MINISTRY OF FACILITY
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER LIDDY OF
WHICH WE ARE AWARE EMPLOYEES
TECHNICAL STAFF.
THE WATER BOARD HAS MORE THAN
TWO THOUSAND AND CONCERT IF TIME
PROVES THIS IS NECESSARY THE
TECHNICAL STAFF WILL BE GLAD TO
TALK.
THE H. O. IN LAW IS EXEMPT FROM
PROVIDING RULINGS WITHIN NINETY
DAYS IF THE ISSUE IS NOVEL OR
DIFFICULT.
IF THERE ARE A LARGE NUMBER OF
PARTIES OR WITNESSES IF THERE IS
A LARGE AMOUNT OF THAT EVIDENCE
OR THE NEED TO COORDINATE WITH
RELATED PROCEEDINGS.
THIS DESCRIBES MOST IF NOT ALL
WATER RIGHT ACTIONS THUS WE ASK
THIS COMMITTEE. TO REQUIRE
TRANSPARENCY BY DIRECTING THE
WATER BOARD TO REPORT ANNUALLY
ON THE RESULTS OF THE H. SHOW AS
WELL AS THE PROGRESS ON A B. C.
P..
FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THAT WAS DESIGNED TO
REDUCE --
BACKLOGS AND PERMIT PROCESSES
OTHER IN SOME CASES NOT TO FORTY
FOUR YEARS --
ALSO IT ONE LAST COMMENT WE ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
USE OF CANNABIS IS THE
JUSTIFICATION FROM THE BEGINNING
WE HAVE TESTIFIED HERE INTO THE
WATER BOARD THAT CANNABIS FEE
PAYERS IN STATUTE AND BUDGET
LANGUAGE.
MUST BEAR THE FULL COST OF THIS
IT'S NOT RELATED TO THIS BCP
THANK YOU.
VVC LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY JUST
REAL QUICK VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE REQUEST --
ONE FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN TO
FACILITATE REGIONAL SOLUTIONS
FOR WASTE WATER SERVICE AND
DRINKING WATER.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE BOARD --
AND OTHERS TO IMPLEMENT SAFE
DRINKING WATER THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND ACCESS TO SAFE WASTE
WATER SERVICE THANKS SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION ALSO I'D ON ITEM
SIXTEEN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS OFFICE GENERALLY WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF AN ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
OFFICE WITHIN THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WE THINK
CAN MAKE WATER RIGHTS PROCESSES
MORE EFFICIENT.
MORE TRANSPARENT --
AND YOU KNOW BY IN SHORT WE HAVE
EMPIRE MANY OF THESE IMPORTANT
MATTERS THAT SAID WE DO SHARE
MANY OF THE CONCERNS ARTICULATED
BY MISTER GORE ON SPECIFICS OF
THIS B. C. P..
THE ISSUE OF STAFFING AND HELP
HOW THIS OFFICE WILL BE
CONSTITUTED IS AN ISSUE OF FIRST
IMPRESSION FOR THE LEGISLATURE
THE LEGISLATURE DID NOT SPECIFY
EXCUSE ME.
AB SEVEN FOUR SEVEN FROM LAST
YEAR DID NOT SPECIFY THE
APPROPRIATE STAFFING LEVELS AND
WE THINK THE IDEA AT THE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED SO FAR. FOR EXAMPLE
WHETHER THE H. O. NEEDS
DEDICATED TECHNICAL STAFF IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED --
BY THIS BY THIS CAN --
SUBCOMMITTEE AND OTHERS --
WE ALSO SHARE THE CONCERNS
RELATED TO COST ALLOCATION
WITHIN THEIR WITHIN THE PROGRAM --
YOU HAS AS IT WAS DESCRIBED IN
THE B. C. P. OTHER IS
ANTICIPATED INCREASING CANNABIS
RELATED ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES
ENSURING THAT THAT THAT THOSE
COSTS ARE BORNE BY THE
BENEFICIARIES OF FOLKS TO PLACE
THE BURDEN ON THE OFFICE.
IN THAT CASE THE CANNABIS FOLKS --
IS SOMETHING THAT WE THINK IS
IMPORTANT PORTENT SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN TODAY AND WE LOOK FOR TO
THE CONVERSATION COME WITH STATE
WATER BOARD WITH --
YOU AND YOUR STAFF THANK YOU.
HI EVERYONE HIGH CHAIR IN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RACHEL I'M
FROM RURAL COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION A NON PROFIT SERVING
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
IN THE WESTERN STATES AND HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF ITEMS FIFTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
SOWE HAVE --
ISSUES ELEVEN THROUGH --
SEVENTEEN I THINK WE CAN TAKE A
A MOTION ON ALL --
ON ALL THOSE ITEMS COLLECTIVELY
NO OKAY YOU WANT TO THE MALL
SEPARATELY.
THE PROBLEM.
IS OUR MOTION ON ISSUE
ELEVEN MOVED AND SECONDED
[inaudible]
HI FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY S. REVERSE [inaudible]
ISSUE [inaudible]
TWELVE A SECOND.
BLOOM HI.
FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY S. REVERSE [inaudible]
ISSUE [inaudible]
THIRTEEN SECOND.
BLOOM HI FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY S. REVERSE [inaudible]
ISSUE.
FOURTEEN A MOVE THAT
[inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY S. REVERSE [inaudible]
ISSUE [inaudible]
FIFTEEN SECOND.
BLOOM HI FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY YES REVERSE [inaudible]
ISSUE.
SIXTEEN SECOND BLOOM HI FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY S. REVERSE.
AND ISSUE [inaudible]
SEVENTY SECOND [inaudible]
HI FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN PATTERSON.
YES RE THAT REQUEST.
GREAT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU PASSED MUSTER IN YOUR FIRST
YEAR OF A WILL WELCOME YOU BACK
AGAIN SOON.
I PACKED WE'RE GOING TO BE
WALKING ME BACK RIGHT RIGHT
REALLY SOON RIGHT NOW.
SEPTEMBER OUR LAST ISSUE OF THE
DAY IS THIS YOU EIGHTEEN WERE
WILL HAVE --
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD AND CDFA.
FOOD AGRICULTURE DEPARTMENT --
TALK TO US ABOUT --
THE VEXING ISSUE OF SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
WELL GOOD MORNING AGAIN CHAIR
BLOOM MORNING.
I HAVE THE HONOR OF SERVING AS
CHAIR OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ABOUT OUR BUDGET
REQUEST AN ASSOCIATED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR PROVIDING SAFE
AND CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
HAVE TODAY WITH ME TERRIBLE HIM
IT'S AGAIN OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE TO OF THE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM.
AS YOU KNOW IN TWENTY TWELVE THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED AB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH ESTABLISHED
CALIFORNIA'S HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER POLICY.
THAT POLICY CLEARLY AND
UNEQUIVOCALLY STATES THAT EVERY
HUMAN BEING HAS A RIGHT TO SAFE
CLEAN AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
DRINKING WATER WATER ADEQUATE
FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION.
I AM PLEASED TO SAY THAT OVER
THE PAST FOUR YEARS WITH YOUR
HELP WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN THIS REGARD.
OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS
LEGISLATURE'S PROVIDED THE STATE
WATER BOARD WITH NEW AUTHORITIES
TO ADDRESS THE DRINKING WATER
PROBLEMS.
IN JULY OF TWO TWENTY FOURTEEN
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF FOR THE
SAFE AND SAFE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM WAS TRANSFERRED FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO THE STATE WATER BOARD.
TO ALLOW FOR ONE AGENCY TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FROM SOURCE THE TAP
TO PROVIDE ONE STOP SHOPING FOR
COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES FOR
THE FUNDING NEEDS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE COME BACK
TO YOU NEEDS TO DO THE JOB AND
WE'VE GIVEN THEM AND YOU'VE
GIVEN THEM TO US FOR EXAMPLE.
PROP ONE CAPITAL.
FOR CAPITAL FUNDING FOR DRINKING
WATER AND WASTEWATER TREATMENT
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND THE ABILITY TO USE THOSE
DOLLARS FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AS WELL.
THE CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF
SUSTAINABLE WATER SOLUTIONS TO
FOCUS ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR NEEDS.
THE AUTHORITY TO ORDER
CONSOLIDATION OF SMALL SYSTEMS
WITH LARGER SYSTEMS.
LIMITATIONS ON THE ABILITY TO
CREATE NEW SMALLER SYSTEMS STOP
THE BLEEDING.
THE ABILITY TO HELP PRIVATE
PROVIDE DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
THE SMALLER COMMUNITIES AND
DOMESTIC WELL OWNERS IN CERTAIN
CASES PARTICULARLY OWN --
OWING TO TO TO THE DROUGHT HE
SUPPORTER OF BILLS PERHAPS THE
BEST EXAMPLE.
OF THIS AND ONE WE'RE NOW WE
HAVE CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER
FLOWING INTO HUNDREDS OF HOMES
THAT WERE COMPLETELY WITHOUT
WATER DURING THE DROUGHT.
AND WITHOUT CLEAN WATER FOR MUCH
LONGER TIME.
AND YOU ALSO GIVE US THE ABILITY
BUT LIMITED FUNDING TO HIRE AN
ADMINISTRATOR TO MANAGE
COMMUNITY SYSTEMS THAT SIMPLY
LACKED THE MANAGERIAL FINANCIAL
AND TECH TECHNICAL SKILLS TO
MANAGE WATER TREATMENT
FACILITIES.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP MANY
COMMUNITIES ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF HELPING MANY MORE.
OVER THE PAST FOR YEARS FOR
EXAMPLE THE BOARD HAS BROUGHT
DRINKING WATER SYSTEM TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS THAT WERE FAILING TO
DELIVERS SAFE DRINKING WATER
BACK INTO COMPLIANCE.
WE'VE ALSO TAKEN ACTIONS ARE
PROVIDED ASSISTANCE TO WATER
SYSTEMS THAT HAS LED TO THE
CONSOLIDATION OF A TOTAL OF
NINETY SIX FAILING OR LIKELY TO
FILL SYSTEM SINCE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT HAS HELPED
OVER TWO HUNDRED SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SECURE
FUNDING FOR PROJECT PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION THROUGH OFFICES
STAINED WATER SOLUTIONS.
AND WE PROVIDED OVER ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN LOW
INTEREST LOANS AND GRANTS
BENEFITING APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITIES LARGE AND SMALL RICH
AND POOR URBAN AND RURAL.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BECAUSE OF
OUR REVOLVING FLAT LOAN PROGRAMS.
DESPITE THESE EFFORTS MANY LOCAL
WATER THOSE SERVING SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS WE HAVE NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED SYSTEMS UNDER OUR
JURISDICTION THEY CAN'T
CONSISTENTLY MEET.
MEET STANDARDS AND I'M TOLD MANY
MORE ARE TOO SMALL TO BE
REGULATED BY THE STATE.
WE ALSO OF UNTOLD THOUSANDS ON
DOMESTIC WELL.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO HELP THOUSANDS WITH
MORE SINCE --
TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO PREVIOUSLY BUT WE
STILL HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN RELIABLE
DRINKING WATER.
WHICH TOO MANY OF US IS THE
PREEMINENT WATER ISSUE OF OUR
TIME ONE THAT WE HAVE
CALIFORNIANS NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT.
WE HAVE AN IMMEDIATE MORAL
PAIRED UP TO ENSURE ALL.
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS I
CAN SAY WITH CERTAINTY THAT MY
TIME ON THE BOARD IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I GET THE
OVERWHELMING SENSE OF AGREEMENT
THAT WE CAN NO LONGER ACCEPT
THIS.
GIVEN ALL THE NEW AUTHORITIES OF
THE LEGISLATURE'S PROVIDED THE
LAST REMAINING PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE FOR ENSURING THAT.
IS THAT THE THE LACK OF
PROVISION FOR A STABLE FUNDING
TERM FOR LONG TERM OP THE
FUNDING SOURCE EXCUSE ME FOR A
LONG TERM OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE FOR DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS.
THE LACK OF SUCH A STABLE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE LIMITS THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS THE ADDITIONAL
CAPITAL COSTS FOR HUNDREDS OF
SMALL SYSTEMS AND DOMESTIC WELL
THE CANNOT BE CONSOLIDATED.
THIS IS IN A REQUEST OF FIRST
RESORT.
NOR IS IT A WAY TO INDEFINITELY
PROP UP UNSUSTAINABLE SYSTEMS
INSTEAD THE FUND IS THE KEYSTONE
TO A COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM THAT
THE STATE HAS THOUGHTFULLY PIECE
TOGETHER.
OVER THESE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
THE STATE'S LEGISLATURE IN
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT ON THE
ISSUE OVER THESE LAST YEAR'S.
HAVE CRASS CHARACTER THESE
AUTHORITIES.
WHEN SKIP AHEAD I APOLOGIZE
WHILE THE CHALLENGE --
TAXES CLEAN DRINKING WATER MY AS
A RULE ISSUE.
THE MAP ABOUT APPLIANCES SYSTEM
SHOWS THAT IT'S A PROBLEM THAT
IMPACTS COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THIS IS AN URBAN
SUBURBN.
AND RURAL PROBLEM AND THE
SOLUTION THE NEEDS ARE UNIQUE TO
EACH COMMUNITY THAT IS FACING
CHALLENGES.
THE SOLUTIONS FOR COMMUNITIES
WITH ARSENIC CONTAMINATED WELLS
IN EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY WILL
BE DIFFERENT THAN THOSE IT'S
THAN STEPS TAKEN TO ADDRESS
SMALL SYSTEMS AND URBAN LOS
ANGELES WITH AGING AN ADEQUATE
INFRASTRUCTURE OR COMMUNITIES
AND LIKE COUNTY.
LOOKING TO BUILD RESILIENCE IN
THE FRAGMENTED WATER SYSTEM SIR
CONSOLIDATION.
LASTLY I WANT TO ADDRESS
DIRECTLY THE CONCERN THAT I'VE
HEARD FROM SOME THAT THE WATER
FREE PROPOSED IN THE TRAILER
BILL WILL NOT DIRECTLY BENEFIT
COMMUNITIES THAT ALREADY HAVE.
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER OF
CALIFORNIANS WE HAVE A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND AS CALIFORNIANS WE ALL PAY
FOR A WIDE RANGE OF PUBLIC GOODS
AND SERVICES.
EVEN THROUGH EVEN THOUGH SOME
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAMS
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFIT SOME
COMMUNITIES MORE THAN OTHERS.
JUST AS PEOPLE IN REAL PARTS OF
THE STATE HELP PAPER STORM WATER
PROJECTS PRIMARY BENEFIT URBAN
AREAS THROUGH BONDS.
IT IS JUST AS REAL RISK
REASONABLE AND APPROPRIATE FOR
PEOPLE IN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO ALREADY HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER TO CONTRIBUTE A
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY. TO HELP
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT DO NOT
YET HAVE ACCESS.
IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THIS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED
PROPOSES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO ESTABLISH A NEW SPECIAL FUND.
FOR THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
ASSIST COMMUNITIES PARTICULAR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
PAYING FOR SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM COSTS OF ATTAINING ACCESS
TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
STATUTORY LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH
A PROGRAM THE PRICE GRANTS LOANS
IN ADMINISTRATOR CONTRACTS OR
SERVICES TO ASSIST ELIGIBLE
COMMUNITIES AND HOUSEHOLDS AND
SECURING ACCESS TO SAFE AND
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET PROPOSES
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND FOR THE STATE WATER
BOARD IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO TAKE INITIAL
STEPS TOWARD IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS NEW PROGRAM INCLUDING.
ONE DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
FEE COLLECTION SYSTEMS TO
ADOPTION OF AN ANNUAL
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN AND THREE
DEVELOPMENT OF A MAP OF HIGH
WITH HIGH RISK AQUIFER'S USES
DRINKING WATER SOURCES.
WE HAVE TO ADD ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
LA L. SEAN MARTIN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
KAREN ALICE'S AT THIS AT THIS
PROPOSAL WE HAVE SOME COMMENTS
AND SOME ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
A FIRST SO IT'S UNCERTAIN THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THE PROPOSED
REVENUES WILL FULLY ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS.
THAT ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
COMPLETED AN ESTIMATE OF THE
TOTAL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
BRINGING WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UNABLE TO ME WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS INTO
COMPLIANCE --
ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
THEY WERE FUNDED LAST FALL TO
UNDERTAKE A STUDY --
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT IT WILL
BE COMPLETED IN THE FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY AND IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH AND THEY
INDICATED THAT SOME PARTS OF THE
STUDY MAY BE AVAILABLE SOONER.
WE KNOW THAT A PRIVATE
CONSULTING FIRM DID AN ESTIMATE
AND THEY ESTIMATED IT WOULD COST
A HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION.
HOWEVER THAT ESTIMATE IS HIGHLY
UNCERTAIN AND SO IT'S POSSIBLE
THE ACTUAL COSTS COULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER OR LOWER
THAN THE ESTIMATES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TODAY.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT MOST CHARGE
PAIRS WOULD NOT BE DIRECT
BENEFICIARIES OF THE OF THE
PROGRAM --
THE MAIN BENEFICIARIES OF THE
PROGRAM WOULD BE PEOPLE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
SIR BY SMALLER WATER SYSTEMS
WOULD BE BORNE BY TWO GREAT
PAIRS ACROSS THE STATE WITH AND
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS FOR LOW
INCOME PERSONS AND CUSTOMERS --
ASSISTANCE WITH LESS THAN TWO
HUNDRED CONNECTIONS SO.
GENERALLY SPEAKING THEIR WEIGHT
COULD BE SOME BENEFIT TO FOLKS
SERVICE IN AN AREA WHERE THE
THIS PROGRAM HAS BROUGHT THE
WATER SYSTEM INTO COMPLIANCE BUT
MOST OF THE RATE PAYERS IN THE
STATE.
WOULDN'T BE BENEFITING IT TOOK
FROM IT THIS PROGRAM DIRECTLY IN
TERMS OF IN MAKING IMPROVEMENTS
TO THEIR WATER SYSTEM.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT SOME OF THE
CHARGE PAIRS.
WOULD NOT BE AT FAULT FOR THE
CONTAMINATION BE MEDICAID AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THE
VAST MAJORITY OF NITRATE
CONTAMINATION IS CAUSED BY
AGRICULTURAL ACTIVITY SUCH AS
FERTILIZER APPLICATIONS AND ANIL
MODERATION SEARCHES AS DAIRIES.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
HAVE THESE AGRICULTURAL ENTITIES
PLAY CHARGES CREATES A NICE LINK
BETWEEN THE OPERATIONS THAT ARE
THE MAIN SOURCE OF THE NITRATE
CONTAMINATION.
AND THE ENTITIES THAT WOULD PAY
THE CHARGES TO MEDICATE IT
HOWEVER IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING
THAT SOME OF THAT NITRATE
CONTAMINATION WOULD NOT BE A
DIRECT RESULT OF THEIR
OPERATIONS IT COULD HAVE BEEN.
THAT SOME OF THE CONTAMINATION A
WAS FROM A LEGACY CONTAMINATION
FROM DECADES AGO --
WE LOOKED AT ALTERNATIVE SOURCES
OF FUNDING THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE AVAILABLE TO PAY
FOR THE PROGRAM.
I GENERALLY WE DIDN'T FIND WE
FOUND THAT THERE LIMITED --
GENERAL FUND IS AN ALTERNATIVE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE PROGRAM
HOWEVER THE PROGRAM WOULD HAVE
TO COMPETE WITH OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT RELY ON THE GENERAL FUND.
OF FOR SUPPORT [inaudible]
AND WE DON'T THINK THAT BOND
FUNDING IS APPROPRIATE FOR FOR
THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE OF THE ONE
TIME NATURE OF THAT --
BOND FUND IT AND THIS PROGRAM
REQUIRES AN ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE.
AND WE HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED ANY
EXISTING SPECIAL FUNDS THAT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO SUPPORT
THIS PROGRAM IT WOULD HAVE
SUFFICIENT AVAILABLE FUNDS --
FINALLY WE ALSO NOTE THAT THERE
AS BECAUSE OF SAFE HARBOR
PROVISIONS ABOUT SOME TRADE OFFS
COMPARED TO THE STATE'S CURRENT
ENFORCEMENT APPROACH.
ON THE ONE HAND THE PROPOSAL IS
STRUCTURED TO BETTER ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE. FOR WATER
QUALITY MITIGATION THROUGHOUT
THE STATE RATHER THAN LIMITED
AIR AREAS AND IN CERTAIN AREAS
IN THE STATE YES BECAUSE THE
STATE'S CURRENT ENFORCEMENT
APPROACH.
I GENERALIZE AND TARGETING
INDIVIDUAL OR GROUPS OF
POLLUTERS IN A LIMITED
GEOGRAPHIC AREA --
FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE REALLY
USES CLEAN UP IN A DATE IN ORDER
FOR NITRATE CONTAMINATION ON THE
OTHER HAND THE THE PROPOSAL.
THE STATE WOULD RELINQUISH
AUTHORITY TO TAKE CERTAIN
ENFORCEMENT ACTION SUCH AS CLEAN
UP IN A BASEMENT ORDERS AGAINST
POLLUTERS IF THERE OTHERWISE
COMPLYING WITH THEIR POLITICAL
PERMITAN WAIVERS IN THIS WITH
LIMITS THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD'S.
AUTHORITY.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE COMMENTS.
OF ANY QUESTIONS --
LET'S TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT I MAY
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AFTER PUBLIC
COMMENT I KNOW THERE'S SOME
FOLKS WHO WANT TO SPEAK ON THIS
WHOLE LOOK AT THAT I WAS RIGHT.
BACK UP WITH THAT PLEASE.
THIS IS A SERIES OF PROPOSALS --
THAT HAS --
CREATED A SITUATION WHERE
EVERYBODY HAS SOMETHING TO BE
UNHAPPY ABOUT.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM AND
MEMBERS CINDY TECH WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE OF THE WATER
TAX PART OF THE LANGUAGE.
WE AGREE WITH THE GOVERNOR THAT
THERE IS A PROBLEM WE AGREE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE ACTION THIS
YEAR ON THE FUNDING SOLUTION.
BUT THIS CAN BE SOLVED WITHOUT A
WATER TAX.
THE WATER TAX PART OF THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS VERY
SIMILAR TO THE A LANGUAGE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION LAST YEAR
WITH GOVERNOR BROWN ADVANCED.
YOU'LL RECALL THAT THE FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WERE HERE LAST YEAR
YOU'LL RECALL THAT THE JOINT
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
REJECTED THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
WATER TAX LANGUAGE IN IT.
ON THE MERITS THREE QUICK POINTS
WE DON'T THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO
TAX A RESOURCE THAT'S ESSENTIAL
TO LIVING THE STATE DOESN'T TAX
YOUR TAP WATER AT HOME IT
DOESN'T TAX.
YOUR FOOD WHEN YOU GO TO THE
GROCERY STORE.
ANOTHER POINT IS THE HUMAN RIGHT
TO WATER PROVIDES A RIGHT TO
BOTH SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER --
THE TAX IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
COSTS FOR IT WOULD ADD TO THE
COST WATER THE WAY IT'S PROPOSED
IT WOULD HAVE ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND LOCAL SYSTEMS ACROSS
THE STATE IMPLEMENT IT.
SO YOU WOULD HAVE EACH OF THOSE
SYSTEMS PAYING TO CHANGE THE
SOFTWARE THAT CAN BE FOR SOME
SYSTEMS A HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR
SOME MORE SOME LESS.
ALSO HIRING A STAFF PERSON IN
SOME CASES MORE THAN ONE STAFF
PERSON TO IMPLEMENT THE TAX WHEN
YOU MULTIPLY THE COST TIMES
THREE THOUSAND AGENCIES THE
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS SKYROCKET.
AND THAT MAKES WATER YOU KNOW IT
ADDS TO THE COST OF WATER MAKING
IT ON AFFORDABLE.
SO FINALLY THE LAST POINT IS
THIS WOULD BE THE PRESIDENT FOR
A STATE TAX ON WATER IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THERE'S A
BETTER APPROACH SENATOR CAFIERO
HAS SB SIX SIX NINE WHICH WOULD
CREATE THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
TRUST.
AND THAT COULD REPLACE THE
PROPOSED WATER TAX AWKWARD IN
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION ARE SPONSORING THAT
BILL YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT THE
TRUST FROM DANIEL GLASS IT.
BUT IN CLOSING AWKWARD WOULD
REQUEST THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
REJECT THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
BECAUSE OF THE WATER TAX PART.
THE OTHER PARTS WERE OKAY WITH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR KEEPING YOUR
COMMENTS CONCISE AS WE HAVE SO
MANY PEOPLE AND A LIMITED AMOUNT
OF TIME TO HEAR YOU ALL.
WE DO WANT --
TO ADJOURNED THE MEETING BY
ABOUT NOON --
I'LL ASK YOU TO TRY AND KEEP
YOUR COMMENT.
NOT MORE THAN TWO MINUTES BUT IF
YOU KEEP TO WANDER LAST THAT
WOULD BE.
GREAT OKAY HERE SOMEBODY ELSE --
SAY SOMETHING THAT --
YOU AGREE WITH YOU CAN POINT TO
THEM AND AGREE WITH THEM OKAY
GREAT DANIEL BLASTED HAYDN WITH
CMU WAY.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AENDED POSITION AS WELL
BECAUSE OF THE PROPOSED WATER
TAX THERE IS AN ALTERNATIVE SB
SIX SIX NINE CREATES A SAFE
DRINKING WATER TRUST USING
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS DURING A
BUDGET SURPLUS YEAR --
WE UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS ABOUT
UTILIZING GENERAL FUND FOR
SOLUTION AS AN ONGOING SOLUTION
BACK TO THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
TRUST WOULD HAVE A GENERAL AND
AT ONE TIME OR MAYBE OVER TWO
YEARS AND FUSION OF GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS SO IT WOULD NOT BE
ONGOING.
IT WOULD JUST BE THAT INITIAL
INFUSION UNLIKE THE WATER TAX
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL AS TRUST IS NOT ADD TO THE
COST OF WATER FOR CALIFORNIANS
IT'S PROGRESSIVE INSTEAD OF THE
REGRESSIVE WATER TAX AND A
PROGRESSIVE FUNDING SOURCE TO US
MAKES MORE SENSE.
WE AGREED THAT THIS IS A YEAR TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND YOU CAN
SOLVE IT WITHOUT A WATER TAX
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU AND
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THERE'S
THIRTY OR FORTY PEOPLE OUTSIDE
OR WHEN THE SO.
THANK YOU FOR UNDERSTANDING AND
KEEPING YOUR COMMENTS CONCISE
YES COMMENTS WILL BE VERY
CONCISE A GOOD MORNING HERE IN
MEMBERS DIRECT ALL OF HIM HALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES -- I
DO WANT TO LINE MY COMMENTS WITH
US.
AQUA AND SAY THAT THE LEAGUE --
DOES OF COURSE SUPPORT --
SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS HOWEVER WE DO HAVE
A ISSUE WITH THE TAX PORTION OF
THIS TRAILER BILL AND DO REQUEST
THAT -- THAT
BE TAKEN OUT SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING THERESA RIVAGE
ON BEHALF OF CERES.
BOTH ARE BUSINESS PARTNERS AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES RELY ON SAFE IN
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES SO FOR THAT
THEY ARE IN SUPPORT I'M ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAN
SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUALLY
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE TODAY --
AND WE SUPPORT --
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HI AS
WE'VE SUPPORTED IT LAST YEAR --
WILL WITH GOVERNOR BROWN
ADMINISTRATION HOW WE DO THINK
NOW IS THE TIME TO ACT.
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST SIMPLY
POINT OUT --
THE ISSUE OF THE SAFE HARBOR FOR
AGRICULTURE --
THIS IS A IN AN AGREED UPON
APPROACH THAT JUST COME WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WORKING WITH
THE THE TECHNICAL STAFF IN THE
EXPERTS THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AS A MEANS IN AND AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MOST EFFICIENTLY ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF NITRATE CONTAMINATION
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN IN SALINAS
VALLEY'S.
THERE IS NO --
TAKEN AWAY OR REDUCTION OF
ENFORCEMENT --
BECAUSE IN ORDER TO ACT IT'S
THOSE IN AGRICULTURE HAVE TO BE
UNDER OTHER REGULATORY SCHEMES
THAT WILL ULTIMATELY GET TO THE
GOALS OF REDUCED FERTILIZER --
ACTIVITY IN THE STATE AND
CLEANER AQUIFER'S IN THE STATE
SO IT IS A COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT WHEN THE TIME COMES.
HELLO CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RACHEL SMITH
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF FIRST SELF
HELP ENTERPRISES WHO IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND.
I'M ALSO HERE AS WELL --
WITH WORLD COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION AND NON PROFIT THAT
WORKS IN CALIFORNIA WITH A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DISADVANTAGED
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS.
THIS FIND WOOD --
POTENTIALLY BENEFIT THOUSANDS OF
THOSE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
CURRENTLY OUT OF COMPLIANCE AND
BRING OF WATER THAT IS ALREADY
BEING PAID FOR BY THOSE SMALL
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE URGE
SUPPORT AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
SULLIVAN SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT IS SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR TO SB SIX TWENTY THREE
FROM LAST YEAR THAT WOULD CREATE
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUND.
AS WELL AS A PROPOSED FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND FOR THE ONE TIME ALLOCATION
I WOULD JUST ALSO LIKE TO
QUICKLY THINK OF THE CHAIR OF
THE WATER BOARD FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND I LIKE SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT HE MADE AS TO WHY
THIS.
ISSUE IS SO IMPORTANT THEY'RE IN
ESTIMATED ONE MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
AN ESTIMATED ONE IN FOUR SCHOOLS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHO HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED BY SEN UNSAFE
DRINKING WATER AND AS MANY AS
THREE HUNDRED PUBLIC WATER.
SYSTEMS HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
DON'T MEET THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR SAFE DRINKING
WATER -- WE
THINK IN A STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA
THAT WORLD THAT THAT IS AN
ACCEPTABLE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO ENGAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION BOTH THE CHAIR AS
WELL AS THE NEW SECRETARIES MR
BLUMENFELD.
AND MISTER CRAWFORD ON THE ISSUE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA PAUSE
REALLY QUICKLY --
TO ALLOW MEMBERS WHO MAY NEED TO
LEAVE SHORTLY TO ADD ON OF THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN SO ENOUGH TO
WORRY ABOUT THIS.
ONE ITEMS TO BE HEARD ISSUE
ELEVEN CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO
SURE VOTING AYE GARCIA.
ISSUE TWELVE CURRENT VOTE TWO
ONE CHAIR VOTING AYE GARCIA.
ISSUE THIRTEEN CURRENT VOTE TWO
ISSUE FOURTEEN CURRENT VOTE FOUR
ZERO CHORE VOTING AYE GARCIA.
ISSUE FIFTEEN CURRENT VOTE TO
ONE SURE VOTING AYE GARCIA.
ISSUE SIXTEEN CURRENT VOTE TO
ISSUE SEVENTEEN CURRENT VOTE TO
TO CHAIR VOTING AYE GARCIA.
THANK YOU PLEASE.
BUT MR CHEN MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTIST --
AS WE DID LAST YEAR WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN'S PROPOSAL WE'RE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT GOVERNOR
NUISANCE PROPOSAL ENCOURAGE
DRIVE A THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DONNA SO THAT
SOMEONE WATER DISTRICT WE SHARE
THE OPINIONS OF AQUA WE OPPOSE
THE BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE --
DUE TO THE INCLUSION OF THE
WATER TAX.
SIR CHAIR MEMBERS DON GILBERT
FOR ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
I WANTED TO TOUCH ON THE SAFE
HARBOR FOR AG.
THE SAFE HARBOR FOR AG IS GREAT
FOR THEM BUT FOR THE RATE PAYERS
WHO WOULD BE MAKING UP THE
POTENTIAL DID DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE COST TO ADDRESS THE NITRATE
CONTAMINATION.
AND WHAT AG IS PAYING ITS A
CRUMBLING HARBOR IT'LL CAST
THEIR VOTES A DRAFT AND WE
SHOULD CARE ABOUT THEM.
TOO IN THE CITY IN THE CITY'S
WITH HEAT WITH VERY SUBSTANTIAL
COST OF LIVING IN THIS STATE AND
HOUSING COSTS THAT WE'RE ALL
CONCERNED ABOUT FOR SOME PEOPLE
EVERY PENNY COUNTS.
NO TAX IS IS IS GOING TO BE LOW.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRICIA GUARANTOR WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE AND THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION ONE BEGIN BY BRIEFLY
KNOWLEDGE AND REALLY RECOGNIZING
THE FACT THAT PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE ON THIS ISSUE WE HEARD
ABOUT SOME THESE EFFORTS EARLIER
TODAY BILLS LIKE AB TWENTY FIVE
A ONE CONSIDERED BY THE LODGE
THE LATER.
LAST YEAR ARE NOW MAKING A
DIFFERENCE THERE IS THIS
CRITICAL UNMET NEED HOWEVER WE
THINK THE ELEMENTS OF
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED TO YOU TODAY BETWEEN
THE WATER BOARD PRESENTATION
SOME OF STAKEHOLDERS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM.
THINGS LIKE MAPPING OUT HIGH
RISK AREAS IS IMPORTANT SETTING
UP A PROGRAM BY WHICH THE WATER
BOARD CAN GET THE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THESE RESOURCES THOSE
RESOURCES IS APPROPRIATE.
ON ISSUES LIKE THE FUNDING
SOURCE WE AGREE IN A WIDER
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES AND KEPT US THE ANYWAY
WE DON'T THINK IT TAXES THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO ABOUT DOING THIS
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MERION WARMER I REPRESENT THE
REAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE A COALITION OF
THIRTY SIX COUNTIES AT THIRTY
SIX OF THE FIFTY EIGHT MANY OF
THE COMMUNITIES AFFECTED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
OUR IN OUR COUNTIES --
AND IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE FIND
AN APPROACH THAT WILL SERVE
THEIR NEEDS AS WELL AS MAINTAIN
A VIABLE ECONOMIC --
IN ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY WHICH IS
ONE OF OUR KEY CORNERSTONES IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC BIGGER IN OUR
COUNTIES.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
SUPPORTED GOVERNOR BROWN'S
PROPOSAL AS WE CONTINUE TO DO
WITH GOVERNOR NEWS SOME THANK
YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSAL AND IN SUPPORT
OF THE CREATION OF A SAFE IN A
FORMAL DRINKING WATER FIND.
CLEAN WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND
IS YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM OF THE
NORTH THAT GUY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES IN THERE AND THE
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS ALLIANCE
WE REPRESENT MOSTLY SYSTEMS THAT
ARE DISADVANTAGED AROUND THE
STATE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE POLICY
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADVANCED ACROSS THE BOARD ARE --
GOING TO TRIGGER A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM.
PRIMARILY BECAUSE IT EXT TERMS
UNDER PROP ONE AND PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT COMMUNITIES WITH
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND RESIDENTS
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR GRANTS AND
SO WE URGE YOU TO ADOPT
PROVISIONS THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT --
THAT WOULD ALLOW THESE
COMMUNITIES TO APPLY IF THEY
MEET A CERTAIN THRESHOLD OF
BEING DISADVANTAGED.
IT WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE
ECONOMIES OF SCALE ON
CONSOLIDATIONS AS WELL.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
AVERT A RACE TO THE BOTTOM IF
THE WATER BOARD ADOPTED
STRATEGIC COMPLIANCE PLANS WHEN
THEY ADOPT NEW REGULATIONS THAT
ACTUALLY STIPULATE HOW THEY WILL
DEPLOY.
THEIR RESOURCES IN TERMS OF
GRANTS AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO SYSTEMS THAT CAN AFFORD THE
REMEDIES FOR NEW REGULATIONS
BECAUSE WE FEAR THAT ONCE YOU
ADDRESS THIS LOG OF THREE
HUNDRED SYSTEMS THAT ARE
CHRONICALLY DISADVANTAGED.
YOU'RE JUST GONNA BE HERE NOT IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE FOLKS
WILL BE --
TESTIFYING BEHIND ME.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT --
THERE'S A PRACTICAL REASON FOR
NOT ADOPTING THE TAX --
FIRST IT HAS TO DO WITH THE YET
TO BE COMPLETED --
ASSESSMENT THAT THE STATE WATER
BOARD HAS PENDING FOR TWENTY
TWENTY AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
TRUST FUND COULD BE SEAT FUNDED
AND THEN ADOPTED LATER --
TO MEET THE FUNDING REQUIREMENTS
THAT THE STUDY WOODS A STIPULATE
SO WE WANT TO THANK YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS IF IT'S
AMENDED THANK YOU.
BRIAN --
JACKING WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY ARE W. A. IS A JOINT
POWERS ASSOCIATION COMPRISED OF
TWENTY ONE SACRAMENTO AREA WATER
SUPPLIERS.
PROVIDING DRINKING WATER TO AND
AREA OUR MISSION IS TO RELY WE
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY WATER.
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME LEMENTS OF
THE HUMAN RIGHTS WATER.
OUR CONCERN IS THE FUNDING
SOURCE BEING A TAX IT'S GOING TO
MAKE IT MORE CHALLENGING FOR US
TO DO THAT TO ACHIEVING RIGHT
WATER.
WE SUPPORT A SOLUTION WE ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH COMMENTS OF
AUCKLAND SEEM USA WE BELIEVE
THAT A VIABLE SOLUTION AS THE
TRUST FUND THANKS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S OF PAUL
THE MEASURE I'M WITH --
SUBURBAN WATER SYSTEMS --
COMPANY THAT SUPPLIES WATER --
TO CAMINO WAS GIVING A LOS
ANGELES SORRY CAMINO WAS CAMINO
WOULD YOUR LONG MARADA AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY --
WE STAND FIRMLY AGAINST --
THE WATER TAX --
BECAUSE IN OUR REGIONS THE
RESIDENTS --
ARE ALREADY PAYING TO CLEAN UP
THE NATION'S LARGEST U. S. EPA
SUPERFUND SITE.
AND THEN ALSO AS AS WELL AS WHAT
ALREADY HAS BEEN STATED --
WE BELIEVE THAT THINGS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO HUMAN WILL BEINGS --
SHOULD NOT BE TAXED --
WE SB SIX SIX NINE BUT BECAUSE
THE TRUCKS WERE PROVIDED DURABLE
AND ADOPTABLE FUND FUNDING
SOURCE TO HELP COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
I THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LINDA NORIEGA WITH
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WATER
COMPANY WE OPERATE A HIGH
EFFICIENCY WATER SYSTEM THAT
PROVIDES WATER TO THE AREAS OF
BRAILLE Là HARPER AND PORTIONS
OF THE CITY OF WHITTIER Là
MARADA.
WE STAND FIRMLY AGAINST THE
STATE WIDE WATER TAX AND WHAT IS
BEING PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL --
WE LOOK AT IT AS TAX REVENUE
THAT'S GOING TO BE REMOVED FROM
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SERVE AND THEN SPREAD
NOW LOCATED ACROSS DIFFERENT
AREAS OF THE STATE.
IN THAT RESPECT WE SUPPORT THE
TRUSTFUND THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED
BY SENATOR COUPLE YEAH ROLE IN
SB SIX SIX NINE BECAUSE WILL
PROVIDE AN ADAPTABLE FUNDING
SOURCE. FOR THE COMMUNITIES IN
THAT DISADVANTAGED AREAS AND
PROVIDE THEIR CUSTOMERS WITH
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER --
ALSO IN THAT WE BELIEVE THAT IT
IS THE SAFEST APPROACH BECAUSE
THE TRUST PRINCIPLES AND THE NET
INCOME IN SEED FUNDING FROM THE
STATE BUDGET SURPLUS COULD BE
TRANSFERRED.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS TO THE STATE
DRINKING WATER FUND THAT WOULD
BE ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AND IF NEEDED THERE COULD BE
OTHER SOURCES OF FUNDING
DEVELOPED AS WELL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KELLY
GARDNER AND ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY FOR THE SINGULAR VALUE
WATER ASSOCIATION.
I ECHO THE COMMENTS OF HIS
ORTEGA AND MISS NORIEGA'S WELL
THAT IT'S OUR AGENCY AS OPPOSED
TO THE WATER TAX --
ALTERNATIVELY WE SUGGEST THE
CAVIAR --
SIX SIX NINE BILL --
PROVIDES AN AFFORDABILITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY --
FOR ESSENTIAL.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
ESSENTIAL ITEMS FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SHARED MISIA'S SOME WITH --
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF UTILITIES
FORCES SELECT WATER.
WE'RE MUNICIPAL UTILITY THAT
SERVES A HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
IN THE CITY OF AZUSA PORTIONS OF
COVINA WEST COVINA GLENDORA
IRWINDALE AN UNINCORPORATED LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
I'M ALSO DIRECTOR WITH THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY A WATER SO
SITUATION.
AND AS AN ASSOCIATION WE TAKE A
STAND AGAINST A WATER TAX.
AS THE COMMENTS MENTION WE WE
DON'T THINK IT'S SOUND POLICY TO
TAX IN THE CENTRAL A LIFE
RESOURCE LIKE WATER.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
MANDATED THE STATE WATER BOARD
CONDUCT A NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
OF CHRONICALLY FEELING WATER
SYSTEMS WHICH IS DUE SOMETIME IN --
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
ASSESS A TAX ON WATER USERS
WITHOUT KNOWING THE COST IS NOT
ADVISABLE.
AS A VIABLE ALTERNATIVE WE
SUPPORT THE CONCEPTS PRESENTED
IN SB SIX SIX NINE BY SENATOR
CAPPIELLO.
BECAUSE THE TRUST ENVISION WILL
PROVIDE A DURABLE AND ADAPTABLE
FUNDING SOURCE TO HELP COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS.
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
SERVE THEIR FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SHOULD BE
THOUGHTFUL IN ITS APPROACH AND
TAKE A CONCRETE STEP INTO
CLEARING THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER.
AS A PRIORITY BY SUPPORTING THE
TRUE BUT WHICH HAS NO REGRETS.
APPROACH NO MATTER THE OUTCOME
OF THE SEA WATER BOARDS NEEDS
AND COST ASSESSMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA PAUSE
QUICKLY --
TO ALLOW MISTER FUNK TO ADD ON
TO I THINK TWO BILLS.
ARE TWO ITEMS RATHER.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE ONE CURRENT VOTE
FOUR ZERO CHAIR VOTING I FONG.
VOTE ONLY ISSUES TWO THROUGH
SEVEN ITEMS TO BE HEARD ISSUES
TO THROUGH.
FOR CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO SURE
VOTING AYE FONG.
THANK YOU SORRY FOR THE
INTERRUPTION.
I'M ERIN GO OVER WITH THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
AND WE WOULD SIMPLY ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF ALL QUINCY ANYWAY.
YOU ARE NOW THAT WAS THAT WAS
PERFECT TESTIMONY.
THIS WILL BE SIMILAR --
YOU ARE NOT THINKING TINY HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE IRVINE RANCH
WATER DISTRICT EAST VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT AND ALSO YUBA WATER
AGENCY AND OUR BELIEFS ARE IN
LINE WITH AKEL WITH RESPECT.
TO ASKING THE STATE TO NOT NOW
OR EVER CROSS THE BRIGHT LINE OF
TAXING WATER --
PARTICULAR IN A TIME OF
SUBSTANTIAL SURPLUS WHICH SHOULD
BE PROPERLY PRIORITIZE TO FUND
THE TRUST THANK YOU --
GOOD MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME'S JOSE MARTINEZ
ON ON THE GENERAL MANAGER ABOUT
LIKE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT WE
SERVE ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED CONNECTIONS TO A
POPULATION.
OF ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND THE CITY
BALLPARK OR WINDOWS CITY OF WEST
COVINA AND CITY BUSY SO --
I DO --
SUPPORTS --
BUT DONNA ORTEGA AND THIS.
NINE BECAUSE THE TRUST WOULD
PROVIDE AN ADAPTABLE FUNDING
SOURCE TO HELP COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS.
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
PROVIDE THEIR CUSTOMERS WITH
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER.
OUR DISTRICT --
STANDS FIRMLY AGAINST THE STATE
WATER TAX BECAUSE NOT SOUND
POLICY TO TAX ESSENTIAL WATER
RESOURCES LIKE WATER.
AND THIS TAX WILL HAVE AN IMPACT
ON THE AFFORDABILITY FOR WATER
FOR OUR CUSTOMERS.
OUR DISTRICT HAS WORKED
DILIGENTLY IN MINIMIZING RATE
ADJUSTMENTS OVER THE YEARS AND
CUSTOMERS PAY THEIR TRUE COSTA
WATER SERVICE RIGHT NOW.
IN THE SAME YEAR VALLEY WE HAVE
COLLECTIVELY WORK TO CLEAN UP
ONE OF THE NATION'S GROUNDWATER
LARGEST GROUNDWATER SUPERFUND
SITES -- TO
PROVIDE SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER TO OUR
DISADVANTAGE COMMITTEE I
COMMUNITIES.
WITH THIS WE SUPPORT SB SIX SIX
NINE AS A SOUND AFTER APPROACH
AND APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR SHARE IT ANYMORE
LEAN ON BEHALF THE SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY WATER AGENCIES MAY SO
WATER DISTRICT YOU SEEN GIVE A
VALUE MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT --
WHICH YOU ARE OPPOSED TO THE TAX
WE BELIEVE THE TRUST AS A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS AS YOU
KEEP THIS ITEM OPEN THANK YOU.
HELLO LOCAL CAN YOUR IS ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
OUR MEMBERS REPRESENT THE NON AG
FERTILIZER INDUSTRY --
AND WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
TO THE CURRENT PROPOSAL WE WOULD
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THE
LANGUAGE IN SB EIGHT FOUR FOUR
FROM LAST YEAR WHICH ASSESSES
THE NON COMMERCIAL FERTILIZERS
AT A LOWER RATE --
THE RESEARCH HAS NOT SHOWN THAT
THESE MATERIALS ARE CAN WATER
QUALITY IMPACTS AND WE BELIEVE --
THAT FORMULA IS A MORE EQUITABLE
FORMULA THANK YOU.
BUT SHARING AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SOME THE GENERAL MANAGER
OF LA PUENTE VALLEY COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT --
SANGER VALLEY REGION --
AND WE SERVE BUT NINETY FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE CONSIDER SMALL
WATER SYSTEM --
ALSO VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
SINGER VALLEY WATER ASSOCIATION
SO I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM.
MY PEERS --
FROM THE ASSOCIATION --
WANTING WITHIN I DON'T THINK WE
POINTED OUT AS IS SOCIAL ATION
IS MADE UP OF SIXTY WATER
SUPPLIERS IN THIRTY CITIES AND
SAYING WE'RE VALUE.
AREA A SERVICE WATER ABOUT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE SO --
WE ARE AGAINST THE WATER TAX --
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SIX SIX NINE
I THINK ONE THING MAYBE I WANT
TO POINT OUT COST OR AN EFFORT
THAT WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH
OBVIOUSLY TO EDUCATE OUR
CUSTOMERS.
IF THERE WAS A WATER TAX AND
JUST SAYS --
JOSE MARTINEZ FOR VALLEY COUNTY
POINT OUT IT'S AN EFFORT WE GO
THROUGH A PAINSTAKING EFFORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
CUSTOMERS UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE COST OF SERVICES AND
THAT WERE UTILIZING THAT MONEY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PROVIDE
GOOD SERVICE TO THEM SO?
ANYTHING --
THAT'S GOING TO INCREASE THEIR
COSTS IS OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT --
IS GOING TO BE HARD TO EXPLAIN.
I TO THEM BUT NOT ONLY THAT BUT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
KEEP --
THOSE REVENUES IN OUR COST YOU
KNOW LOCAL TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DRIVE DOWN THE COST
MINIMIZE INC AND FUTURE
INCREASES.
THANK VERY MUCH.
FOR TO GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GREG
ANDERSON OR IT WAS SACRAMENTO
SUBURBAN WATER DISTRICT
INTERVIEWS A LINE WITH AQUA SEE
IN YOU A AND THE SECOND REASON
WATER THIRTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME AND CHRIS
NELSON I REPRESENT COMICAL WATER
DISTRICT.
I TOO WOULD LIKE --
TO ECHO --
THE THE COMMENTS MADE BY OCT --
WE ARE OPPOSED TO ATTACKS BUT WE
DEFINITELY ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SAFE CLEAN RELIABLE DRINKING
WATER.
IT'S WHAT OUR SYSTEM HAS BEEN
DOING FOR OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING I'M SARAH JONES
WITH THE FOREIGN RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT I'M HERE --
TO TELL YOU THAT WE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH AWKWARD SEE ANYWAY
WE'RE OPPOSED TO STATEWIDE WATER
TAX AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SIX NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK NOMADIC ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF FIRST FELL IN OPPOSITION
TO THE WATER TAX PORTION.
I AM A LINE MY MAJORITY MY
COMMENTS WITH AQUA CMU A AND R.
W. A. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO PUT A
LITTLE IT OF A FINER POINT ON A
COMMENT THAT THEY AYE LEO MADE.
I WE HAVE ESTIMATED THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF THE
WATER TAX TO BE APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OF THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO PASS ON
BETWEEN EIGHTY THOUSAND AND
NINETY THOUSAND ON TO THE RATE
PAYERS.
THANK YOU.
MORNING CAROLYN JENSEN WITH KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
LESSONS WATER DISTRICT IN THE
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY.
WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
OAKLAND CA ANYWAY WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE TAX ON WATER IN SUPPORT
SB SIX SIX NINE THANK YOU.
JAMIE MINOR NEMO PAPPAS
ASSOCIATES FOR EASTER MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN SANTA
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT ALSO A
LINER COMMENTS WITH AQUA AND SEE
ME WAY --
OPPOSED TO WATER TAX BUT DO
BELIEVE IN SAFE DRINKING WATER
FOR ALL AND ALSO YOU KNOW OF
OPTIONS TO REMEDY THAT --
THERE ARE OTHER BILLS IN THE
LEGISLATURE LIKE SB FOUR ONE
FOUR THAT LOOK AT THE THE ROOT
CAUSES OF FAILING SYSTEMS IN THE
SMALL SYSTEM WATER AUTHORITY ACT
SO.
ALSO SUPPORT THAT EFFORT ALONG
WITH THE TRUST THINK THAT'S A
SUSTAINABLE PACKAGE TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S MARK I PERSON ON
GENERAL MANAGER WITH TONIGHT
WATER COMPANY IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY.
HAVE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
CUSTOMERS I SUPPORT MR NORIEGA
AND THIS IS A I MEAN MISTER DE.
MRS NORIEGA THANK YOU.
G. V. AIRS ON BEHALF OF BRIGHT
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AND
REPRESENTING YOU KNOW WESTERN
UNITED TOURNAMENT.
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION THEIR ORGANIZATIONS
ARE IN A SUPPORT IN CONCEPT --
POSITION ON THE BUDGET ITEM.
WE'RE SEEKING A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION THAT PROVIDES A SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FOUND IN THAT INCLUDES
MEANINGFUL FUNDING --
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
AND REGULATORY CERTAINTY FOR
DARIEN CALPERS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
RAQUEL I ALLOW WITH --
ELDORADO YOUR RECREATION
DISTRICT DE SER WATER AGENCY
ROLE ON WATER DISTRICT AND WHILE
NOT VALLEY WATER DISTRICT WE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS TO THOSE OF
AQUA AND SEE ANYWAY.
WHERE ARE NO POSITION --
OF A WATER TAXI AND WE SUPPORT
IS BEING NOT --
SIX SIX NINE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING --
PUBLIC OURS AND WEARING SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT HAVE THIS MORNING ON
BEHALF OF PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION WE WHO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THAT ENOUGH AND
THIS I'M WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BILL WITH THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND.
RAY CHOLISH TWENTY NINE PALMS
WATER DISTRICT GENERAL MANAGER --
WE SERVE OUR COMMUNITY A LARGE --
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY IN THE
MOJAVE THE FORM THAT WE SERVE A
POPULATION ABOUT EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE --
CURRENT PROPOSALS ADDRESSING
CHRONICALLY FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS LACKED THE CONSIDERATION
FOR THE VULNERABILITIES OF WELL
OPERATING SYSTEMS LIKE TWENTY
NINE PALMS --
WE'RE DEFINITELY AGAINST THE
WATER TAX WE DO SUPPORT THE
TRUST FUND HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT AMENDED TO ENSURE
THAT AGENCIES LIKE TWENTY NINE
PALMS WERE ELIGIBLE FOR SOME OF
THESE GRANTS THAT WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR NOW.
THROUGH PROP ONE AND PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT WITHOUT HELP AS IT'S
BEEN SAID BEFORE IT'S A RACE TO
THE BOTTOM WILL BE STANDING HERE
IN ANOTHER COUPLE YEARS THE WAY
WERE TRENDING.
AS ANOTHER FAMILY SYSTEM IF WE
CANNOT GET MORE HELP TO MEET THE
PRESSURES OF THE REGULATIONS
THANK YOU.
IT MIGHT BE GOOD AFTERNOON.
THE RIGHT MY NAME IS TIM GREEN
OUR PRESIDENT OF WESTERN HEIGHTS
WATER COMPANY --
THE REASON I'M SPEAKING TODAY IS
THAT I IN FAVOR OF OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE JUST
THE FUNDING MECHANISM I'M REALLY
UPSET WITH.
WITH ALL THE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
GSA THE BURDEN ON SMALL --
WATER COMPANIES SUCH AS MINE
ABOUT TWENTY ONE HUNDRED NOW
WITH A TOTAL BUILD OUT ABOUT.
FIFTY FIFTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED IN THE NEAR FUTURE AND I
SERVICE --
THE AREA --
YUCAIPA CALIFORNIA.
PARTS OF YOU COULD CALL WITH
ABOUT A 75% SENIORS ON FIXED
INCOME -- SO
ANY AMOUNT OF REYES --
IN COMPLAINTS TO STATE
REGULATIONS REALLY HIT A LOT OF
MY POPULATION EVEN FIVE BUCKS
HERE AND THERE EVEN.
AND I SO I AM ALSO IN FAVOR
AWKWARD POSITION ON THIS --
ALSO PAYER OF THE COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS ALLIANCE
OPPOSITION AND CAL MUTUALS
POSITION --
THE COST OF GIVING GETTING THESE
GRANTS LIKE PROP ONE IN SIXTY
EIGHT ARE SO PROHIBITIVE FOR ME
HIRING GRANT WRITERS AND ALL
THIS THIS STUFF.
AND THEN BECAUSE WE'RE ALWAYS
TRYING TO COMPLETELY --
COMPLY WITH THE GSA HAVING A TAX
IS JUST GOING TO BE ANOTHER
THING JUST HIT MY MY RATE
HOLDERS JUST AFTER WE'VE JUST
PUT TOGETHER A BUDGET.
OF FIVE YEAR OUT TRYING TO
COMPLY WITH ALL THE DEMANDS OF
THE GSA AND THE COST INVOLVED
WHICH ARE VERY EXPENSIVE.
SO AGAIN I'M IN FAVOR OF BEST --
SICK SB SIX SIX NINE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS FROM ALLEN DAVIS FROM
KEVIN I WATER DISTRICT.
DOWN BY PALM SPRINGS.
AND WERE GUESTS SO WATER TAX.
WERE A REAL SMALL COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE MAYBE A HUNDRED CLIENTS.
AND WERE VERY DISADVANTAGED
RETIRED PEOPLE.
AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN. FOR
TOTALLY IN FAVOR OF THE AB SIX
SIX NINE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JANICE TO TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE TIDEWATER
DISTRICT REGRETFULLY OPPOSED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR KEEP IT
SHORT JONATHAN NELSON ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY WATER CENTER
AND ALSO THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS FOR LOS
ANGELES.
WITH US TODAY ARE A NUMBER OF
IMPACTED CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
SAFE DRINKING WATER WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
AND WE THINK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU.
WHEN THE START OF THIS NUMBER OF
POLITICAL STATUS BANG WITH A
LEFT WITHOUT USED TO HOST OF THE
COLBERT UP WILL NOT A --
BIGGER PROXY MILLIMAN THING.
THREE TEN YEARS BEYOND THE HEIDI.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PEDRO
CUSS OUT AS I COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF EASTER ESSIE AND
I'VE BEEN LIVING THERE FOR
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY YEARS.
BUT A LITTLE THREE DANIELS.
MUSSELMAN OF QUEMADO SCANIA'S
QUINLAN THE BILL THAT I WORK
WITH MONOPOLY RENDON THE
THROTTLE.
YES TEMAS AQUI BUT UP WAY OUT
WAS WONDER THIS POLL NEARLY AS
PART OF THE METAL NAM HORROR I
WILL UNSAFE LEVELS ARE NITRATE
NO DRINKING WATER AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO IN SUPPORT OF THE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FOUND.
SIR -- COULD
I JUST ASK A QUICK QUESTION I
DON'T [inaudible]
SEND YOUR WE WENT A LOT OF THIS
LOW INCOME AND THE NUMBER THIS
FILM.
I DON'T RECOGNIZE THE NAME OF
YOUR COMMUNITY I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW --
AGAIN IF YOU COULD REPEAT THE
NAME AND TELL ME WHERE THAT
COMMUNITY HAS AND APPROXIMATE
POPULATION.
THE COMMUNITY IS EASTER ROSY IT
SERVED BY EASTER ROSY COMMUNITY
SERVICES DISTRICT IN THE
POPULATION IS APPROXIMATELY THE
SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE AND
GEOGRAPHICALLY WHERE IS THAT IN
THE STATE TULARE COUNTY THE
NORTHERN PART OF TULARE COUNTY.
THANK YOU ALWAYS LEARNING ABOUT
OUR OUR THE COMPLEXITIES.
OF OUR GREAT STATE.
SEATS.
NOT NICE TO ME AND YEAH YEAH.
AND THOSE WHO SUCCEED OKAY ET AT
PROBLEM MY SCRIPT AND I'M ALSO
OF THE RATHER THAN I WHEN WE OUT
THOUGH.
THE THE THREAT OF MONEY OUT OF
THIS.
HE CALIFORNIA'S AS A FUND ALL
THE SYSTEM THE MENTAL PART OUT
THEN AND I WILL BE.
MUCH OF IT AS THIS.
MY NAME IS FELIPE GONZALEZ I'M
ALSO FROM THE COMMUNITY OF
EASTER OC AND WE'VE BEEN DEALING
FOR A VERY LONG TIME WITH HIGH
LEVELS OF NITRATE IN OUR WATER
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
SUSTAINABLE WATER FUND THANK YOU.
THE STATUS NUMBER IS GONNA BE
BECAUSE THAT IS.
IT I MEAN BANGLA COMMUNITY THAT
THEY START ALSO.
HE OF ONE GOAL.
UP FOR YOUR AND FUNGAL.
BUT A LOT AS WITH ANY MENTAL
THAT I WILL.
AND OVER THE NAY ON USE BVM GO.
EN LA COMPANY THAT IS TOTAL SEE.
MY NAME IS BENEDICTO COMES PASS
OUT AS I'M ALSO FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF EASTER OC AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
SUSTAINABLE DRINKING WATER FUND.
AND I'VE BEEN LIVING FOR
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY NINE YEARS
IN THE EASTER OC.
HE TOM YAM WAS MOM WAS.
NO MOTHER WHEN I THINK OF THEM
WHEN I WORK ON ANOTHER THAT CAN
MOST OF WHEN IT WOULD DELIST OUT
ABOUT THE MODERN NOT.
ONE NOT A MONTH BUT A ABOUT A
ROBOT BUT I GOT A YOUNG OF THE
ECM BUT IT WAS JUST THE NAME OF
ANAKIN'S THAT'S I MEAN YES.
HE IT BELONGS ALTURAS WAS OUT OF
THE ONE I WHAT FOOD I SAID WOULD
HAVE.
BEEN US YES. FOR OVER TWELVE
YEARS OUR COMMUNITY HAS AND SAY
IT HAS HAS HAD WATER THAT WE
CAN'T DRINK WE PAY A REGULAR
WATER BILL FOR WATER THAT WE CAN
ONLY USE TO WASH CLOTHING AND TO
BETH AND WE URGE THIS COMMITTEE --
TO TO TO THE TO PASS THE FUND
FOR A SOLUTION AS QUICK AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED THIS MAY NUMBER A
IS IT A LAND THAT THESE MEN?
IT'S LATE THOUGH TO SEE THAT
ONLY FOR MEDIA IN BY STYLE YEAH
IT'LL SAY ON IF THE YANKEE.
BUT A APPLE YET IF ONLY I WAS
THE THING THAT.
DEMOCRATS YES WHEN AFTER.
MY NAME IS A LINE THE MAIN THE
ARE IS MANDY.
AND I AM LIVING IN BY SALIH OVER
MY FAMILY HAS BEEN LIVING FOR
OVER TWELVE YEARS AND I'M HERE
AND TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
SUSTAINABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
THANK YOU.
HI MICHAEL LINES IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP AND
THE TEARS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE ON BEHALF OF THE WATER
FOUNDATION.
FRY WATER AUTHORITY HILMAR
CHEESE COMPANY IN DERRY
INSTITUTE THANK YOU.
WHEN AT THE LEAVE ME NUMEROUS
MEDIA MAYBE NOT?
LEGAL IN LITTLE SEE YOU'VE ALL
BEEN DANIEL YES THE YANKEE
GETTING AND I'M WANTING BE.
WITH THEM THE LAN Là LOCAL AND
WHEN ATTENDING IT IS YES
[inaudible]
MAYBE NOT.
MY NAME IS NEOVIA MEDINA I LIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY OF ROSY AND I'M
HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT MY
NEIGHBORS AN EASTER OC --
SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER --
AND I'M HERE AND TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE SUSTAINABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND THANK YOU.
UNLESS THE NEW NUMBER IS THE ONE
I'M OF ANYA VILLA LOCAL MANY
OTHERS LISTA VIA.
AND CANNELLA BLOODY.
EVEN WILL.
THEN LOOK WHAT AND THEY ARE
TRYING TO BE AND ALL.
AND THAT THE LAW THAT.
IS SOLELY PREVENT THAT APPLE'S
OF BRAVADO.
IS THE MICHAEL DEMEANOR NO.
MY NAME IS AMONG THEM A GAGNE I
COME FROM THE COMMUNITY OF
SEVILLE IN TULARE COUNTY.
AND I HAVE A DOMESTIC IS
CONTAMINATED AND HAVE BEEN
LIVING IN THIS HOME FOR
APPROXIMATELY FORTY EIGHT YEARS.
EVEN GOAL.
IS CLEAR KEEPING UP WITH YET AND
REALLY IS BETTER THAN THAT I
WILLIAM PS ON THE U. ECONOMICA.
GIVE BOTH PHOTOS I USE IN.
A DINNER BUT I TOLD CALIFORNIA
AND ANOTHER MUST BE THE BUT ON
THE COMPANY THAT.
IT'LL BUT BILL BUT AT THE LITTLE.
LITTLE OF CALIFORNIA GOOD THING
ALMOST I WOULD IMPAIR ECONOMIC A
MUCH OF THAT OFFICE.
AND I'M HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SUSTAINABLE IN
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
I'M NOT JUST ASKING FOR MYSELF
OR JUST MY COMMUNITY I'M HERE
ASKING FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU.
WHEN I THOUGHT OF THE MEAN
NUMBER THAT MIGHT REALLY GOING
GOAL THEY WILL PROBABLY GET THE
TO KEEP UP WITH THE AMOUNT OF
WITH BEER?
CANNELLA THAT THE BLOODY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARK
MARK THE KOREA AND I COME FROM A
SMALL COMMUNITY AND TULARE
COUNTY NAMED WOULD FILL.
I'VE BEEN GOING TO THINK WHY NOT
BE IN THE EATING I KNOW CANNELLA
ONE WE CONFIRM NOW THAT.
YOU'LL GET --
GET MEETING YET THOUGH.
DOMINO WANTING YEAH.
I'VE BEEN LIVING IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AND THE WATER HAS BEEN
CONTAMINATED FOR FIFTEEN OF
THOSE YEARS I WANT TO LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY WHERE MY GRANDCHILDREN
CAN DRINK SAFE WATER.
EVEN WHAT FORGET ONE THOUGH BUT
OFTEN THAT I WON YEAH IN
CALIFORNIA GOOD ACTORS.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
THE FUND TO STAB SAFE DRINKING
WATER AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LUCY
HERNANDEZ AND I COME FROM THE
COMMUTER WEST GOSHEN THIS ISN'T
TULARE COUNTY I LIVE IN TULARE
COUNTY ALL MY LIFE AND I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING BILL
BECAUSE THIS IS A LONG TERM
SOLUTION FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS --
WE WE WE STRUGGLE FOR A LONG
TIME I'VE BEEN A WAS CAUSING ME
TO WHAT A COMPANY FOR THE PAST
ELEVEN YEARS.
AND I ACCEPT THAT FOR MY
COMMUNITY SO WE WE COULD PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR MY
COMMUNITY AND NOW I USE YOU GUYS
TO STEP UP FOR OUR IS STATE.
WE DESERVE BETTER WE SHOULDN'T
BE DEPEND ON A WATER BOTTLE I
SUPPORT THIS TAX BECAUSE FOR US
THE TEXAS NOTHING.
BECAUSE WE SPEND HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS PAYING FOR SAFE DRINKING
WATER FOR OUR FAMILIES.
AT TAX IS NOT A PROBLEM FOR US
WE ARE THE POOREST FAMILIES AND
WE ARE WILLING TO PAY THAT TAX.
BECAUSE WE SPENT A LOT MORE
MONEY THAN THAT TAXES UP
BRINGING WATER BOTTLE FOR OUR
FAMILIES AND WE SHOULD
INDEPENDENT WHAT ABOUT --
THIS IS CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
GREAT STATE BUT THIS IS THAT THE
SAY THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE TO
BE PURCHASING WATER TO HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR THEIR
FAMILIES I'VE BEEN A MEMBER FOR
THAT.
I WHAT COALITION FOR ELEVEN
YEARS I'VE BEEN COMING TO
SACRAMENTO FOR THE PAST TEN
YEARS IN I WANT TO COME BACK TO
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU FOR
PASSING THIS FUND BILL.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA DESERVE
BETTER THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO ALL OF YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR LETTING US HAVE A
MINUTE.
MY NAME IS JOSEPHINE YET THOUGH
I ALSO COME FROM A LITTLE TOWN
THAT SERVE REAL.
I AND TULARE COUNTY I'VE LIVED
IN THAT THE TOWN FOR FIFTY YEARS.
I REYES THREE DAUGHTERS HAVE SIX
GRAND KILLS CHILDREN AND MY
CONCERN IS FOR MY GRAND CHILDREN
I'M OLD I'M GOING I'M ON MY WAY
OUT.
I WOULD LOVE TO LEAVE A LEGACY
FOR AT LEAST FOR MARKETS TO MY
GRANT KILLER CHILDREN TO LOOK
BACK ONE DAY AND SAY WE HAVE
PEOPLE IN THE CAPITAL THE CARE.
OUR ASK.
AND THE TAX IT'S MINUTES NOT
MUCH LIKE OUR MY COLLEAGUE TO
FAIR WE PAY HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS
A MONTH FOR GOOD WATER.
OUR KIDS SO OUR YOUNGER KIDS
DON'T KNOW THAT OUR WATER HOSES
CAN BE DRAGGED OUT OF OUR KIDS
ARE GETTING SICK.
WERE WE WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
COME NEXT YEAR.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR YOU GUYS TO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
WHEN I STARTED THURMOND NUMBER
ELLA MULTI STUFF?
IS AVAILABLE YET A LIST OF
SENATE STILL STANDS OKAY I
BOUGHT A BUT ALAS I WON GET THE
NUMBERS I WELL LEAN VIA THEN GO.
THE BANK YOUNG OF AB IN THE LOVE
THE MONEY THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO OAKLAND PUBLIC BLOODY.
A LET US SEE IT IS SO MY WHAT.
BUT I MEAN THEY COME FROM
ANOTHER CAN ALSO PLAY THEY'LL
SAD BUT AT THE MINE THE IF I'M
MUCH OF THIS IS AT THE BOTTOM
LINE YES THAT THE IN IT WILL
MILAN WITH WITH THE ABLE TO SO
YOU'LL BE THOUGH IT UP FOR YOU
OKAY I BUT A BUT I WOULD.
THEN IT AYE WHY LEAN VIA.
ECONOMIC A DRESS YES.
MY NAME IS RAFAEL LE I ALSO COME
FROM THE COMMUNITY OF WOODVILLE
AND WE'VE BEEN LIVING FOR MANY
MANY YEARS WITH WATER THAT WE
CAN'T DRINK SO I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT A SUSTAIN.
IN NINE FRONT TO LAY AND I'M IN
I'M IN WAS OF A SCHOOL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHEN A SERVICE NUMBER IRAQ AS ON
JUST GIVING ALL THAT ONE DOLLAR
LARA?
YEAH YEAR MAYBE THEY'LL PULL
THOSE SON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RACHAEL SANCHEZ I COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF TO LARRY AND I'VE
BEEN LIVING THERE FOR TWELVE
YEARS. FOR FALLOUT AS I SIT DOWN
WITH US ARE YOU THAT BUT I GET
BY THIS I MEAN BUT THEN IT AYE
WANTING PA SUS THE NEW.
GLASSES.
I'M HERE TO SAY IT TODAY TO SAY
PLEASE SUPPORT THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
TO HAVE SAFE WATER IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CRISIS WE'RE GONNA
PAUSE --
ONCE MORE --
TO ALLOW FOR ADD ONS.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE ONE CURRENT VOTE
FOUR ZERO CHAIR VOTING I MULLIN.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE TWO THREE SEVEN
ITEMS TO BE HEARD ISSUES TO
THROUGH FOR CURRENT VOTE. FIVE
ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE MULLIN.
ITEMS TO BE HEARD ISSUE NUMBER --
SEVEN SKEWS ME ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE FOR TWO CHAIR
VOTING I RAY YES.
ISSUE NUMBER TEN CURRENT VOTE.
SIX ZERO RAMOS.
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN CURRENT VOTE.
FIVE ZERO CHAIR VOTING I MULLIN
[inaudible]
YES.
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE CURRENT VOTE
THREE ONE CHAIR VOTING I MULLIN
[inaudible]
BRASS.
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN CURRENT
VOTE THREE ONE CHAIR VOTING AYE
MULLIN [inaudible]
RAY YES.
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN CURRENT
VOTE FIVE ZERO SURE VOTING I'D
MULLIN [inaudible]
RAY YES.
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN KERN VOTE
THREE ONE CHAIR VOTING AYE
MULLIN [inaudible]
RAY S..
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN CURRENT
BOTH THREE ONE CHAIR VOTING AYE
MULLIN [inaudible]
RAY S..
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN CURRENT
VOTE THREE TO FUTURE VOTING I AM
MULLIN [inaudible]
REYES.
ALL RIGHT YOUNG MAN EUROPE
THANKS FOR BEING PATIENT MY NAME
RIGHT AND AND I WANT ANYONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EDITOR
AND I WANT CLEAN WATER.
HI MY NAME IS RENTS KNOWN CLEAN
WATER.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOUGLAS
HAVE IT ARE I LIVING ACCIDENT
AND THIS IS AN TO LARRY.
AND MY FAMILY AND I THE BANDS
FROM AROUND I PRIVATE WELL WAS
HAVE BACK ON MARION SUPPORT TO
HAVE I FOUND TO HAVE A SAVING A
PHOTO OF A DRINKING WATER.
THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON A MEMBER AND
CHAIRS ASKED THE WHITE SEA IN
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR FREEDOM
CENTER -- WE
AT THE FREEDOM CENTER BRING
TOGETHER --
USE ADULTS COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZATIONS --
UTILIZING THE BEST PRACTICES OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT FOR A
HEALTHIER DEMOCRACY --
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL WE DO BELIEVE THAT SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
IS A HUMAN RIGHT --
WE'VE HEARD COMMENTS YOU HEARD
COMMENTS ABOUT --
THE CONCERNED THAT THIS IS A TAX --
YOU KNOW SHAME ON US IF WE ARE
IN THE TWENTIETH CENTURY --
ARE OKAY WITH KNOWING THAT THERE
ARE SOME COMMUNITIES THAT CANNOT
DRINK DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER --
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING WE
SUPPORT.
THIS PROPOSAL AND WE ASK YOU TO
DO THE SAME THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS GOOD GIGGLES
I'M WITH I'M FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE RIVERSIDE SEPARATE YOU
KNOW COUNTY.
I REPRESENT AT THE LAKE LEGAL
CENTER WHERE GRASSROOTS HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS --
THIS INITIATIVE THAT OF THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I WORK IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
WE HAVE SEEN --
THIS THE ISSUES THAT ARE NOT
JUST ONLY IMPACTING ON THE
FAMILIES BUT ALSO OUR KIDS ARE
WE'VE HAVE SEEN HOW THE
PESTICIDES IN THE WATER IN IT
THE LACK OF CLEAN WATER AND
ACCESSIBLE WATER ASKED WELL.
IS IS IT IS A HUMAN RIGHT AND WE
ARE HERE TO FULLY SUPPORT --
THIS PROPOSITION AND WE WE WE
MOBILIZED A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS
BUT I'M WE HAVE ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS THAT HAS BEEN IMPACTED
BY NOT HAVE BEEN --
GOOD WATER IN HER COMMUNITY --
THE MOMENT THAT THIS MAY I'M
AWFULLY CENTER ONE TOILET.
HE YOUR ANY FROM YOU GOTTA HOMES
AND IF HE HE UGH.
HE POURED Là SAYS YES BUT LAST
BASE TO SEATTLE BUT ALLOW WANT
ME TO MY NOW MONEY SAID LIFE
WITH THE MOST ECONOMICAL GUNS
ANY ORDERS TO LOOK AT THAT.
CRITICAL [inaudible]
COMMONSENSE.
MY NAME IS MY CELL I COME FROM
THE INLAND EMPIRE AND I'M HERE
TODAY BECAUSE IN MY COMMUNITY
THE WATER IS NOT SAFE TO DRINK --
MY COUSIN.
HER NAME IS CITY SANTA HER
SISTERS --
MIGHT HE SAID --
IT AND HER --
HER IN HER FAMILY THEY WORK IN
THE FIELDS AND THERE ARE
UNDOCUMENTED.
NOT ONLY THAT OUR WATER IS AN
ISSUE BUT ALSO HEALTHCARE --
HER SISTER DOESN'T HAVE ACCESS
TO MEDI CAL SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE
IF THERE'S A THERE'S A LOT OF
IMPACT IN A LOT OF SUFFERING
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY OF THIS IS
ONLY ONE FAMILY BUT WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF FAMILY HERE.
AND WE'RE HERE FULLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND A IN A WEEK --
JUST TO EDITORIALIZE HERE A
LITTLE BIT WE SHOULD KNOW THAT
IT'S NOT THE WATER.
THAT'S THE STANDARD WE SHOULD
LIFT BY WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
WONDER WHETHER IT'S THE WATER.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS IS
ABOUT ALL THAT AND I AM FROM
SLAVERY COUNTY IF I SELL IT
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT ARE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FIND.
WE ARE READY YOU KNOW IT IT'S
OUR RIGHT TO HAVE THAT AND NOT
WORRY AND NOT HAVE THOSE
CONCERNS FOR AND WHEN CHILDREN
ARE THOSE THAT WE ALREADY HAVE.
AND WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE
PAYING A WATER BELL AND THEN
STILL OUT OF POCKET.
FIND WATER BOTTLES TEST TO TAKE
THAT EXTRA MEASURE.
WE SHOULD ALREADY HAVE THAT
SAFETY AND THAT COME FOR AND
THAT CLOSER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ERICA HELLO OKAY.
I'M COMING AT REPRESENT IN THAT
COMMUNITY OF EAST AUTO SEE.
AND I CAN GET A LITTLE CLOSER TO
THE MIKE.
OKAY AND THE REASON WE HERE WE
NEED A SAFETY ACTING CAN.
WATER FOUND.
AS I CAN I SUCH HUMAN BEING WAIT
THEY START.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SHOULD BE
HAVE YOUNG FROM I SAY YOUR
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS VERY COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE TAX
ON THEM.
WATER SEC AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WITH MARTINEZ I AM FROM DO COR
CALIFORNIA A SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITY IN SOUTH.
EAST TULARE COUNTY --
I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER ACT AND I AM ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE DO COR COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICT WATER BOARD.
OF WE HAVE.
GOT TO COME OVER HERE AND GET
THIS THING CLEANED UP I HAVE
WORKED WITH --
FOR CLEAN WATER FOR YEARS I WAS
WITH CESAR CHAVEZ IN THE UNITED
FARMWORKERS WHEN HE WAS FIGHTING
FOR CLEAN WATER.
BECAUSE CHILDREN WERE COMING
DOWN WITH CANCER MY DAUGHTER I
LOST HER A FEW YEARS AGO BECAUSE
SHE WAS BORN WITH ONLY ONE
KIDNEY AND THE DOCTOR UCLA TOLD
ME THAT IT WAS BECAUSE OF THE
WATER.
THAT WE HAD BEEN DRINKING FOR SO
MANY YEARS THAT'S WHEN I DECIDED
TO JOIN THE CESAR CHAVEZ
FOUNDATION.
AND NOW I'M WITH THE COMMUNITIES
WATER SERVICE DISTRICT AND I I
REALLY AM.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI AND TO DO WE BORN AND RAISED
IN BY SALIA.
I'M SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
I STILL LIVE IN THE SAME SPOT MY
MOTHER TOOK ME.
TO WATER IS SACRED.
WATER IS LIFE.
AND WE ALL STARTED.
IN OUR MOTHERS WOMBS IN WATER.
I SUPPORT I SUPPORT STRONGLY
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THE CLEAN. FOR WILL DRINKING
WATER [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED ME MOZILLA MAYES?
GOOD ACTORS BECAUSE WHAT THIS
YOUNG MAN NUMBER THIS WOULD HAVE
AND THOSE THAT.
ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE TERROR IN THE COMMITTEE --
MY NAME IS WILLIAM AND ALSO.
THEN CLICK ON THEY'LL IF IT IS
NOW.
HELLO IS DELIVERED AS NOTHING
WITH THAT I'M NOT MAKING IT ONLY
THAT COMPLEXITY SELL EITHER
WHICH OF THESE THAT MONEY THAT.
HE DID YOU HAVE BEEN GOAL OF
LANDLESS GUINNESS'S YOUTH ALMOST
TWO UP ALL YOU.
GET IS THAT IS I COME FROM
FRESNO COUNTY FROM THE COMMUNITY
OF CAN TO A CREEK --
AND I COME HERE TO SAY THAT WE
NEED YOUR SUPPORT.
THIS IS A ALSO SUPPORT THEIR IN
I WORK WITH FAMILY [inaudible]
LEAVE.
A BUT IT'S JUST ACCESSIBLE BUT
I'M ALSO THROWS HIS ALMOST A NO
WIN THING RAMPARTS CANCEL.
THE ABOUT HOW IT IS THE TEMPLE.
WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT WHEN IT
COMES TO CLEAN WATER THAT WE CAN
AFFORD FOR OUR COMMUNITY --
AND WE ARE THE 99% OF WORKING
PEOPLE.
NO IS FUZZY BUT I ME IS THAT A
KEY.
THIS BILL IS ON US NUMBER OF A
JOURNALIST BUT OUR LUCK MONEY
THAT'LL CITY HERO STATUS BUT I
GET THEM IN THAT THEY MEAN THIS
UNIT'S.
HELLO THIS IS THE THAT IS THEN
ALSO DOES HE IS BUT I'M ALSO
ARGUE THAT.
HE IS BETTER BUT IT IS NOT ABOUT
THE RASCAL IN ALEPPO USES THAT
IS A SEPARATE BOYS THE GATE THEN
THE MOST BUT I I WANT. TO SEE UP
TO GET YOUR SUPPORT ON THE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FUND THANK YOU.
JUNE OF ANGER BUT THE LIST CAN
LAW SCHOOL STORY AND COURSES.
GET A SEVEN PART IS GIVEN THAT
HAS A LITTLE BIT.
ARE WILLING TO PUT ON THE
COMMUNITY.
BUT I'M MISSION.
HE PETER THIS UP FOR YOU LET'S
TALK ABOUT ESCALATING.
DOES THIS MAKE COMMENTS WHAT
THINGS YOU REFUSE.
I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO BUILD
THINGS FOR US I'M JUST ASKING
FOR CLEAN WATER FOR MY COMMUNITY --
AND I JUST HUMBLY ASK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION THANKS.
WHEN I SEVENTY NUMBER LONGER
WOMAN?
COME IN BANGOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BLANCA
GOMES.
MY MOTHER LET THAT CAN HAPPEN
WHEN ANOTHER CONTROL ON THAT THE
NAME ALSO ALLOW.
ONE COMPANY NOW THAT.
MUCH I'M ALSO FROM THE SMALL
COMMUNITY OF GOING TO A WHERE WE
HAVE CONTAMINATED WATER RESIDENT
THIS ON WHAT THE TAMBIéN THAT
CANCERS.
MANY OF THE RESIDENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY HAVE DIED OF CANCER AS
WELL.
PUT IT SO MANY MOST UP IT IS
WELL FOR YOU BUT I A LAPTOP WITH
FAMILY.
THAT'S WHY WE'VE COME TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT WHEN IT COMES TO
DRINKABLE WATER.
SO WHAT DO YOU AT THE SAME.
THAT IS AFFORDABLE AND SAFE.
YOU GET A FEEL FOR WHAT THE
SOONEST BUT I'M ALSO UP FOR YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
WE HOPE TO GAIN YOUR SUPPORT.
UGH GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MADELINE HARRIS FROM LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY UNCOMFORTABLE YOU
CAN LIFT THAT MIGHT.
THANK YOU --
I SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR A SAFE AND
pBECAUSE I THINK OF THAT AS
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WE ALL WANT
TO PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH
IS WHEN IT COMES TO THE HUMAN
RIGHT FOR WATER THAT WE'VE
DECLARED IN THE STATE --
AND I THINK THAT WE SHOULD DO
THIS -- BY
CREATING AND SUSTAINING A FUND
THAT CAN PROVIDE THAT FOR AWHILE --
USERS AND FOR COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS --
AND WE SUPPORT A DRINKING WATER
FOR DURING AN ONGOING
SUSTAINABLE FUND --
TO TO ADDRESS THIS HUMAN RIGHTS
CRISIS THANK YOU.
WHEN THE BERLIN NUMBER STADIUM
ANGLE THAT I NEED I THINK ON THE?
ONE BEING UP WE ARE NOT PROPOSAL
THAT GO IN A LOT OF FUN A A LOT
WHILE LEAN VIA SO GOOD IDEA TO
SEE VERY.
MUCH OF THE REST OF PREFER BOYS
OF VINCE YOUNG.
IT'S A LOT LESS MONEY.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SET
IN THE CITY AND I'M FROM THAT
KIND TO LET THEM FROM GOING TO A
CREEK I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNORSHIP ABOVE BUDGET
PROPOSAL ON SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING FUN THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED THIS ME NUMBER
DAYS MUSCLE IN EVERY YOUNG WOMAN
I MEAN YOU?
BANGLA ANOTHER BIG XP --
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS MARCELINE WE HAVE A
MESS AND I COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF BAKERSFIELD.
BANKRUPT OR YELLOW PROPOSED
OTHER BUT IT BUT IT'S THE BOYS
THOUGHT THAT WILL ADD ANOTHER.
I CAME -- TO
SUPPORT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL OF
THE GOVERNOR.
ESPECíFICAMENTE AN INFORMAL BUT
I ALLOW UP WITHOUT REALLY
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING FUN.
SAY WHAT I. YES SIXTY RELY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
FORGET THE ANALYSTS AS THE LAP
BUT ALASKA MONEY THAT IS THERE'S
BEEN BEHIND US BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE NEED OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
YES THIS WAS ON THE SCENE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION --
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JASMINE THE LADY Là AND ON
BEHALF OF THE SET UP --
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL ON SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING FUN BECAUSE WE WORKED
TOGETHER A LONG TIME COMMUNITIES
AND RESIDENTS --
WHO ARE AMONG THE ONE MILLION
RESIDENTS WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER?
AND SO WE'VE ALL WE SUPPORT OF
ENSURING SUSTAINABLE AN ADEQUATE
FUNDING --
TO THIS PROJECT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HAS A
SALON SO I'M --
COME FROM THE COMMUNITY OF THE
MONTH.
AND ON BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND THE LIMóN COMMUNITY --
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND --
BECAUSE WITHOUT THIS --
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE WILL
CONTINUE TO SUFFER --
BOTH FINANCIALLY AND IN THEIR
HEALTH --
DUE TO THE POOR WATER QUALITY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ALEXANDER
HUNTING WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FUND.
AS WELL AS THAT OF POLICY LINK
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
AND MI FAMILIA BOTHA THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON THE HAND
OTHER DOWN WITH THE WIDENING
GROUP HERE ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA TERM AND WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ADVOCACY AND
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE.
AND WERE HERE TO SUPPORT AND
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ON THE CREATION OF THE SIGNAL
CORPS WILL DRINKING WATER FUN
AND THE EXITE CLEAN THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LAND TROUT
NON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN AND WATER
FOUNDATION.
I HERE TO SUPPORT YOURS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S COLD LEADERSHIP AND
STICKING TO ESTABLISH A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE SO
THAT WE CAN ASSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS. TO CLEAN AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER AND FRANKLY THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
MANY OF WHOM DRIVER FOR SIX
HOURS TO COME HERE AND TALK WITH
YOU ABOUT BUT THEY'RE FACING IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AS THE
GOVERNOR HIMSELF SAD.
IT'S A DISGRACE AND THE TIME IS
NOW.
TO JENNIFER CLARY ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN WATER ACTION I WAS ASKED
TO DO A MESSAGE OF SUPPORT FOR
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION FOR PABLO FOR
PROBABLY NEED DOES AND THE
CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE.
NO SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE IT'S A COMPLETE SOLUTION
IT DOESN'T JUST COVER COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS.
LIKE BILL SUCH AS SB SIX SIX
NINE IT COVERS ALL WATER SYSTEMS
COVERS PUBLIC SCHOOLS COVERS
PEOPLE ON DOMESTIC WELLS COVER
STATE SMALL SYSTEMS SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
BECAUSE WE WANT EVERYONE TO HAVE
SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THANK YOU.
WELL WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MUCH AS A ONE MORE --
WE HEAR AS YOU'VE BEEN SO
PATIENT YOU'VE BEEN HERE --
THROUGH THE ENTIRE YEAR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND AND
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JUDY CORAL RONALD I
AM A VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
BIGHORN DOES IF YOU WATER BOARD
IN.
THE HIGH DESERT.
OVERLOOKING TWENTY NINE PALMS
MILITARY BASE --
OUR COMMUNITY IS A 100%
DISADVANTAGE.
AND WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
SB.
SIX SIX NINE WITH AMENDMENTS HAS
TO BE AMENDED AS OF MISTER TAKE
THEIR SUGGESTED IS OF EXCUSE ME.
IT WAS VERY FRUSTRATING FOR US
WE ARE I'VE BEEN ON THE BOARD
SINCE I WAS.
SIX AND DURING THAT TIME WE
APPLIED FOR WOULDN'T WHEN IT
CAME AROUND PROP.
ONE AND WE WERE SUPPOSEDLY.
ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND WE PAID FOR A GRANT WRITER
TO WRITE THE GRANT AND NOW COME
DOWN TO TIME --
WELL WE CERTAINLY DON'T RANK.
SO WE WASTED ALL THAT MONEY
WE'VE WASTED THREE YEARS.
WHEN?
THE PRICE OF EVERYTHING HAS GONE
UP WE COULD A SELF FUNDED AS AS
WE WENT ALONG KNOWING MISTER.
AND SO THAT'S PART OF THE THAT'S
PART OF THE AMENDMENT IT NEEDS
TO BE IN THIS.
AND THEN WE WERE OF WE HAD A
NEIGHBORING SOLID EVEN WITH.
THE OF THEY WERE INCREASING
THEIR WATER RATES BY 20% A YEAR
FOR THREE YEARS I HAD A LADY
COME UP TO ME AND SAY.
LOOK I'M ON SOCIAL SECURITY.
I GET FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH.
SHE SAID I COULD EITHER WATER MY
ANIMALS OR BATES AND SHE SAYS
I'M SORRY IF I SMELL BAD AND I
CRIED.
SO THIS IS A CONNECTING WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT BUT IT'S BY SLAPPING
ATTACKS OF PEOPLE'S WATER WHICH
IS SHOULD.
JUST.
I'M FOR SB.
SB SIX SIX NINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR PATIENCE YOU COULD HAVE --
BEEN FIRST IN LINE BUT CHIU
DEFERRED TO EVERYONE ELSE THAT
WAS -- VERY
VERY KIND OF YOU --
SO -- THANK
YOU AND EVERYONE WHO SPOKE --
CLEARLY THE INTEREST IN THIS
ISSUE WAS ONLY INTENSIFIED I
NOTE DIRECTOR ESCROW BILL YOU --
ARE NO STRANGER TO THIS ISSUE --
AND I KNOW YOU'LL BE NO STRANGER --
TO TO THIS TO THIS COMMITTEE --
PERHAPS YOU WANT TO ADD SOME
BECAUSE SOME COMMENTS NOW
REGARDING.
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM PUBLIC
COMMENT I I WOULD ASK --
IF WE WERE EARLIER AND OUT OF
TIME HERE BUT AND THERE THERE
MAY BE OTHER OTHER QUESTIONS FOR
IF WE COULD TAKE THEM QUICKLY
THAT WOULD BE.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT --
BUT IF YOU COULD SPEND JUST A
MOMENT -- OF
REFLECTING ON IT WITH THE KIND
OF IN A WEEK.
WE'VE BEEN --
ON THIS ISSUE FOR SO LONG --
WHICH KIND OF HEARD IT ALL TO
SAY THAT DISPARAGINGLY ABOUT ANY
ANYBODY'S POSITION OR OR OR
COMMENTS BUT THE ONE NEW THING
THAT I HEARD TODAY AND AND WE
MET WITH SOME OF THESE FOLKS IN
MY OFFICE YESTERDAY --
WERE FOLKS FROM THE LARGER WATER
DISTRICTS --
BUT THEY'RE ALSO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND WHO FEEL THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SOME ISSUES --
IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE LEFT OUT
OF THIS IF YOU COULD.
TO JUST TOUCH ON THIS WE ARE NOT
GOING TO FINISH THIS ISSUE TODAY
IT WAS ALWAYS PLAN TO BE --
HOLD OPEN --
BUT THIS IS A AND IN MY VIEW
HAVING ALL OF YOU HERE --
AND PROVIDING YOUR COMMENTS AND
SHOWING US HOW MUCH.
INTEREST THERE IS IN THIS ISSUE
IS A GREAT WAY TO START OFF --
ARE ARE A BUDGET CYCLE.
ARE AT LEAST ARE A CYCLE THE ON
THIS --
PARTICULAR --
AREA.
I APPRECIATE THAT SURE BLOOM
YEAH THE THE AMOUNT OF OF
ATTENTION AND CERTAINLY IT'S
BEEN BUILDING OVER THE LAST
YEARS RIGHT --
AS I ARTICULATED MY COMMENTS THE
INTEREST OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
SOLVE THIS ISSUE TO GIVE US
ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO BRING THE
DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER TO
THE STATE BOARD.
SHOWS OF A REAL STRONG.
THE EVOLUTION OF THIS DISCUSSION
WE'RE KINDA HERE AT THIS LAST
PIECE WHEN IT COMES TO OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE AND THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF DISAGREEMENT
FROM.
FOLKS OUT THERE AROUND THAT
PARTICULAR TOOL WHEN IT COMES TO
THOUGH THE SIZE OF AGENCY THE
WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
RESOURCES.
THE YOU KNOW I I WOULD QUICKLY
TO GET OVER TO DARREN JUST.
TO DODD GROUND TRUTH YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THE WHAT IS THE
LIMITATION ON WHO CAN THEN
RECEIVE THESE SORTS OF DOLLARS --
IS THERE IN WHAT IS THE IS THERE
A POPULATION CAP THAT WERE WERE
CONTEMPLATING I NEED TO DOUBLE
CHECK ON THAT SO.
I WOULD ASK YOU TO BE AS BRIEF
AS POSSIBLE GIVEN THE THE THE
TIME -- AND
ALL -- TO
MAKE TIME AND WHOEVER WHOEVER
THE APPROPRIATE PERSON IS TO
MAKE TIME IN YOUR SCHEDULE TO
MEET WITH THESE FOLKS SO THAT --
IF THERE'S A MISUNDERSTANDING
THAT CAN BE CLEARED UP --
THIS IS AN ISSUE TO BE HEARD I
THE ONLY THERE IN IN ALL
FAIRNESS IT'S A IT'S A COMPLEX
ISSUE ON WHO QUALIFIES UNDER
WHICH FUNDING IT'S PROBABLY
BETTER TO HAVE A MUCH LONGER
CONVERSATION THAN.
TO DO IT HERE BUT IT IS AN ISSUE
WE ALWAYS WORK ON AND AND LOOK
TO THE BOARD'S POLICIES TO
MODIFY ALL THE TIME OKAY THEN
I'LL SIMPLY LEAVE IT AS SEC --
ASKING YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S FOLLOW UP BOTH WITH THE
ADVOCATES ON THAT PART OF THE
ISSUE -- AND
WITHOUT MY STAFF [inaudible]
MS REYES. EIGHT I I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO THOSE
WHO CAME TO GIVE PLOT PUBLIC
COMMENT.
I THINK TO HAVE PEOPLE FROM
RIVERSIDE FROM SUMMER TO DINO
FROM TO LAURIE COUNTY AND FROM
SAID THE OTHER AREAS THAT ARE
MOST AFFECTED FROM COACHELLA.
THAT IS EXTREMELY WE HAVE THAT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT IF THEY ARE
HERE.
AND THEY HAVE TAKEN THE TIME. TO
GET ON THAT BUS AND THE ON THAT
BUS FOR SIX HOURS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR VOICES HEARD.
WE'VE GOT TO HEAR THE VOICE.
OF ONE OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY
ONE OF THE THE SPEAKERS WATER IS
LIFE.
NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
AND IT WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
AND THE FACT THAT IN CALIFORNIA
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY WE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO CANNOT DRINK
THEIR WATER.
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T EVEN BABY THE
IN THEIR WATER.
OR SOMETHING.
ABSOLUTELY WRONG AND MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP NOT JUST NOW BUT
YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE YOU HAVE NOT.
ALLOWED IT TO BE JUST A SIMPLE
ANSWER YOU HAVE ASKED FOR THE
THE THE HOW YOU ASK THE HARD
QUESTIONS AND I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT ON BEHALF OF
THOSE ESPECIALLY THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
BUT I WAS GIVING YOU DON'T KNOW
A LOT OF IT IS ALWAYS AS GOOD
ASK YES BUT I WOULD BE A NEEDLE.
HE IS STATIC YOU CAN ALSO JUST
BUT I I SAID WOULD ADD GUESS WHO
LOS SET OUT --
EITHER GIVE US SUCH AS THAT WAS
A KEY BUT YOU LOS IT DIDN'T LOOK
AT THE MODELS IN CUENTA GLASSES
BUT I WOULD JUST OTHER MCKEE.
THANK IT'S A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE ALL --
I SHOULD BE BEARING ON OUR
SHOULDERS AND AND TO HI --
WOULD BE FOOLISH --
BASED ON THE HISTORY OF THIS
ISSUE -- TO
MAKE.
PROMISES ABOUT WE'RE GONNA END
UP A AT THE END OF THE CYCLE BUT
I WILL COMMIT TO DOING MY TO
BRING THIS TO A CONCLUSION --
IN THIS LEGISLATIVE CYCLE --
AND WITH THAT I THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING PATIENT FOR STICKING
WITH US THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
HEARING AND TO WE ARE WE HAVE NO
MORE ADD ONS RIGHT.
THIS MISTER.
ALL RIGHT --
WE ARE ADJOURNED